hi everyone
welcome you all to this machine learning
engineer full course video by simply
learn
in this video you will learn all the
important skills that will help you
become a successful machine learning
expert
you will look at the algorithms used by
machine learning engineers with hands-on
demonstrations in python
before i begin make sure to subscribe to
the simply learn channel to learn
interesting tech videos
so we will start with a short video to
understand machine learning in two
minutes and look at the top 10
applications of machine learning we will
see the machine learning roadmap for
2021 and learn the roles and
responsibilities of a machine learning
engineer
we will then see the difference between
machine learning versus deep learning
versus artificial intelligence
next we will understand the various
mathematical concepts and crucial
algorithms used in machine learning
so we will learn about linear regression
analysis logistic regression decision
tree support vector machines as well as
k-means clustering we will also focus on
principal component analysis
regularization machine learning feature
selection reinforcement learning as well
as q learning
finally we will look at the resume of a
machine learning engineer and learn the
top machine learning interview questions
that are often asked
so let's get started
sci-fi movies and books depict a future
with sentinel machines capable of
interacting with humans and performing
tasks just like people would
what if we told you that this future is
already a reality all of this is already
made possible by machine learning
machine learning is the science of
programming machines to think and act
like humans without being specifically
programmed to we already use machine
learning in our daily life without
knowing it email spam recognition spell
check even the youtube video
recommendation which brought you here
are implemented using machine learning
machine learning uses algorithms to
learn tasks these algorithms are fed
with data from which they learn to
perform these tasks this means that over
time as changes in data occur we don't
need to reprogram our application just
let it find patterns and learn from the
new data
machine learning is a subset of
artificial intelligence which is a
science concerned with imparting
human-like intelligence onto machines
and creating machines which can sense
reason act and adapt
deep learning is a sub-branch of machine
learning which is inspired by the
working of the human brain
machine learning is leading us to a
future where machines can learn and
think and has opened us a whole new
plethora of job opportunities
this was a brief intro to machine
learning machine learning has improved
our lives in a number of wonderful ways
today let's talk about some of these i'm
rahul from simply learn and these are
the top 10 applications of machine
learning first let's talk about virtual
personal assistants google assistant
alexa cortana and siri now we've all
used one of these at least at some point
in our lives now these help improve our
lives in a great number of ways for
example you could tell them to call
someone you could tell them to play some
music you could tell them to even
schedule an appointment so how do these
things actually work first they record
whatever you're saying send it over to a
server which is usually in a cloud
decode it with the help of machine
learning in neural networks and then
provide you with an output so if you
ever notice that these systems don't
work very well without the internet
that's because the server couldn't be
contacted next let's talk about traffic
predictions now say i wanted to travel
from buckingham palace to large cricket
ground the first thing i would probably
do is to get on google maps so
search it
and let's put it here
so here we have the path you should take
to get to large cricket ground now here
the map is a combination of red yellow
and blue now the blue regions signify a
clear road that is you won't encounter
traffic there the yellow indicate that
they are slightly congested and red
means they're heavily congested so let's
look at the map a different version of
the same map and here as i told you
before red means heavily congested
yellow means slow moving and blue means
clear so how exactly is google able to
tell you that the traffic is clear slow
moving or heavily congested so this is
the help of machine learning and with
the help of two important measures first
is the average time that's taken on
specific days at specific times on that
route the second one is the real-time
location data of vehicles from google
maps and with the help of sensors some
of the other popular map services are
bing maps maps dot me and here we go
next up we have social media
personalization so say i want to buy a
drone and i'm on amazon and i want to
buy a dji mavic pro the thing is it's
close to one lap so i don't want to buy
it right now but the next time i'm on
facebook i'll see an advertisement for
the product next time i'm on youtube
i'll see an advertisement even on
instagram i'll see an advertisement so
here with the help of machine learning
google has understood that i'm
interested in this particular product
hence it's targeting me with these
advertisements this is also with the
help of machine learning let's talk
about email spam filtering now this is a
spam that's in my inbox now how does
gmail know what spam and what's not spam
so gmail has an entire collection of
emails which have already been labeled
as spam or not spam so after analyzing
this data gmail is able to find some
characteristics like the word lottery or
winner from then on any new email that
comes to your inbox goes through a few
spam filters to decide whether it's spam
or not now some of the popular spam
filters that gmail uses is content
filters header filters general blacklist
filters and so on next we have online
fraud detection now there are several
ways that online fraud can take place
for example there's identity theft where
they steal your identity fake accounts
where these accounts only last for how
long the transaction takes place and
stop existing after that and man in the
middle attacks where they steal your
money while the transaction is taking
place the feed forward neural network
helps determine whether a transaction is
genuine or fraudulent so what happens
with feed forward neural networks are
that the outputs are converted into hash
values and these values become the
inputs for the next round so for every
real transaction that takes place
there's a specific pattern a fraudulent
transaction would stand out because of
the significant changes that it would
cause with the hash values stock market
trading machine learning is used
extensively when it comes to stock
market trading now you have stock market
indices like nikai they use long short
term memory neural networks now these
are used to classify process and predict
data when there are time lags of unknown
size and duration now this is used to
predict stock market trends assistive
medical technology now medical
technology has been innovated with the
help of machine learning diagnosing
diseases has been easier from which we
can create 3d models that can predict
where exactly there are lesions in the
brain it works just as well for brain
tumors and ischemic stroke lesions they
can also be used in fetal imaging and
cardiac analysis now some of the medical
fields that machine learning will help
assist in is disease identification
personalized treatment drug discovery
clinical research and radiology and
finally we have automatic translation
now say you're in a foreign country and
you see billboards and signs that you
don't understand that's where automatic
translation comes of help now how does
automatic translation actually work the
technology behind it is the same as the
sequence of sequence learning which is
the same thing that's used with chatbots
here the image recognition happens using
convolutional neural networks and the
text is identified using optical
character recognition furthermore the
sequence to sequence algorithm is also
used to translate the text from one
language to the other ai and machine
learning have been the top burst words
in 2020. machine learning can be an
interesting career move for programmers
developers and other professionals
looking for a script in their career
over the last few years machine learning
and artificial intelligence together
have become a crucial component in many
of the world's most popular business
applications
as we approach 2021 it's a good time for
us to take a look at the machine
learning roadmap for 2021.
in this video
we will discuss the basics of machine
learning and the companies actively
hiring for machine learning roles you
will understand the skills required to
become a machine learning expert in 2021
the salary of a machine learning
engineer and how simply learn can help
you get certified in machine learning
now let's look at what machine learning
is
machine learning is an application of
artificial intelligence that allows
systems to learn from vast volumes of
data
it enables you to process analyze and
train machines using data and create
models to solve business problems
machine learning has the potential to
learn from structured semi-structured
and unstructured data
there are various supervised
unsupervised and reinforcement learning
algorithms used to build machine
learning models
some of the most popular machine
learning algorithms are linear
regression logistic regression support
vector machines k-nearest neighbors
k-means clustering knife base and others
now some of the top companies hiring for
machine learning roles are microsoft
spotify google cell
ericsson oracle and walmart
there are numerous product based service
based as well as startup companies that
are hiring for machine learning
positions now learning machine learning
can position an individual for a variety
of exciting careers in a growing number
of industries
with machine learning becoming more
widely accepted and adapted technology
let's look at the important skills you
need to know to become a machine
learning expert in 2021
first we have programming machine
learning mostly depends on algorithms
which means one should possess sound
knowledge of different programming
languages such as python and r
you should have knowledge of basic
programming concepts and understand data
structures this will help you write
better and efficient codes you should
also know about searching sorting and
optimization algorithms the second skill
you need to know is mathematics and
statistics
statistics is the backbone of data
analytics you should have knowledge of
various measures such as mean median
variance etc distribution such as
uniform normal binomial poison etc and
analysis methods such as anova manova
t-test chi-square test hypothesis
testing and others
now this is required for building and
validating models from observed data a
basic understanding of high school
mathematics will help you understand how
machine learning algorithms work
the topics include probability linear
algebra and calculus the third skill you
need to know is database and sql
very often machine learning tasks are
carried out using data stored in the
form of tables that are present in
database servers
so it's important to know about
databases and sql good understanding of
relational databases and nosql databases
such as mysql postgresql oracle database
microsoft sql server is vital to store
manipulate retrieve and handle
structured data now we have data
wrangling
now there's a lot of pre-processing of
data that is needed before you start
building your machine learning model
collecting the data cleaning it
identifying the problems asking the
right questions and formatting the data
are crucial steps in machine learning
you should have knowledge of libraries
and packages such as numpy pandas plier
deep flyer and idea to perform data
wrangling next we have data
visualization while working on any
machine learning problem it's important
to understand the data well
data visualization and exploratory data
analysis skills are very important to
show the hidden trends and insights in a
visual form using various charts and
graphs this will help you find out
unseen patterns in the data
you need to have experience with
matplotlib c-bond plotly and ggplot
libraries
it would be an advantage to know bi
tools such as tableau and power bi
finally
the most important skill is machine
learning itself
you need to learn different machine
learning techniques and algorithms that
are widely used to solve business
problems
then implement the algorithms using
python and r libraries such as
scikit-learn tensorflow garrett and mlr
having knowledge of natural language
processing computer vision and time
series analysis would be a really good
advantage
to gain more experience in solving real
world problems you need to work on small
projects using variety of data sets
data science and machine learning
challenges such as those on github and
kegel are a great way to get exposed to
different kinds of problems and their
nuances now talking about the salary of
a machine learning engineer
according to glassdoor in the united
states a machine learning engineer can
earn around 114 thousand dollars per
annum
while in india you can earn nearly 7
lakh 73 000 rupees per annum
this salary may vary based on your
experience the industry you are applying
for and the company policy now moving on
to the final section
let me tell you how simply learn can
help you start your career in machine
learning
so let me take you to our website first
okay so i am on the chrome browser
let me search for simplylearn.com
and here
under what you want to learn let me type
machine learning it will show me the
relevant courses that simply learn
offers
in the machine learning category
so you can see here there are multiple
courses
first let me open the
first link
and let's open the second link as well
so
so this is the postgraduate program in
ai and machine learning which is in
collaboration with purdue university and
ibm
if i scroll down
you can see the key features of this
course
so we'll get purdue alumni association
membership
industry recognized ibm certificates
enrollment to simply launch job assist
there's 25 plus hands-on projects on gpu
enabled labs you have
450 plus hours of applied learning
caption projects in three domains
and much more
and here you can see on the right this
is the certificate that you will get
after completing this program
and you will also get
certificates recognized by ibm
and another key feature of this course
is you can enroll to simply learn job
assist program so you will get im jobs
crew membership for six months resume
assistance and career monitoring there's
interview preparation and career affairs
if i scroll further here you can see the
learning path
and you will learn about python for data
science
this machine learning
deep learning with tensorflow and keras
that's advanced deep learning and
computer vision you will also learn
about natural language processing that
is nlp and speech recognition
we have reinforcement learning
and you also have the opportunity to
select a few electives so we have ibm
watson for chatbots machine learning
with r there's git and github training
and two others
here you can see
the skills that will be covered so you
will learn about statistics which is a
core component of machine learning we
learn about python supervised learning
there's dance computer vision tensorflow
there's reinforcement learning speech
recognition you will also learn about
numpy pandas and other libraries
and here you can see these are some of
the tools that will be covered in this
course
if i scroll further now this is the
important section you can see the
industry projects that you will get to
work on
so this is
on twitter there's one on zumato one on
uber
and mercedes benz as well
now they are our course advisors
so please go ahead and enroll to this
postgraduate program in ai machine
learning if you want to kick start your
career in
machine learning
now the next course we have is machine
learning certification course if i
scroll down you can see the details of
this course
so you will gain expertise with 25 plus
hands-on exercises you will get to work
on four real-life industry-based
projects with integrated labs there will
be dedicated mentoring sessions from
industry experts 44 hours of
instructor-led training with
certification
here on the right you can see the skills
that will be covered
so we learn about time series modeling
linear and logistic regression you will
also learn about support vector machines
games clustering knife base decision
trees
random forest
and you learn the concepts of bagging
and boosting and deep learning
fundamentals as well
here you can see the
course content
and if i scroll further now these are
the projects that you'll get to work on
and finally you'll receive this
certificate once you complete the course
who is a machine learning engineer a
machine learning engineer is someone who
performs the following tasks develops
and implements production-ready
algorithms and methods this is a very
difficult challenge because we talk
about production ready that's a key word
in here this is something that's going
to be pushed out to end users to be able
to use whether it's a bank doing their
finances or your
new cell phone where it's doing some
kind of image adjustment and adding in
virtual images or stamps onto the
picture code evolves machine learning
solutions with data scientists and
engineers so you're going to be working
as a team the data scientists are going
to be developing this and then you're
going to be implementing it provides
technical guidance to product teams on
the choice of machine learning
approaches appropriate for the task
machine learning engineers will design
implement and ship new algorithms
provides architectural guidance on
changing prototypes to high performance
production models and provides feedback
on tools and new features required to
send it back to the development teams so
let's dig a little deeper into the
responsibilities of a machine learning
engineer they study and transform data
science prototypes design machine
learning systems implement machine
learning algorithms develop machine
learning applications
select appropriate data sets that is so
huge in the machine learning engineer is
how do you get these data sets in there
and how do you use appropriate ones and
that's going to go back and forth to
your data scientists as a machine
learning engineer you want to be able to
recommend stuff for them and then they
got to go back and prototype it and then
it comes back to you to put it together
and start training these neural networks
perform statistical analysis and
fine-tuning and train and retrain
systems when necessary and that's also
another big one because there's a lot of
upkeep on these if you've ever seen the
evolution of any of the current
ais out there from google voice to
all the different picture programs and
everything there's a continual
retraining of these systems going on and
they continually improve so they're not
just rebuilding the whole thing from the
bottom up sometimes they're just
retraining them to get a better response
simply learn welcomes you to machine
learning versus deep learning versus
artificial intelligence some of the most
exciting technologies evolving in
today's world
my name is richard kirschner and i'll be
hosting this talk or simply learn
before we start covering the basics of
these three topics and how they connect
and how they are different let's just
look at a few examples so we get an
understanding of what's going on
here's an example of artificial
intelligence in today's world amazon
echo
amazon echo is a wonderful tool we can
go in there and you can say hey alexa
what's the temperature in chicago
and the amazon echo then translates that
into zeros and ones and something the
computer understands
then it comes in and processes that
information to identify what you're
asking and what you need and where to
get that information and then it comes
back and says the current temperature in
chicago is six degrees fahrenheit or
whatever it is at the moment
so this is a wonderful example of
artificial intelligence that we're using
right now today where that's at as far
as a commercial deployment
machine learning a machine learning
example out there is google you're on
your google search engine it comes up
you spend a lot of time on the first
link you come into and you read the page
and
google looks at that and says okay he
spent five minutes on this let's give it
a thumbs up
and then you go to the second page and
the third page you just kind of skip
over them and glance at them for a
couple seconds and google says i wasn't
interested in those pages let's give
them a thumbs down
so this is a good example of machine
learning is it starts guessing what you
like and what you don't like so it gives
you more information along what you're
going to read and actually use
and then we have an example of deep
learning
in this example we have a black and
white image
it comes into in this case a neural
network
some people like to call it a magic box
because you really it's hard to follow
all that's going on in there there's all
these different weights and connections
and nodes
and then it comes out
and colors the beach ball the people the
background
what's going on in here is the black and
white image goes into this neural
network and before it's ever gone in
the neural network has looked at all
these different pictures on the web or
wherever it pulls the data from
and it's already itemized them and kind
of separated them that we have some that
look like beach balls we have some that
look like people and it programs that so
that when the black and white image
comes in it goes okay that piece right
there
resembles this and all these other
photos
and the network is able to identify that
and then color the beach ball with the
colors uh that you see on there so it
gives it a full this is really wonderful
because they did a wonderful job
coloring this picture
and that's the full setup is where the
deep learning example comes in and they
usually center around neural networks
so we looked at a few examples what's in
it for you
first we're going to talk about human
versus artificial intelligence
this is very important because this is
our marker we as humans are amazing and
so we want to understand how artificial
intelligence compares
and what it does that it can accelerate
above humans and how it can integrate
with the human experience
what is machine learning and deep
learning all about
are they really all that different
we'll have a few more examples in here
and then we'll talk a little bit about
types of ai and machine learning and
comparing machine learning and deep
learning and finally a glimpse into the
future
human versus artificial intelligence
humans are amazing let's just face it
we're amazing creatures we're all over
the planet we're exploring
every nic chinook we've gone to the moon
uh we've gone into outer space we're
just amazing creatures
we're able to use the available
information to make decisions to
communicate with other people identify
patterns and data remember what people
have said adapt to new situations so
let's take a look at this so we so you
can get a picture you're a human being
so you know it's like to be human let's
take a look at artificial intelligence
versus the human artificial intelligence
develops computer systems that can
accomplish texts that require human
intelligence
so we're looking at this
one of the things that computers can do
they can provide more accurate results
this is very important
recently i did a project on
cancer whereas identifying markers
and as a human being you look at that
and you might be looking at all the
different images and the data that comes
off of them and say i like this person
so i want to give them a very good
outlook and the next person you might
not like so you want to give a bad
outlook well with artificial
intelligence you're going to get a
consistent prediction of what's going to
come out interacts with humans using
their natural language we've seen that
as probably the biggest development
feature right now that's in the
commercial market that everybody gets to
use as we saw with the example of alexa
they learn from their mistakes and adapt
to new environments so we see this
slowly coming in more and more and they
learn from the data and automate
repetitive learning
has a lot to do with the neural networks
you have to program thousands upon
thousands of pictures in there and it's
all automated so as today's computers
evolve it's very quick and easy and
affordable to do this
what is machine learning and deep
learning all about
imagine this say you had some time to
waste not that any of us really have a
lot of time anymore to just waste in
today's world and you're sitting by the
road and you have a whole lot and a
whole lot of time passes by there's a
few hours
and suddenly you wonder
how many cars buses trucks and so on
passed by in the six hours
now chances are you're not going to sit
by the road for six hours and count
buses cars and trucks unless you're
working for the city and you're trying
to do city planning and you want to know
hey do we need to add a new truck route
maybe we need a bicycle length we have a
lot of bicyclists here that kind of
thing so maybe city planning would be
great for this
machine learning well the way machine
learning works is we
have labeled data with features
okay so you have a truck or a car a
motorcycle a bus or a bicycle and each
one of those are labeled
it comes in and based on those labels
and comparing those features it gives
you an answer it's a bicycle it's a
truck it's a motorcycle this is a little
bit more in depth on this and the model
here it actually the features we're
looking at would be like the tires
someone sits there and figures out what
a tire looks like it takes a lot of work
if you try to try to figure the
difference between a car tire a bicycle
tire a motorcycle tire
so in the machine learning field this
could take a long time if you're going
to do each individual
aspect of a car
and try to get a result on there and
that's what they did do there was a very
this is still used on smaller amounts of
data where you figure out what those
features are and then you label them
deep learning so with deep learning
one of our solutions is to take a very
large unlabeled data set
and we put that into a training model
using artificial neural networks
and then that goes into the neural
network itself when we create a neural
network and you'll see uh the arrows are
actually kind of backward but which
actually is a nice point because when we
train the neural network
we put the bicycle in and then it comes
back and says if it's a truck it comes
back and says well you need to change
that to bicycle and then it changes all
those weights going backward they call
it back propagation
and let it know it's a bicycle and
that's how it learns
once you've trained the neural network
you then put the new data in and they
call this testing the model so you need
to have some data you've kept off to the
side where you know the answer to and
you take that and you provide the
required output and you say okay is this
is this neural network working correctly
did it identify a bike as a bike a truck
as a truck a motorcycle as a motorcycle
let's just take a little closer look at
that
determining what objects are present in
the data so how does deep learning do
this and here we have the image of the
bike
it's 28 by 28 pixels that's a lot of
information there could you imagine
trying to guess that this is a bicycle
image by looking at each one of those
pixels and trying to figure out what's
around it and we actually do that as
human beings it's pretty amazing we know
what a bicycle is and even though it
comes in as all this information and
what this looks like is the image comes
in
it converts it into a bunch of different
nodes in this case there's a lot more
than what they show here and it goes
through these different layers and out
comes and says okay this is a bicycle
a lot of times they call this the magic
black box why because as we watch it go
across here
all these weights and all the math
behind this and it's not it's a little
complicated on the math side you really
don't need to know that when you're
programming or doing working with the
deep learning but it's like magic you
don't know you really can't figure out
what's going to come out by looking
what's in each one of those dots and
each one of those lines are firing and
what's going in between them so we like
to call it the magic box uh so that's
where deep learning comes in
and in the end it comes up and you have
this whole neural network comes up and
says okay
we fire all these different pixels and
we connects all these different dots
and gives them different weights and
says okay this is a bicycle and that's
how we determine what the object is
present in the data with deep learning
machine learning we're going to take a
step into machine learning here and
you'll see how these fit together in a
minute the system is able to make
predictions or take decisions based on
past data that's very important for
machine learning is that we're
looking at stuff and based on what's
been there before we're creating a
decision on there we're creating
something out of there we're coloring a
beach ball we're telling you what the
weather is
in chicago
what's nice about machine learning is a
very powerful processing capability it's
quick and accurate outcomes
so you get results right away once you
program the system the results are very
fast
and the decisions and predictions are
better they're more accurate they're
consistent
you can analyze very large amounts of
data
some of these data things that they're
analyzing now are petabytes and
terabytes of data it would take
hundreds of people
hundreds of years to go through some of
this data and do the same thing that the
machine learning can do in a very short
period of time and it's inexpensive
compared to hiring hundreds of people so
it becomes a very affordable way to move
into the future is to apply the machine
learning
to whatever businesses you're working on
and deep learning systems think and
learn like humans using artificial
neural networks again it's like a magic
box performance improves with more data
so the more data the deep learning gets
the more it gives you better results
it's scalability so you can scale it up
you can scale it down you can increase
what you're looking at
currently you know we're limited by the
amount of computer processing power as
to how big that can get but that
envelope continually gets pushed every
day on what it can do
problem solved in an end-to-end method
so instead of having to break it apart
and you have the first piece coming in
and you identify tires and the second
piece is identifying
labeling handlebars and then you bring
that together that if it has handlebars
and tires it's a bicycle and if it has
something that looks like a large square
it's probably a truck the neural
networks does this all in one network
you don't really know what's going on in
all those weights and all those little
bubbles
but it does it pretty much
in one package that's why the neural
network systems are so big nowadays and
coming in to their own
best features are selected by the system
and it this is important they kind of
put it's on a bullet on the side here
it's a subset of machine learning this
is important
we talk about deep learning it is a form
of machine learning there's lots of
other forms of machine learning data
analysis but this is the newest and
biggest thing that they apply to a lot
of different packages and they use all
the other machine learning tools
available to work with it
and it's very fast to test
you put in your information
you then have your group of tests
and then you held some aside you see how
does it do it's very quick to test it
and see what's going on with your deep
learning in your neural network
are they really all that different
ai versus machine learning versus deep
learning
concepts of ai
so we have concepts of iii you'll see
natural language processing
machine learning an approach to create
artificial intelligence so it's one of
the subsets of artificial intelligence
knowledge representation automated
reasoning computer vision
robotics
machine learning versus ai versus deep
learning or ai and machine learning and
deep learning
so we look at this we have ai with
machine learning and deep learning
and so we're going to put them all
together we find out that ai is the big
picture we have a collection of books
it goes through some deep learning
the digital data is analyzed text mining
comes through
the particular book you're looking for
maybe it's a genre books is identified
and in this case we have a robot that
goes and gives a book to the patron i
have yet to be at a library that has a
robot bring me a book but that will be
cool when it happens
as we look at some of the pieces here
this information goes into
there's as far as this example
the translation of the handwritten
printed data to digital form
that's pretty hard to do that's pretty
hard to go in there and translate
hundreds and hundreds of books and
understand what they're trying to
say
if you've never read them so in this
case we use the deep learning because
you can already use examples where
they've already classified a lot of
books and then they can compare those
texts and say oh okay this is a book on
automotive repair this is a book on
robotic building the digital data is in
analyzed then we have more text mining
using machine learning so maybe we'd use
a different program to do a basic
classify
what you're looking for and say oh
you're looking for
auto repair and computers so you're
looking for automated cars once it's
identified then of course it brings you
the book
so here's a nice summation of what we
were just talking about ai with machine
learning and deep learning deep learning
is a subset of machine learning which is
a subset of artificial intelligence
so you can look at artificial
intelligence as the big picture how does
this compare to the human experience
in either doing the same thing as a
human we do
or it
does it better than us
and machine learning which has a lot of
tools
is something that learns from data past
experiences it's programmed it's uh
comes in there and it says hey we
already had these five things happen the
sixth one should be about the same and
then there's a lot of tools in machine
learning but deep learning then is a
very specific tool in machine learning
it's the artificial neural network which
handles large amounts of data and is
able to take huge pools
of experiences pictures and ideas and
bring them together
real life examples
artificial intelligence news generation
very common nowadays as it goes through
there and finds the news articles or
generates the news based upon the news
feeds
or the back end coming in and says okay
let's give you the actual news based on
this there's all the different things
amazon echo they have a number of
different prime music on there of course
there's also the
google command and there's also
cortana there's tons of smart home
devices now where we can ask it to turn
the tv on or play music for us that's
all artificial intelligence from front
to back
you're having a human experience
with these computers and these
objects that are connected to the
processing machine learning uh spam
detection very common machine learning
doesn't really have the human
interaction part
so this is the part where it goes and
says okay that's a spam that's not a
spam and it puts it in your spam folder
search engine result refining
another example of machine learning
whereas it looks at your different
results and it go and it is able to
categorize them as far as i said the
most hits this is the least viewed this
has five stars you know however they
want to weight it
all exactly good examples of machine
learning and then the deep learning
deep learning another example is as you
have like a exit sign
in this case is translating it into
french
sorti i hope i said that right
neural network has been programmed with
all these different words and images and
so it's able to look at the exit in the
middle and it goes okay we want to know
what that is in french and it's able to
push that out in france french and learn
how to do that
and then we have chat bots
i remember when microsoft first had
their little paper clip um boy that was
like a long time ago they came up and
you would type in there and chat with it
these are growing you know it's nice to
just be able to ask a question and it
comes up and gives you the answer
and instead of it being were you just
doing a search on certain words it's now
able to start linking those words
together and form a sentence in that
chat box
types of ai and machine learning
types of artificial intelligence this in
the next few slides are really important
so one of the types of artificial
intelligence is reactive machines
systems that only react they don't form
memories they don't have past
experiences they have something that
happens to them and they react to it
my washing machine is one of those
if i put a ton of clothes in it and it
all clumped on one side
it automatically adds a weight to
recenter it so that my washing machine
is actually a reactive machine working
with whatever the load is and keeps it
nice and so when it spins it doesn't go
thumping against the side
limited memory another form of
artificial intelligence
systems look into the past
information is added over a period of
time and information is short-lived
when we're talking about this and you
look at like a neural network that's
been programmed to identify cars
it doesn't remember all those pictures
it has no memory as far as the hundreds
of pictures you process through it all
it has is this is the pattern i use to
identify cars as the final output for
that neural network we looked at
so when they talk about limited memory
this is what they're talking about
they're talking about i've created this
based on all these things but i'm not
going to remember anyone specifically
theory of mind systems being able to
understand human emotions and how they
affect decision making to adjust their
behaviors according to their human
understanding
this is important because this is our
page mark this is how we know whether it
is an artificial intelligence or not
is it interacting with humans in a way
that we can understand
without that interaction is just an
object uh so we talk about theory of
mind we really understand how it
interfaces that whole if you're in web
development user experience would be the
term i would put in there so the theory
of mind would be user experience how's
the whole ui connected together and one
of the final things is as we get into
artificial intelligence is systems being
aware of themselves
understanding their internal states and
predicting other people's feelings and
act appropriately so as artificial
intelligence continues to progress
we see ones are trying to understand
well what makes people happy how would
they increase our happiness
how would they keep themselves from
breaking down if something's broken
inside they have that self-awareness to
be able to fix it and just based on all
that information
predicting which action would work the
best what would help people
if i know that you're having a cup of
coffee first thing in the morning is
what makes you happy as a robot i might
make you a cup of coffee every morning
at the same time
to help your life and help you grow
that'd be the self-awareness is being
able to know all those different things
types of machine learning and like i
said on the last slide this is very
important this is very important if you
decide to go in and get certified in
machine learning or know more about it
these are the three primary types of
machine learning
the first one is supervised learning
systems are able to predict future
outcome based on past data requires both
an input and an output to be given to
the model for it to be trained
so in this case we're looking at
anything where you have a hundred images
of a bicycle
and those hundred images you know are
bicycle so it's they're presets someone
already looked at all hundred images and
said these are pictures of bicycles and
so the computer learns from those and
then it's given another picture
and maybe the next picture is a bicycle
and it says oh that resembles all these
other bicycles so it's a bicycle and the
next one's a car and it says that's not
a bicycle
that would be supervised learning
because we had to train it we had to
supervise it unsupervised learning
systems are able to identify hidden
patterns from the input data provided by
making the data more readable and
organized the patterns similarities or
anomalies become more evident you'll
heard the term cluster how do you
cluster things together some of these
things go together some of these don't
this is unsupervised where you can look
at an image
and start pulling the different pieces
of the image out
because they aren't the same the human
all the parts of the human are not the
same as a fuzzy tree behind them just
slightly out of focus which is not the
same as the beach ball it's unsupervised
because we never told it what a beach
ball was we never told them what the
human was and we never told it that
those were trees
all we told it was hey separate this
picture by things that don't match
and things that do match and come
together
and finally there's reinforcement
learning systems are given no training
it learns on the basis of the reward
punishment it received for performing
its last action it helps increase the
efficiency of a tool function or a
program reinforced learning a
reinforcement learning is kind of you
give it a yes or no yes you gave me the
right response no you didn't and then it
looks at that and says oh okay so based
on this data coming in
what i gave you was a wrong response so
next time i'll give you a different one
comparing machine learning and deep
learning so remember that deep learning
is a subcategory of machine learning so
it's one of the many tools and so they
we're grouping a ton of machine learning
tools all together linear regression k
means clustering there's all kinds of
cool tools out there you can use in
machine learning enables machines to
take decisions to make decisions on
their own based on past data
enables machines to make decisions with
the help of artificial neural networks
so it's doing the same thing but we're
using an artificial neural network as
opposed to one of the more traditional
machine learning tools
needs only a small amount of training
data this is very important when you're
talking about machine learning
they're usually not talking about huge
amounts of data we're talking about
maybe your spreadsheet from your
business and your totals for the end of
the year when you're talking about
neural networks you usually need a large
amount of data to train the data so
there's a lot of training involved if
you have under 500 points of data that's
probably
not going to go into machine learning or
maybe you have like the case of one of
the things 500 points of data and 30
different fields
it starts getting really confusing there
in artificial intelligence or machine
learning and the deep learning aspect
really shines when you get to that
larger data that's really complex
works well on a low end systems
so a lot of the machine learning tools
out there you can run on your laptop
with no problem and do the calculations
there
where with the machine learning usually
needs a higher end system to work it
takes a lot more processing power to
build those neural networks and to train
them it goes through a lot of data
we're talking about the general machine
learning tools most features need to be
identified in advanced and manually
coded so there's a lot of human work on
here
the machine learns the features from the
data it is provided so again it's like a
magic box you don't have to know what a
tire is
it figures it out for you
the problem is divided into parts and
solved individually and then combined so
machine learning you usually have all
these different tools and use different
tools for different parts
and the problem is solved in an
end-to-end manner so you only have one
neural network or two neural networks
that is bringing the data in and putting
it out it's not going through a lot of
different processes to get there and
remember you can put machine learning
and deep learning together so you don't
always have just the deep learning
solving the problem by having selling
one piece of the puzzle
with regular machine learning and most
machine learning tools out there they
take longer to test and understand how
they work
and with the deep learning it's pretty
quick once you build that neural network
you test it and you know
so we're dealing with very crisp rules
limited resources
you have to really explain how the
decision was made when you use most
machine learning tools but when you use
the deep learning tool inside the
machine learning tools the system takes
care of it based on its own logic and
reasoning and again it's like a magic
black box
you really don't know how it came up
with the answer you just know it came up
with the right answer a glimpse into the
future
so a quick glimpse into the future
artificial intelligence be using it to
detecting crimes before they happen
humanoid ai helpers which we already
have a lot of there'll be more and more
maybe it'll actually be androids that'd
be cool to have an android that comes
and get stuff out of my fridge for me
machine learning increasing efficiency
in healthcare that's really big in all
the forms of machine learning better
marketing techniques any of these things
if we get into the sciences it's just
off the scale machine learning and
artificial intelligence go everywhere
and then the subcategory deep learning
increased personalization so what's
really nice about the deep learning is
it's going to start now catering to you
that'll be one of the things we see more
and more of
and we'll have more of a hyper
intelligent personal assistant i'm
excited about that
we're going to cover mathematics for
machine learning
data and as types data denotes the
individual pieces of factual information
collected from various sources it is
stored processed and later used for
analysis
and so we see here just a huge grouping
of information a lot of tech stuff money
dollar signs numbers
and then you have your performing
analytics to drive insights and
hopefully you have a nice share your
shareholders gather it at the meeting
and you're able to explain it in
something they can understand
so we talk about data types of data
we have in our types of data we have a
qualitative categorical
you think nominal or ordinal and then
you have your quantitative or numerical
which is discrete or continuous
and let's look a little closer at those
data type vocabulary always people's
favorite is the vocabulary words okay
not mine
uh but let's dive into this what we mean
by nominal nominal they are used to
label various
label our variables without providing
any measurable value
country gender race hair color etc it's
something that you either mark true or
false this is a label it's on or off
either they have a red hat on or they do
not
so a lot of times when you're thinking
nominal data
labels
think of it as a true false kind of
setup and we look at ordinal this is
categorical data with a set order or a
scale to it
and you can think of salary range as a
great one
movie ratings etc you can see here the
sally rains if you have ten thousand to
twenty thousand number of employees
earning that rate is 150 20 000 to 30
100 and so forth some of the terms
you'll hear is bucket uh this is where
you have 10 different buckets and you
want to separate it into something that
makes sense into those 10 buckets
and so
we start talking about ordinal a lot of
times when you get down to the brass
bones again we're talking true false uh
so if you're a member of the 10 to 20k
range
uh so forth those would each be either
part of that group or you're not but now
we're talking about buckets so we want
to count how many people are in that
bucket
quantitative numerical data
falls into two classes discrete or
continuous
and so data with a final set of values
which can be categorized class strength
questions answered correctly and runs
hit and cricket a lot of times when you
see this you can think integer
and a very restricted integer i.e
you can only have 100 questions
on a test so you can it's very discreet
i only have a hundred different values
that it can attain
so think usually you're talking about
integers but within a very small range
they don't have an open end or anything
like that
so discrete is very solid
simple to count
set number
continuous on the other hand uh
continuous data can take any numerical
value within a range so water pressure
weight of a person etc usually we start
thinking about float values where they
can get phenomenally small and they're
in what they're worth
and there's a whole series of values
that falls right between discrete and
continuous
you can think of the stock market you
have dollar amounts it's still discrete
but it starts to get complicated enough
when you have like you know jump in the
stock market from 525.33
to
580.67
there's a lot of point values in there
it'd still be called discrete but you
start looking at it as almost continuous
because it does have such a variance in
it now
we talk about no we did we went over
nominal and ordinal
almost true false charts and we looked
at quantitative and numerical data which
we'll start to get into numbers discrete
you can usually a lot of times discrete
will be put into it could be put into
true false but usually it's not
so we want to address this stuff and the
first thing you want to look at is the
very basic which is your algebra so
we're going to take a look at linear
algebra you can remember back when your
euclidean geometry we have a line well
let's go through this we have a linear
algebra is the domain of mathematics
concerning linear equations
and their representations in vector
spaces and through matrixes i told you
we're going to talk about matrix is
so a linear equation
is simply
2x plus 4y minus 3z equals 10. very
linear 10x plus 12.4y equals z and now
you can actually solve these two
equations by combining them
uh and that's we're talking about a
linear equation
in the vectors we have a plus b equals c
now we're starting to look at a
direction
and these values usually think of an x y
z plot
so each one is a direction and the
actual
distance of like a triangle a b is c
and then your matrix can describe all
kinds of things
i find matrixes
confuse a lot of people
not because they're particularly
difficult but because of the magnitude
and the different things they're used
for
and a matrix is a chart or a
you know think of a spreadsheet but you
have your rows and your columns
and you'll see here we have a times b
equals c
very important to know your counts
so depending on how the math is being
done what you're using it for making
sure you have the same rows and number
of columns or a single number there's
all kinds of things that play in that
that can make matrixes confusing
but really it has a lot more to do with
what domain you're working in are you
adding in
multiple polynomials where you have like
uh
a x squared plus b y plus you know you
start to see that can be very confusing
versus a very straightforward matrix
and let's just go a little deeper into
these because these are such primary
this is what we're here to talk about is
these different math
mathematical computations that come up
so we're looking at linear equations
let's dig deeper into that one an
equation having a maximum order of 1 is
called a linear equation
so it's linear because when you look at
this we have ax plus b equals c which is
a one variable
we have two variable ax plus b y equals
c a x plus b y plus z c z equals d
and so forth but all of these
are to the power of one you don't see x
squared you don't see x cubed so we're
talking about linear equations that's
what we're talking about in their
addition if you have already dived into
say neural networks you should recognize
this a x plus b y plus c z
setup plus the intercept
which is basically your your neural
network each node adding up all the
different inputs
and we can drill down into that most
common formula is your y equals mx plus
c
so you have your y
equals the m which is your slope
your x value plus c
which is your
y-intercept you kind of labeled it wrong
here
threw me for a loop but the the c would
be your y-intercept so when you set x
equal to zero y equals c and that's
that's your y-intercept right there
uh and that's they just had a reverse
value of y when x equals zero equals the
y-intercept which is c and your slope
gradient line which is your m so you get
your y equals 2x plus 3.
and there's lots of easy ways to compute
this this way this is why we always
start with the most basic one when we're
solving one of these problems
and then of course the
one of the most important takeaways is
the slope gradient of the line
so the slope is very important that m
value
in this case we went ahead and solved
this
if you have y equals 2x plus 3 you can
see how it has a nice line graph here on
the right
so matrixes a matrix refers to a
rectangular representation of an array
of numbers arranged in columns and rows
so we're talking
m rows by n columns here a11 is denotes
the element of the first row in the
first column similarly
a12 and it's really pronounced a11 in
this particular setup so it's a row one
column one a 12 is a
row one column two
uh first row and second column and so on
and there's a lot of ways to denote this
i've seen these as like a capital letter
a smaller case a for the top row or i
mean you can see where they can go all
kinds of different directions as far as
the value
you just take a moment to realize there
needs to be some designation as far as
what row it's in and what column it's
and we have our basic operations we have
addition so when you think about
addition you have
two matrixes of two by two and you just
add each individual number in that
matrix and then when you get to the
bottom you have in this case the
solution is 12 10 plus 2 is 12 5 plus 3
is 8 and so on
and the same thing with subtraction
now again you're counting matrixes you
want to check your
dimensions of the matrix
the shape you'll see shape come up a lot
in programming so we're talking about
dimensions we're talking about the shape
if the two shapes are equal
this is what happens when you add them
together or subtract them and we have
multiplication when you look at the
multiplication you end up with a very uh
a slightly different setup going now
if we look at our last one where
we're like why
this always gets to me when we get to
matrixes they don't really say why you
multiply matrixes
um you know my first thought is 1 times
2 4 times 3 but if you look at this we
get 1 times 2 plus 4 times 3
1 times 3 plus 4 times five
six times two plus three times three six
times three plus three times five if
you're looking at these matrixes uh
think of this more as an equation
and so we have if you remember we move
back up here for our multiple line
equations let's just go back up a couple
slides where we were looking at a two
variable so this is a two variable
equation a x plus b y equals c
and this is a way to make it very quick
to solve these variables and that's why
you have the matrix and that's why you
do
the multiplication the way they do
and this is the dot product of 1 times 2
plus 4 times 3
one times three plus four times five
uh six times two plus three times three
six times three plus three times five
and it gives us a nice little
14 23 21 and 33 over here which then can
be used and reduced down to a sample
formula as far as solving the variables
as you have enough inputs
and then in matrix operations when
you're dealing with a lot of matrixes
now keep in mind
multiplying matrixes is different than
finding the product of two matrixes okay
so we're talking about multiplication
we're talking about solving
for equations when you're finding the
product you are just finding one times
two keep that in mind because that does
come up i've had that come up a number
of times where i'm altering data and i
get confused as to what i'm doing with
it
transpose flipping the matrix over is
diagonal comes up all the time where you
have you still have 12 but instead of it
being a 12 8 it's now 12 14
8 21 you're just flipping the columns
and the rows
and then of course you can do an inverse
changing the signs of the values across
this main diagonal and you can see here
we have the inverse a to the minus 1 and
ends up with
instead of 12 8 14 12 is now minus 22
minus 12.
vectors
vector just means we have
a value and a direction
and we have down four numbers here on
our vector
in mathematics a one dimensional matrix
is called a vector uh so
if you have your x plot and you have a
single value that values along the x
axis and it's a single dimension
if you have two dimensions you can think
about putting them on a graph you might
have x and you might have y and each
value denotes a direction and then of
course the actual distance is going to
be the hypothesis of that triangle
and you can do that with three
dimensionals x y and z
and you can do it all the way to nth
dimensions so when they talk about the k
means
for categorizing and how close data is
together they will compute that based on
the pythagorean theorem so you would
take
the square of each value add them all
together and find the square root and
that gives you a distance
as far as where that point is where that
vector exists or an actual point value
and then you can compare that point
value
to another one it makes a very easy
comparison versus comparing uh 50 or 60
different numbers
and that brings us up to i gene vectors
and i gene values
uh i gene vectors the vectors that don't
change their span while transformation
and i gene values the scalar values that
are associated to the vectors
conceptually
you can think of the vector as your
picture you have a picture it's uh
two dimensions x and y
and so when you do those two dimensions
and those two values or whatever that
value is
that is that point but the values change
when you skew it and so
if we take and we have a vector a
and that's a set value uh b is um your
is your you have a and b which is your
hygiene vector 2 is the i gene value so
we're altering
all the values by two that means we're
maybe we're stretching it out one
direction making it tall if you're doing
picture editing
that's one of the places this comes in
but you can see when you're transforming
uh your different information how you
transform it is then your hygiene value
and you can see here vector after line
transit transition
we have three a a is the i gene vector
three is the i aging value
so a doesn't change that's whatever we
started with that's your original
picture and three
is skewing it one direction and maybe
a b is being skewed another direction
and so you have a nice tilted picture
because you altered it by those by the
aging values
so let's go ahead and pull up a demo on
linear algebra and to do this i'm going
to go through my trusted anaconda into
my jupiter notebook
and we'll create a new notebook called
linear algebra
since we are working in python we're
going to use our numpy i always import
that as np or numpy array probably the
most popular
module for doing matrixes and things in
given that this is part of a series i'm
not going to go too much into numpy we
are going to go ahead and create two
different variables a for a numpy array
10 15 and b 29.
we'll go ahead and run this and you can
see there's our two arrays 10 15 29 and
i went and added a space there in
between so it's easier to read
and since it's the last line we don't
have to put the print statement on it
unless you want we can simply but we can
simply do a plus b so when i run this
we have 10 15 29
and we get 30 24 which is what you
expect 10 plus 20 15 plus 9
you could almost look at this edition as
being
just adding up the columns on here
coming down and if we wanted to do it a
different way we could also do a dot t
plus b dot t
remember that t flips them and so if we
do that we now get them
we now have 30 24 going the other way
we could also do something kind of fun
there's a lot of different ways to do
this
as far as a plus b i can also do a plus
b
dot t
and you're going to see that that will
come out the same the 30 24 whether i
transpose a and b or transpose them both
at the end
and likewise we can very easily subtract
two vectors i can go a minus b
and we run that and we get minus 10 6.
now remember this is the last line in
this particular section that's right not
to put the print around it
and just like we did before
we can transpose either the individual
or we can transpose the main set up and
then we get a minus 10 6 going the other
way
now we didn't mention this in our notes
but you can also do a scalar
multiplication
and just put down scalar so you can
remember that
uh what we're talking about here is i
have
this
array here u
and if i go a
times u uh we'll take the value 2 we'll
multiply it by every value in here so 2
times 30 is 60 2 times 15
and just like we did before
this happens a lot because when you're
doing matrixes you do need to flip them
you get 60 30 coming this way
so in numpy uh we have what they call
dot product
and uh with this in a two dimensional
vectors it is the equivalent of two
matrix multiplication remember we were
talking about matrix multiplication
uh where it is the
well let's walk through it
we'll go ahead and start by defining two
numpy arrays we'll have uh 10 20 25 6 or
our u and our v
and then we're going to go ahead and do
if we take
the values
and if you remember correctly
an array like this would be 10 times 25
plus 20 times 6.
we'll go ahead and
print that
there we go
and then we'll go ahead and do the np
dot dot
of u comma
v
and we'll find when we do this we go and
run this
we're going to get
370 370.
so this is a strain multiplication where
they use it to solve
linear algebra when you have multiple
numbers going across and so this could
be very complicated we could have a
whole string of different variables
going in here but for this we get a nice
value for our dot multiplication
and we did
addition earlier which is just your
basic addition
and of course the matrix you can get
very complicated on these or
in this case we'll go ahead and do
let's create two
complex matrixes
this one is a matrix of um you know 12
10 4 6 4 31. we'll just print out a so
you can see what that looks like here's
print
a
we print a out you can see that we have
2 by 3
layer matrix for a
and we can also put together
always kind of fun when you're playing
with print values
we can do something like this we could
go in here there we go
we could print a we have it end with uh
equals a
run
and this kind of gives it a nice look uh
here's your matrix that's all this is
comma n means it just tags it on the end
that's all all that is doing on there
and then we can simply add in what is a
plus b and you should already guess
because this is the same as what we did
before there's no difference
when we do a simple vector addition we
have 12 plus 2 is 14 10 plus 8 is 18 and
so on
and just like we did the matrix addition
we can also do a minus b
and do our matrix subtraction
and we look at this we have what 12
minus 2 is 10 10 minus 8 um where are we
oh there we go 8 minus
confusing what i'm looking at i should
have reprinted out the original numbers
but we can see here 12 minus 2 is of
course 10 10 minus 8 is 2
4 minus 46 is minus 42 and so forth so
same as the subtraction as before we
just call it matrix subtraction is
identical
now if you remember up here we had a
scalar addition we're adding just one
number
to a matrix you can also do scalar
multiplication
and so simply if you have a single value
a and you have b which is your array we
can also do a times b
when we run that
you can see here we have 2 times 4 is 8
5 times 4 is 20 and so forth you're just
multiplying the 4 across each one of
these values
and this is an interesting one that
comes up
a little bit of a brain teaser is matrix
and vector multiplication
and so we're looking at this
we are just do a regular arrays it
doesn't necessarily have to be a numpy
array
we have a
which has our
array of arrays and b which is a single
array and so we can from here
do the dot
a b
and this is going to return two values
and the first value is that is you could
say it's like uh
we're doing the
this array b array
first with a and then with a second one
and so it splits it up so you have a
matrix of vector multiplication and you
can mix and match
when you get into really complicated uh
back end stuff this becomes more common
because you're now you've got layers
upon layers of data and so you you'll
end up with a matrix and a set of bolt
vector matrices do you want to multiply
now keep in mind
that if you're doing data science a lot
of times you're not looking at this this
is what's going on behind the scenes so
if you're in
the scikit looking at sk learn where
you're doing linear regression models
this is some of the math that's hidden
behind the scenes that's going on
other times you might find yourself
having to do part of this and manipulate
the data around so it fits right and
then you go back in and you run it
through the psi kit and if we can do
up here where we did a
matrix and vector multiplication we can
also do matrix two matrix multiplication
and if we run this we have the two
matrixes uh you can see a very
complicated array that of course comes
out on there for our dot
and just to reiterate it we have our
transpose a matrix which is your dot t
and so if we create a matrix a and we do
uh transpose it you can see how it flips
it from
5 10 15 20 25 30 to 5 15 25 10 20 30
rows and columns
and certainly with the math this comes
up a lot
it also comes up a lot with xy plotting
when you put into pi plot you have one
format where they're looking at pairs
and numbers and then they want all of
x's and all y's
so you know the transpose is an
important tool both for your math and
for plotting and all kinds of things
another tool that we didn't discuss uh
is your identity matrix
and this one is more definition
the identity matrix
we have here one where we just did
two
so it comes down as one zero zero one uh
one zero zero zero one zero it creates a
diagonal of one and what that is is when
you're doing your identities you could
be comparing
all your different features to the
different features and how they
correlate
and of course when you have uh feature
one compared to feature one to itself it
is always
one uh where
usually it's between zero one depending
on how well correlates so when we're
talking about identity matrix that's
what we're talking about right here is
that you create this preset matrix and
then you might adjust these numbers
depending on what you're working with
and what the domain is
and then another thing we can do
to kind of wrap this up will hit you
with the most complicated
piece of this
puzzle here is an inverse
a matrix
and let's just go ahead and put the um
it's a lengthy description
let's go and put the description this is
straight out of the
the website for
numpy
so given a square matrix a here's our
square matrix a which is two one zero
zero one zero one two one keep in mind
three by three is square it's to be
equal it's going to return the matrix a
inverse satisfying dot a
a inverse so here's our
matrix multiplication
and then of course it equals the dot uh
yeah a inverse of a
with an identity shape of
a dot shaped zero this is just reshaping
the identity
that's a little complicated there uh so
we're going to have our here's our array
uh we'll go ahead and run this
and you can see what we end up with
is we end up with uh an array 0.5 minus
0.5 and so forth with our 2 1 1 going
down 2 1 0 0 1 0 1 2 1.
getting into a little deep on the math
understanding
when you need this is probably really is
is what's really important when you're
doing data science
versus
handwriting this out and looking up the
math and handwriting all the pieces out
you do need to know about the linear
algorithm inverse of a
so if it comes up you can easily pull it
up or at least remember where to look it
up we took a look at the algebra side of
it let's go ahead and take a look at the
calculus side of what's going on here
with the machine learning so
calculus oh my goodness and differential
equations you got to throw that in there
because that's all part of the
bag of tricks especially when you're
doing large neural networks but also
comes up in many other areas the good
news is most of it's already done for
you in the back end
so when it comes up you really do need
to understand from the data science not
data analytics data analytics means
you're digging deep into
actually solving these math equations
and a neural network is just a giant
differential equation
uh so we talk about calculus uh we're
going to go ahead
and understand it by talking about cars
versus time and speed
so helps to calculate the spontaneous
rate of change
so suppose we plot a graph of the speed
of a car with respect to time
so as you can see here
going down the highway probably merged
into the highway from an on-ramp so i
had to accelerate so my speed went way
up
uh stuck in traffic
merged into the traffic traffic opens up
and i accelerate again up to the speed
limit
and
maybe peter's off up there so you can
look at this is as
the speed versus time i'm getting faster
and faster because i'm continually
accelerating and if i hit the brakes you
go the other way
so the rate of change of speed with
respect to time is nothing but
acceleration how fast are we
accelerating
the acceleration is the area between the
star point of x and the end point of
delta x
so we can calculate a simple
if you had x and delta x we could put a
line there and that slope of the line is
our acceleration
now that's pretty easy when you're doing
linear algebra but i don't want to know
it just for that line in those two
points i want to know what across the
whole of what i'm working with
that's where we get into calculus
so we talk about the distance between x
and delta x it has to be the smallest
possible near to zero in order to
approximate the
acceleration so the idea is instead of i
mean if you ever did took a basic
calculus class
they would draw bars down here and you
would divide this area up
let's go back up the screen you divide
this area of this time period up into
maybe 10 sections and you'd use that and
you could calculate the acceleration
between each one of those 10 sections
kind of thing
and then we just keep making that space
smaller and smaller until delta x is
almost
infinitesimally small
and so we get a function of a
equals a limit as h goes to 0 of a
function of a plus h minus a function of
a over h and that is you're computing
the slope of the line
we're just computing that slope and
they're smaller and smaller and smaller
samples
and that's what calculus is calculus is
the integral you can see down here we
have our nice
integral sign looks like a giant s
and that's what that means is that we've
taken this down to as small as we can
for that sampling
uh so we're talking about calculus we're
finding the area under the slope is the
main process in the integration
similar small intervals are made of the
smallest possible length of x plus delta
x where delta x approaches almost an
infinitesimally small space
and then it helps to find the overall
acceleration by summing up all the links
together
so we're summing up all the
accelerations from the beginning to the
end
and so here's our integral we sum of a
of x times d of x
equals a plus c
that is our basic calculus here
so when we talk about multivariate
calculus
multivariate calculus deals with
functions that have multiple variables
and you can see here we start getting
into some very complicated equations
um
change in w over change of time
equals change of w over change of z
the differential of z to dx differential
of x to dt it gets pretty complicated uh
and it really translates into the
multivariate integration using double
integrals and so you have the the sum of
the sum of f of x of y of d of a equals
the sum from c to d and a to b of f of x
y d x d y equals
the sum of a to b sum of c to d of f x
of y d y d x
understanding the very specifics of
everything going on in here and actually
doing the math is usually calculus 1
calculus 2 and differential equations
so you're talking about three full
length courses to dig into
and solve these math equations
what we want to take from here is we're
talking about calculus
we're talking about summing of all these
different slopes and so we're still
solving a linear uh expression we're
still solving y equals m x plus b
but we're doing this for infinity small
x's and then we want to sum them up
that's what this integral sign means
the sum of a of x d of x equals a plus c
and when you see these very complicated
multivariate differentiation using the
chain rule
when we come in here and we have the
change of w to the change of t equals
the change of w dz
uh and so forth that's what's going on
here that's what these means we're
basically looking for the area under the
curve which really comes to how is the
change changing speeds going up how is
that changing and then you end up with a
multiple layer so if i have three layers
of neural networks how is the third
layer changing based on the second layer
changing which is based on the first
layer changing and you get the picture
here that now we have a very complicated
multivariate integration
with integrals
the good news is we can solve this
mathematically and that's what we do
when you do neural networks and reverse
propagation
so the nice thing is that you don't have
to solve this on paper unless you're a
data analysis and you're working on the
back end of integrating these formulas
and building the script to actually
build them so we talk about applications
of calculus it provides us the tools to
build an accurate predictive model
so it's really behind the scenes we want
to guess at what the change of the
change or the change is
that's a little goofy i know i just
threw that out there it's kind of a meta
term but if you can guess how things are
going to change then you can guess what
the new numbers are
multivariate calculus explains the
change in our target variable in
relation to the rate of change in the
input variables
so there's our multiple variables going
in there if one variable is changing how
does it affect the other variable
and then in gradient descent calculus is
used to find the local and global maxima
and this is really big uh we're going to
actually going to have a whole section
here on gradient descent because it is
really i mean i talked about neural
networks and how you can see how the
different layers go in there but
gradient descent is one of the most key
things for trying to guess the best
answer to something
so let's take a look at the code behind
gradient descent and uh before we open
up the code let's just do real quick
gradient descent
let's say we have a curve like this and
most common
is that this is going to represent your
error oops
error there we go there
ah hard to read there and i want to make
the error as low as possible
and so what i'm looking at it is i want
to find this line here
which is the minimum value so we're
looking for the minimum
and it does that by
sampling there
and then based on this it guesses it
might be someplace here and it goes hey
this is still going down
it goes here and then goes back over
here and then goes a little bit closer
and it's just playing a high low until
it gets to that spot that bottom spot
and so we want to minimize the error
in and
on the flip note you could also want to
be maximizing something you want to get
the best output of it
that's simply
minus the value
so if you're looking for where the peak
is
this is the same as a negative
for where the valley is i'm looking for
that valley
uh that's all that is and this is a way
of finding it so
the cool thing is um all the heavy
lifting is done
i actually
ended up putting together one of these a
while back as uh when i didn't know
about sidekick and i was just starting
uh boy it's a long while back
and uh
is playing high low how do you play high
low not get stuck in the valleys uh
figure out these curves and things like
that well you do that and the back end
is all the calculus and differential
equations to calculate this out
the good news is you don't have to do
those
so instead we're going to put together
the code and let's go ahead
and see what we can do with that
so uh guys in the back put together a
nice little piece of code here which is
kind of fun
uh some things we're gonna note and this
is this is really important stuff
because when you start doing your data
science and digging into your machine
learning models
you're going to find
these things are stumbling blocks
the first one is current x where do we
start at
keep in mind
your model that you're working with is
very generic so whatever you use to
minimize it the first question is where
do we start
and we started at this because the
algorithm starts at x equals three so we
arbitrarily picked five learning rate is
uh how many bars to skip going one way
or the other i'm in fact i'm going to
separate that a little bit because these
two are really important
if we're dealing with something like
this where we're talking about
well here's our here's the function
we're going to use our
gradient of our function
2 times x plus 5 keep it simple so
that's a function we're going to work
with so if i'm dealing with increments
of a thousand point one is going to be a
very long time and if i'm dealing with
increments of 0.001
0.1 is going to skip over my answer so i
won't get a very good answer
and then we look at precision this tells
us when to stop the algorithm so again
very specific to what you're working on
if you're working with money
and
you don't convert it into a float value
you might be dealing with 0.01 which is
a penny that might be your precision
you're working with
and then of course the previous step
size max iterations we want something to
cut out at a certain point usually
that's built into a lot of minimization
functions
and then here's our actual
formula we're going to be working with
and then we come in we go while previous
step size is greater than precision and
iters is less than max and max
iters let's say that 10 times fast
um
we're just saying if it's uh if we're if
we're still greater than our precision
level we still got to keep digging
deeper
and then we also don't want to go past a
thou or whatever this is a million or
ten thousand uh running that's actually
pretty high i almost never do max
iterations more than like a hundred or
two hundred
rare occasions you might go up to four
or five hundred if it's depending on the
problem you're working with uh so we
have our previous equals our current
that way we can track time wise
uh the current now equals the current
minus the rate times the formula of our
previous x
so now we've generated our new version
previous step size equals the absolute
current previous
so we're looking for the change in x
errors equals iterations plus one that's
so we know to stop if we get too far
and then we're just going to print the
local minimum occurs at
x on here and if we go ahead and run
this
uh you can see right here it gets down
to this point and it says hey
local minimum is minus 3.3
for this particular series we created uh
this is created off of our formula here
lambda x2 times x plus 5.
now
when i'm running this stuff
you'll see this come up a lot
and
with the sk learn kit
and one of the nice reasons of breaking
this down the way we did is i could go
over those top pieces
those top pieces are everything when you
start looking at these minimization
toolkits in built-in code
and so from um we'll just do it's
actually
docs
dot
scipy.org
and we're looking at
the scikit
there we go
optimize minimize
you can only minimize one value
you have the function that's going in
this function can be very complicated
so we used a very simple function up
here
it could be
there's all kinds of things that could
be on there and there's a number of
methods to solve this as far as how they
shrink down
and your x naught there's your there's
your start value so your function your
start value
um
there's all kinds of things that come in
here that you can look at which we're
not going to
optimization automatically creates
constraints bounds
some of this it does automatically but
you really the big thing i want to point
out here is you need to have a starting
point you want to start with something
that you already know is mostly the
answer
if you don't then it's going to have a
heck of a time trying to calculate it
out
or you can write your own little script
that does this and does a high low
guessing and tries to find the max value
that brings us to statistics what this
is kind of all about is figuring things
out a lot of vocabulary and statistics
ah so statistics well i guess it's all
relative it's definitely not an edel
class
so a bunch of stuff going on statistics
statistics concerns with the collection
organization analysis interpretation
and presentation of data
that is a mouthful
so we have from end to end
where does it come from is it valid what
does it mean how do we organize it
how do we analyze it then you gotta take
those analysis and interpret it into
something that people can use kind of
reduce it to understandable
and nowadays you have to be able to
present it if you can't present it then
no one else is going to understand what
the heck you did
so we look at the terminologies
there is a lot of terminologies
depending on what domain you're working
in
so clearly if you're working in
a domain that deals with
viruses and t cells and and
how does you know where does it come
from you're studying the different
people then you can have a population
if you are working with um
mechanical gear
you know a little bit different if
you're looking for the wobbling
statistics uh to know when to replace a
rotor on a machine or something like
that that can be a big deal you know we
have these huge fans that turn
in our sewage processing systems and so
those fans they start to wobble and hum
and do different things that the sensors
pick up at one point do you replace them
instead of waiting for it to break in
which case it costs a lot of money
instead of replacing a bushing you're
replacing the whole fan unit
uh an interesting project that came up
for our city a while back
uh so population all objects are
measurements whose properties are being
observed
so that's your population all the
objects it's easy to see it with people
because we have our population
in large
but in the case of the sewer fans we're
talking about how the fan units that's
the population of fans that we're
working with
you have a parameter a matrix that is
used to represent a population or
characteristic
you have your sample a subset of the
population studied you don't want to do
them all because then you don't have a
if you come up with a conclusion for
everyone you don't have a way of testing
it so you take a sample
sometimes you don't have a choice you
can only take a sample of what's going
on you can't
study the whole population
and a variable a metric of interest for
each person or object in a population
types of sampling
we have a probabilistic approach
selecting samples from a larger
population using a method based on the
theory of probability
and we'll go into a little bit more
deeper on these we have random
systematic stratified and then you have
a non-probabilistic approach selecting
samples based on the subjective judgment
of the researcher rather than random
selection
uh has to do with convenience trying to
reach a quota
or snowball
and they're very biased that's one of
the reasons you'll see this big stamp on
it says biased uh so you gotta be very
careful on that
so probabilistic sampling uh when we
talk about a random sampling we select
random size samples from each group or
category so it's as random as you can
get we talk about systematic sampling
we're selecting random size samples from
each group or category with a fixed
periodic interval
uh so we kind of split it up this would
be like a time set up or our different
categories
and you might ask your question what is
a category or a group
uh if you look at i'm going to go back a
window let's say we're studying
economics of different of an area
um we know pretty much that based on
their culture where they came from
they might need to be separated and so
uh and why i say separated i don't mean
separated from their place where they
live i mean as far as the analysis we
want to look at the different groups and
make sure they're all represented
so if we had like an 80 percent uh of a
group that is
say hispanic and or indian and also in
that same area we have 20 percent 20
percent who are let's call our
expatriates they left america and
they're nice and
your caucasian group
we might want to sample a group that is
representative of both
so we're talking about stratified
sampling and we're talking about groups
those are the groups we're talking about
and that brings us to stratified
sampling selecting approximately equal
size samples from each group or category
this way we can actually separate the
categories and give us an insight into
the different cultures and how that
might affect them in that area
so you can see these are very very
different kind of
depends on what you're working with as
far as your data and what you're
studying and so we can see here just a
little bit more we'd have selecting 25
employees from a company of 250
employees randomly don't care anything
about them what groups are in which
office they're in nothing we might be
selecting one employee from every 50
unique employees in a company of 250
employees
and then we have selecting one employee
from every branch in the company office
so we have all the different branches
there's our group or categories by the
branch and the category could depend on
what you're studying so it has a lot of
variation on there
you see this kind of grouping and
categorizing is also used to generate a
lot of misinformation
so if you only study one group and you
say this is what it is
then everybody assumes that's what it is
for everybody and so you've got to be
very careful of that and it's very
unethical thing to kind of do
so types of statistics uh we talk about
statistics
we're going to talk about descriptive
and inferential statistics
there are so many different terms and
statistics to break it up
so we so we're talking about a
particular
setup
so we're talking about descriptive of
inferential uh statistics
the base of the word describe
is pretty solid you're describing the
data what does it look like with
inferential statistics we're going to
take that from the small population to a
large population so if you're working
with a drug company you might look at
the data and say these people were
helped by this drug
they did 80 percent better
as far as their health or 80 percent
better survival rate than the people
who did not have the drug so we can
infer that that drug will work in the
greater populace and will help people so
that's where you get your inferential so
we are predicting how it's going to
affect the greater population
so descriptive statistics it is used to
describe the basic features of data and
form the basis of quantitative analysis
of data
so we have a measure of central
tendencies we have your mean median and
mode
and then we have a measure of spread
like your range your interquartile range
your variance and your standard
deviation
and we're going to look at all these a
little deeper here in a second
but one of them you can think of is um
how the data difference
differences you know what's the max min
range all that stuff is your spread and
anything that's just a single number is
usually your central uh tendencies
measure of central tendencies
so we talk about the mean it is the
average of the set of values considered
what is the average outcome of whatever
is going on
and then your median
separates the higher half and the lower
half of data
so where's the center point of all your
different data points so your mean might
have some a couple really big numbers
that skew it uh so that the average is
much higher than if you took those
outliers out
where the median would by separating the
high from the low might give you a much
lower number you might look at and say
oh that's that's odd why is the average
so much higher than the median well it's
because you have some outliers or why is
it so much lower
and then the mode is the most frequent
appearing value
this is really interesting if you're
studying economics and how people are
doing you might find that the most
common
income like in the u.s was
1.24 000 a year where the average was
closer to 80 000. and it's like wow what
a difference well there's some people
have a lot of money and so that skews
that way up so the average person is not
making that kind of money and then you
look at the median income and you're
like well the median income is a little
bit closer to the average so it does
create a very interesting way of looking
at the data again these are all uh
central tendencies single numbers you
can look at for the whole spread of the
data and we look at the measure of
central tendencies the mean is the
average marks of a students in a
classroom so here we have the mean sum
of the marks of the students total
number of students and as we talked
about the median
we have 0 through 10
and we take half the numbers and put
them on one side of the line half the
numbers on the other side of the line
we end up with 5 in the middle and then
the mode what mark was scored by most of
the students in a test
in a simple case where most people
scored like an 82 percent and got
certain problems wrong easy to figure
out uh not so easy when you have
different areas where like you have like
the um oh let's go back to economy a
little bit more difficult to calculate
if you have a large group that scores
that makes 30 000
and a slightly bigger group that makes
26 000 so what do you put down for the
mode
certainly there's a number of ways to
calculate that and there's actually
different variations depending on what
you're doing
so now we're looking at a measure of
spread uh range what's the difference
between the highest and the lowest value
first thing you want to look at you know
it's uh we had everybody in the test
score between 60 and 100 so we got 100
or maybe 60 to 90 percent it was so hard
that a lot of people could not get a
hundred percent
um you have your
inter-quartile range quartiles divide a
rank ordered data set into four equal
parts
very common thing to do as part of all
the basic packages whether you're
working in uh
data frames with pandas whether you're
working in scala whether you're working
in r
you'll see this come up where they have
range your min your max and then it'll
have your interquartile range how does
it look like in each quarter of data
variance measures how far each number in
the set is from the mean and therefore
from every other number in the set
so you have like a how much turbulence
is going on in this data
and then the standard deviation
it is to measure the variance or the
dispersion of a set of values from the
mean
and you'll usually see if i'm doing a
graph i might have the value graphed
and then based on the the error i might
graph the standard deviation in the
error on the graph as a background so
you can see how far off it is
so standard deviation is used a lot
so measurement of spread marks of a
student out of a hundred we have here
from 50 to 63 or 50 to 90.
so the range maximum marks minimum marks
we have 90 to 45 and the spread of that
is 45 90 minus 45 and then we have the
interquartile range using the same marks
over there you can see here where the
median is and then there's the first
quarter the second quarter and the third
quarter based on splitting it apart by
those values
and to understand the variance and
standard deviation we first need to find
out the mean
uh so here's our our you know
calculating the average there we end up
approximately 66 for the average and
then we look at that the variance once
we know the means we can do equals the
marks minus the mean squared
why is it squared uh because one you
want to make sure it's you don't have
like if you if you're
putting all this stuff together you end
up with an error as far as one's
negative one's positive one's a little
higher one's a little lower
so you always see
the squared value and over the total
observations
and so the standard deviation equals the
square root of the variance which is
approximately 16.
and if you were looking at a predictable
model you would be looking at the
deviation based on the error how much
error does it have
that's again
really important to know if your if your
prediction is predicting something
what's the chance of it being way off or
just a little bit off
now that we've looked at the
tools as far as some of the basics for
doing your statistics and we're talking
about let's go ahead and pull up a
little demo and show you what that looks
like in python code
so you can get some little hands-on here
for that let's go in back into our
jupyter notebook and python now almost
all of this you can do in numpy last
time we worked in numpy this time we're
going to go ahead and use pandas and if
you remember from pandas on here
this is basically a data frame rows
columns let's just go ahead and do a
print
df.head
and run that
and you can see we have the name jane
michael william rosie hanna sat in their
salaries on here and of course instead
of having to do all those hand
calculations and add everything together
and divide by the total we can do
something very simple on this like
use the command mean in pandas and so if
i go and do this print df
pick our column salary because we want
to find the means of that calorie
we want to find the means of that column
and we go and print this out and you can
see that the
average income on here is 71 000.
and let's just go ahead and do this
we'll go ahead and put in
means
and if we're going to do that we also
might want to find the median
and the median is
very similar
except it actually is just median we're
used to means in average it's kind of
interesting that those are they use the
two different words
there can be in some computation slight
differences but for the most part the
means is the average
and then the median
oops let's put a
median here
do you have salary that way it displays
a little better we can see the median is
thousand so the halfway mark is
significantly below the average why
because we have somebody in here makes
189 000.
darn you rosie for throwing off our
numbers
but that's something you'd want to
notice this is this is the difference
between these is huge
and so is what is the meaning behind
that when you're studying a populist and
looking at
the different data coming in and of
course we also want to find out hey
what's the most common
income that people make
in this little tiny sample and so we'll
go ahead and do the mode
and you can see here with the mode uh
it's at fifty thousand
so this is this is very telling that
most people are making fifty thousand
the middle point is at 54 000. so half
the people are making more than that
what that tells me is that if the most
common income is weight is below the
median
then
there's a few there's a scale there's a
lot of high salaries going up but
there's some really low salaries in
there
and so this trend which is very common
in statistics and when you're analyzing
the economy and different people's
income is pretty common and the bigger
difference between these is also very
important when we're studying statistics
and when you hear someone just say hey
the average income was you might start
asking questions at that point why
aren't you talking about the median
income why aren't you talking about the
mode the most common income
what are you hiding
and if you're doing these analysis you
should be looking at these saying hey
why are these discrepancies why are
these so different and of course with
any analysis it's important to find out
the minimum
and the maximum so we'll go ahead it's
just simply uh
dot min
so pull up your minimum and then dot max
pulls up the maximum
pretty straightforward on as far
as translating it and knowing which you
know what the
lowest value which your highest value is
here
which you'll use to generate like a
spread later on and real quick on no
mode note that it puts mode 0. like i
said there's a couple different ways you
can compute the mode
although the standard one is pretty good
we can of course do the range
which is your max minus your min so now
we have a range of 149 000 between the
upper end and the lower end and you
might want to be looking at the
individual values on all of these but it
turns out there is a describe
feature in pandas
and so in pandas we can actually do df
salary describe and if we do this you
can see we have that there's seven uh
setups here's our mean
our standard deviation which we didn't
compute yet which would just be a dot
std
and you gotta be a little careful
because when it computes it it looks for
axes and things like that
uh we have our minimum value and here's
our quartiles
uh our maximum value and then of course
the name salary uh so these are these
are the basic statistics you can pull
them up and like just describe
this is a dictionary so i could actually
do something like
in here i could actually go uh count
and run
and now it just prints the count
so because this is a dictionary you can
pull any one of these values out of here
it's kind of a quick and dirty way to
pull all the different information and
then split it up and depending on what
you need
now if i just walked in and gave you
this information
in a meeting
at some point you would just kind of
fall asleep
that's what i would do anyway
um so we want to go ahead and see about
graphing it here and we'll go ahead and
put it into a histogram and plot that
graph on it
of the salaries and let's just go ahead
and put that in here so
we do our matplot inline remember that's
a jupiter's notebook thing a lot of the
new version of the matplot library does
it automatically
but just in case i always put it in
there uh import matplot library pipeline
is plt that's my plotting
and then we have our data frame uh i
don't i guess i really don't need to
respell the data frame
maybe we could just remind ourselves
what's in it so we'll go ahead and just
print
df
that way we still have it
and then we have our salary df salary
salary.plot history title salary
distribution color gray
plot ax v line salary the mean value so
we're going to take the mean value
color violet
line style dash this is just all making
it pretty
what color dashed line line width of 2
that kind of thing
and the median and let's go ahead and
run this just so you can see what we're
talking about
and so up here we are taking on our plot
um so here's the data here's our our
data frame print it out so you can see
it with the salaries we'll look at the
salary distribution and just look at
this the way the salary is distributed
um
you have our
in this case we did
let's see we had red for the median
we have violet
for our average or mean
and you can just see how it really
i mean here's our outlier here's our
person who makes a lot of money here's
the average and here's the median
and so as you look at this you can say
wow
based on the average it really doesn't
tell you much about what people are
really taking home all it does is tell
you
how much money is in this you know what
the average salary is
so
some of the things you want to take away
in addition to this is that it's very
easy to plot um
an ax v line
these are these up and down lines for
your markers
and as you just display the data i mean
you can add all kinds of things to this
and get really complicated keeping it
simple is pretty straightforward i look
at this and i can see we have a major
outlier out here we can definitely do a
histogram and stuff like that
but you know pictures worth a thousand
words what you really want to make sure
you take away is that we can do a basic
describe
which pulls all this information out and
we can print any of the individual
information from the describe
because this is a dictionary
and so if we want to go ahead and look
up
um the mean value we can also do
describe mean so if you're doing a lot
of statistics
being able to
it doesn't have the print on there so
it's only going to print the last one
which happens to be the mean
you can very easily reference any one of
these and then you can also if you're
doing something a little bit more
complicated and you don't need just the
basics you can come through and pull any
one of the individual
references from the from the pandas on
here so now we've had a chance to
describe our data
let's get into inferential statistics
inferential statistics allows you to
make predictions or inferences from data
and you can see here we have a nice
little picture movie ratings and
if we took this group of people and said
hey how many people like the movie
dislike it can't say and then you ask
just a random person who comes out of
the movie who hasn't been in this study
you can infer that 55 chance of saying
liked
35 chance of saying disliked or a 10 or
11 percent chance of can't say so that's
real basics of what we're talking about
is you're going to infer that the next
person is going to follow these
statistics
uh so let's look at point estimation uh
it is a process of finding an
approximate value for a population's
parameter like mean
or average from random samples of the
population
let's take an example of testing
vaccines for covid19
vaccines and flu bugs all that it's a
pretty big thing of how do you test
these out and make sure they're going to
work on the populace
a group of people are chosen from the
population medical trials are performed
results are generalized for the whole
population
so here's a protected there's our small
group up here where we've selected them
we run medical trials on them and then
the results work for the population
nice diagram with the arrows going back
and forth and the very scary coveted
virus in the middle of one
and let's take a look at the
applications of inferential statistics
very central is what they call
hypotheses testing
and the confidence interval which go
with that and then as we get into
probability we get into our binomial
theorem our normal distribution in
central limit theorem
hypothesis testing hypothesis testing is
used to measure the plausibility of a
hypothesis
assumption by using sample data
now
when we talk about theorems
theory
hypothesis
keep in mind that if you are in a
philosophy class
theory
is the same as hypothesis
where theorem is a scientific uh
statement that is something that has
been proven
although it is always up for debate
because in science we always want to
make sure things are up to debate so
hypothesis is the same as a
philosophical class calling a theory
where theory in science is not the same
theory in science says this has been
well proven gravity is a theory so if
you want to debate the theory of gravity
try jumping up and down if you want to
have a theory about why the economy is
collapsing in your area
that is a philosophical debate
very important i've heard people mix
those up and it is a pet peeve of mine
we talk about hypotheses testing the
steps involved in hypotheses testing is
first we formulate a hypothesis
we figure out the right test to test our
hypothesis we execute the test and we
make a decision and so when you're
talking about hypothesis you're usually
trying to disprove it if you can't
disprove it
and it works for all the facts then you
might call that a theorem at some point
so in a use case let's consider an
example we have four students we're
given a task to clean a room every day
sounds like working with my kids they
decided to distribute the job of
cleaning the room among themselves they
did so by making four chits which has
their names on it and the name that gets
picked up has to do the cleaning for
that day
rob took the opportunity to make chits
and wrote everyone's name on it so
here's our four people nick rob emlia
emilia and summer
now rick emilia and summer are asking us
to decide whether rob has done some
mischief in preparing the chits i.e
whether rob has written his name on one
of the chit
for that we will find out the
probability of rob getting the cleaning
job on first day second day third day
and so on until 12 days
the probability of rob getting the job
decreases every day i.e his turn never
comes up then definitely he has done
some mischief while making the chits
so the probability of rob not doing work
on day one is three out of four there's
a .75 chance that he didn't do work
two days three-fourths times
three-fourths equals point five six
three days you have three-fourths
three-fourths three-fourths which equals
0.42
when you get to day 12 it's 0.032 which
is less than 0.05
remember this .05 that comes up a lot
when we're talking about
certain values when we're looking at
statistics
rob is cheating as he wasn't chosen for
12 consecutive days that's a very high
probability when
on day 12 he still hasn't gotten the job
cleaning the room
so we come up to our important important
terminologies
we have null hypothesis
a general statement that states that
there is no relationship between two
measured phenomena or no
association among the groups
alternative hypothesis
contrary to the null hypothesis it
states whenever something is happening a
new theory is preferred instead of an
old one and so the two hypotheses go
hand in hand uh so your null this is
always interesting in and when talking
about data science and the math behind
it it's about proving that the things
have no correlation null hypothesis says
these two have zero relation to each
other where the alternative hypothesis
says hey we found a relation this is
what it is
we have p-value the p-value is a
probability of finding the observed or
more extreme results when the null
hypothesis of a study question is true
and the t-value it is simply the
calculated difference represented in
units of standard error the greater the
magnitude of t the greater the evidence
against the null hypothesis and you can
look at the t values being specific to
the test you're doing
where the p value is derived from your t
value and you're looking for what they
call the five percent or the 0.05
showing that it has a high correlation
so digging in deeper let's assume that a
new drug is developed with the goal of
lowering the blood pressure more than
the existing drug
and this is a good one because the null
value here isn't that you don't have any
drug the null value here is that it's
better than the existing drug the new
drug doesn't lower the blood pressure
more than the existing drug
now if we get that
that says our null hypothesis is correct
there is no correlation and the new drug
is not doing its job the alternative
hypothesis the new drug does
significantly lower the blood pressure
more than the existing drug
yay we got a new drug out there and
that's our alternative hypothesis or the
h1 or ha
and we look at the p-value results from
the evidence like medical trial showing
positive results which will reject the
null hypothesis
and again they're looking for
a 0.05 or 5 percent and the t value
comparing all the positive test results
and finding means of different samples
in order to test hypothesis so this is
specific to the test how what percentage
of increase did they have
and this leads us to the confidence
intervals
a confidence interval is a range of
values we are sure our true values of
observations lie in
let's say you asked a dog owner around
you and asked them how many cans of food
do you buy for your per year for your
dog
through calculations you got to know
that the on an average around 95 percent
of the people bought around 200 to 300
cans of food hence we can say that we
have a confidence interval of 2 300
where 95 percent of our values lie in
that spread data spread
uh and this the graph really helps a lot
so you can start seeing what you're
looking at here where you have the 95
percent you have your peak in this case
it's a normal distribution so you have a
nice bell curve equal on both sides it's
not asymmetrical and 95 of all the
values lie within a very small range and
then you have your outliers the 2.5
percent going each way
so we touched upon hypothesis uh we're
going to move into probability uh so you
have your hypothesis once you've
generated your hypothesis we want to
know the probability of something
occurring probability is a measure of
the likelihood of an event to occur any
event can be predicted with total
certainty
and can only be predicted as a
likelihood of its occurrence so any
event cannot be predicted with total
certainty can only be predicted as a
likelihood of its occurrence
score prediction how good you're going
to do in whatever
sport you're in weather prediction stock
prediction
if you've studied physics in chaos
theory even the location of the chair
you're sitting on has a probability that
it might move three feet over
granted that probability is one in like
uh i think we calculated as under one in
trillions upon trillions so it's
the better the probability the more
likely it's going to happen there are
some things that have such a low
probability
that we don't see them
so we talk about a random variable a
random variable is a variable whose
possible values are numerical outcomes
of a random phenomena so
we have the coin tossed how many
heads will occur in the series of 20
coin flips
probably you know the on average they're
10 but you really can't know because
it's very random
how many times a red ball is picked from
a bag of balls if there's equal number
of red balls and blue balls and green
balls in there how many times the sum of
digits on two dice
results are five each
um
so you know there's how often you're
going to roll two fives on your pair of
dice
so in a use case let's consider the
example of rolling two dice we have a
random variable outcome equals y you can
take values two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
so we have a random variable and a
combination of dice
and instead of looking at how many times
both dice were roll five let's go ahead
and look at total sum of five and you
have in as far as your random variables
you can have a one four equals five four
one two three three two
so four of those rolls can be four if
you look at all the different options
you have four of those random rolls can
be a five
and if we look at the total number
which happens to be 36 different options
uh you can see that we have four out of
36 chance every time you roll the dice
that you're going to roll a total of
five you can have an outcome of five
and uh we'll look a little deeper as to
what that means but you could think of
that at what point if someone never
rolls a five or they always roll a five
can you say hey that person's probably
cheating
we'll look a little closer at the math
behind that but let's just consider this
is one of the cases is rolling two dice
and gambling
there's also a binomial distribution is
the probability of getting success or
failure as an outcome in an experiment
or trial that is repeated multiple times
and the key is is by meaning two
binomial so passing or failing an exam
winning or losing a game and getting
either head or tails so if you ever see
binomial distribution it's based on a
true false kind of setup you win or lose
let's consider a use case
and let's consider the game of football
between two clubs
barcelona and dortmund the teams will
have to play a total of four matches and
we have to find out the chances of
barcelona winning the series
so we look at the total games and we're
looking at five different games or
matches
let's say that the winning chance for
barcelona is 75
or 0.75 that means that each game they
have a 75 chance that they're going to
win that game and losing chances are 25
or 0.25
clearly 0.75 plus 0.25 equals 1. so that
accounts for 100 of the game probability
for getting k wins in in matches is
calculated
and we we're talking like so if you have
five games and you want to know if i
play um how many wins in those five
games should i get what's a percentage
on those and the probability for getting
k wins and in matches is calculated by p
x equals k equals n c k p to the k q to
the n minus k
here p is the probability of success and
q is the probability of failure and so
we can do total games of n equals five
where k equals zero one two three four
five
p which is the chance of winning is
point seven five q the chance of losing
equals one minus p
which equals one minus .075 which equals
0.25 the probability that barcelona will
lose all of the matches can then just
plug in the numbers
and we end up with a .0009765625
so very small chance they're gonna lose
all their matches
and we can plug in uh the value for two
matches probability that barcelona will
win at least two matches is
0.0878 and of course we can go on to the
probability that barcelona will win
three matches the 0.26 and of course
four matches and so on and it's always
nice to take this information um and
let's find the accumulated discrete
probabilities for each of the outcomes
where barcelona has won three or more
matches x equals three x equals four x
equals five
and we end up with the p equals point
two six four plus point three nine five
plus two three seven which equals point
eight nine in reality
the probability of barcelona winning the
series is much higher than 0.75
and it's always nice to
put out a nice graph so you can actually
see the number of wins to the
probability and how that pans out with
our binomial case
continuing in our important terminology
location the location of the center of
the graph depends on the mean value and
this is some very important things so
much of the data we look at and when you
start looking at probabilities almost
always has a normalized look like the
graph in the middle
but you do have left skewed where the
data is skewed off to the left and you
have more stuff happening out to the
left and you have right skewed data
and so when this comes up and these
probabilities come up where they're
skewed it's really important to take a
closer look at that
mostly you end up with a normalized set
of data but you've got to also be aware
that sometimes it's a skewed data and
then the height height of the slope
inversely depends upon the standard
deviation
so you can see down here the standard
deviation is really large it kind of
squishes it out and if the standard
deviation is small then most of your
data is going to hit right there in the
middle you can have a nice peak
and so being aware of this that you
might have a probability that fits
certain data but it has a lot of
outliers so you're if you have a really
high standard deviation
if you're doing stock market analysis
this means your predictions are probably
not going to make you much money uh
where if you have a very small deviation
you might be right on target and set to
become a millionaire
which leads us to the z-score z-score
tells you how far from the mean a data
point is it is measured in terms of
standard deviations from the mean around
68 percent of the results are found
between one standard deviation
around 95 percent of the results are
found between two standard deviations
and you read the symbols of course they
love to throw some greek letters in
there we have mu minus two sigma
mu is just a quick way it's a kind of
funky u it just means the mean
and then the sigma is the standard
deviation and that's the o with the
little arrow off to the right or the
little
waggly tail going up the o with it with
the line on it uh so mu minus two sigma
is your
95 of the results are found between two
standard deviations
central limit theorem
this goes back to the skew if you
remember we were looking at the skew
values on this previous slide have left
skewed normalized and right skewed when
we're talking about it being skewed or
not skewed the distribution of the
sample means will be approximately
normally distributed evenly distributed
not skewed if you take large random
samples from the population with the
mean mu and the standard deviation sigma
with replacement
and you can see here
of course we have our
mu minus two sigma and the spread down
here the mean the median and the mode
and so when you're talking about very
large populations
these numbers should come together and
you shouldn't have a skewed value if you
do that's a flag that something's wrong
that's why this is so important to be
aware of what's going on with your data
where your samples are coming from
and the math behind it
if we're going to do all this we got to
jump into conditional probability
the conditional probability of an event
a is the probability that the event will
occur
given the knowledge that an event b has
already occurred and you'll see this as
bayes theorem b-a-y-e-s base
and this is read i mean you have these
funky looking little
p
brackets a b
this is the probability of a being true
while b is already true
and you have the probability of b being
true when a is already true so p
b of a
probability of a being true divided by
the probability of b being true
and we talk about bayes theorem which
occurred back in the 1800s when he
discovered this this is such an
important formula and it's really it's
not if you actually do the math you
could just kind of do
x y equals j k and then you divide them
out and you're going to see the same
math but it works with probabilities
which makes it really nice
and so if you have a set you might have
uh eight or nine different studies going
on in different areas different people
have done the studies they brought them
together
if we look at today's covered virus the
virus spread
certainly the studies done in china
versus the studies the way they're done
in the u.s
that data is different in each of those
studies but if you can find a place
where it overlaps
where they're studying the same thing
together you can then compute the
changes that you need to make in one
study to make them equal
and this is also true if you have a
study of
one group and you want to find out more
about it so this formula is very
powerful and it really has to do with
the data collection part of the math and
data science and understanding where
your data is coming from and how you're
going to combine different studies in
different groups
and we're going to go into a use case
let's find out the chance of a person
getting lung disease due to smoking
this is kind of interesting the way they
word this
let's say that according to medical
report provided by the hospital states
that around 10 percent of all patients
they treated suffered lung disease
so we have kind of a generic medical
report
they further found out
by a survey that 15 of the patients that
visit them smoke
so we have 10 percent that are lung
disease and
15 percent of the patients smoke and
finally five percent of the people
continued smoke even when they had lung
disease uh not the brightest choice um
but you know it is an addiction so it
can be really difficult to kick and so
we can look at the probability of a uh
prior probability of 10 percent people
having lung disease
and then probability b probability that
a patient smokes is 15 percent
uh and the probability of b
if b then a the probability of a patient
smokes even though they have lung
disease is 5
and probability of a is b probability
that the patient will have lung disease
if they smoke and then when you put the
formulas together you get a nice
solution here you get the probability of
a of b probability that the patient will
have lung disease if they smoke
and you can just plug the numbers right
in and we get a 3.33 percent chance
hence there is a 3.33 chance that a
person who smokes will get a lung
disease
so we're gonna pull up a little python
code i'm always my favorite roll up the
sleeves
keep in mind we're going to be doing
this
kind of like the back end way
so that you can see what's going on and
then later on we're going to create
we'll get into another demo which shows
you some of the tools are already
pre-built for this
let's start by creating a set so we're
going to create a set with curly braces
this means that our set has
only unique values so you have a list
uh you have your tuples which can never
change
and then you have
in this case the the set so four seven
you can't create a four seven comma four
it'll delete the four out so it's only
unique values
and if you use dictionaries
quick reminder this should look familiar
because it is a dictionary we have a
value and that value is assigned to or
that key is assigned to a value
so you could have a key value set up as
a dictionary so it's like a dictionary
without the value it's just the keys and
they all have to be unique
and if we run this we have a set of four
seven
we can also take a list a regular
setup and i'm going to go ahead and just
throw in another number in here 4
and run it
and you can see here if i take my list 1
2 3 4 4
and i convert it to a set and here it is
my set from list equals set my list
the result is one two three four so it
just deletes that last four right out of
there
and with the sets you can also go in
there and
print here is my set my set
uh three is in the set and then if you
do three in my set
that's going to be a logic function
and one in my set six is not in the set
and so forth if we run this
we get three is in the set true one is
in the set false because three five
seven is another one six is in the set
uh six is not in the set so not in my
set
you can also use this with the list we
could have just used three five seven
and it would have
the same response on there is three and
usually you do if three is in but three
in my set is still works on just a
regular list
and we'll go ahead and do a little
iteration we're going to do kind of the
dice one remember
one two three four five six and so we're
going to bring in the iteration tool and
import product as product
and i'll show you what that means in
just a second so we have our two dice we
have dice a
and it's going to be a set of values
they can only have one value for each
one that's why they put it in a set
and if you remember from range it is up
to seven so this is going to be one two
three four five six it will not include
the seven and the same thing for our
dice b
and then we're going to do is we're
going to create a list
which is the product
of a and b so what's a plus b
and if we go ahead and run this it'll
print that out and you'll see in this
case when they say product because it's
an iteration tool
we're talking about creating a tuple of
the two
so we've now created a tuple of all
possible outcomes of the dice where dice
a is one two three one to six and dice b
is one to six and you can see one to one
one to two one to three and so forth
you remember we had a slide on this
earlier where we talked about um
the different all the different outcomes
of a dice
we can play around with this a little
bit uh we can do in dice equals two
dice faces one two three four five six
uh another way of doing what we did
before and then we can create an event
space where we have a set which is the
product of the dice faces
repeat equals indice and we'll go ahead
and just run this
and you can see here it just again puts
it through all the different possible
variables we can have
and then if we want to take the same set
on here and print them all out like we
had before
we can just go through for outcome and
event space outcome and equals
so the event space is creating
a sequence and as you can see here when
we print it out it stacks some versus
going through and putting them in a nice
line
and we'll go ahead and do something
let's go print
since we have the end printing with a
comma that just means it's just going to
it's not going to hit the return going
down to the next line
and we'll go ahead and do the length
of our event space uh that'll be an
important variable we're going to want
to know in a minute
and of course if i get carried away with
my typing of length we'll print it twice
and it'll give me an error
so we have 36 different possible
variations here
and we might want to calculate something
like um
what about the multiple of three what if
we want to have
uh the probability of the multiple of
three in our setup
and so we can put together the code for
the outcome and event space of x y
equals outcome
if x plus y
remainder 3 so we're going to divide by
3 and look at the remainder and it
equals zero
then it's a favorable outcome we're
going to pop that outcome on the end
there
and we'll turn it into a set so the
favor outcome equals a set not necessary
uh because we know it's not going to be
repeating itself but just in case we'll
go ahead and do that
and if we want to print out the outcome
we can go ahead and see what that looks
like and you can see here these are all
multiples of three one plus two is three
five plus 4 is 9 which divided by 3 is 3
and so forth
and just like we looked up the length of
the one before let's go ahead and print
the length
of our
f outcome
so we can see what that looks like
there we go
and of course i did forget to add the
print in the middle because we're
looping through and putting an end on
the on the setup on there so we're going
to put the print in there and if i run
this you can see
we end up with 12. so we have 36 total
options
we have 12 that are multiple that add up
to a multiple of three
and we can easily conv compute the
probability of this
uh by simply taking the length
of our favorable outcome over the length
of the event space
and if we print it out let me put that
in there
probability
last lines we just type it in we end up
with a 0.3333 chance
that's roughly a third
and we want to make this look nice so
let's go ahead and put in another line
there the probability of getting the sum
which is a multiple of 3 is
0.3333
we can compute the same thing for five
dice
and if we do this for five dice and go
and run it uh you can see we just have a
huge amount of choices
so it just goes on and on down here and
we can look at
the
length of the event space
and we have over seven thousand seven
hundred and seventy six choices that's a
lot of choices
and if we wanna ask the question like we
did above uh
what is the sum where the sum is a
multiple of five but not a multiple of
three
we can go through all of these different
options and then
you can see here
d1 d2 d3 d4 d5 equals the outcome
and if you add these all together and
the
division by 5 does not have a remainder
of zero
but the remainder is also of a division
by three is not equal to zero
so the multiple of five is equal to zero
but the multiple three is not we can
just append that on here and then we can
look at that
favorable outcome
we'll go ahead and set that and we'll
just take a look at this what's our
length
of our favorable outcome
it's always good to see what we're
working with and so we have 904 out of
and then of course we can just do a
simple division to get the probability
on here what's the probability that
we're going to roll
a multiple of five when you add them
together
but not a multiple of three
and so we're just going to divide those
two numbers and you can see here we get
0.116255 or eleven point six two percent
and so you can really have a nice visual
that this is not really complicated math
right here on probabilities uh it's just
how many options do you have and how
many of those are you possibly going to
be able to come up with with the
solution you're looking for
and this leads us to a confusion matrix
a confusion matrix is a table which is
used to describe the performance of a
classification model on a set of test
data for which the true values are known
and so you'll see in the left we have
the predicted
and the actual
and we have a negative
false negative positive true positive
and then we have false positive and true
negative and you can think of this as
your predicted model what does that mean
that means if you divided your data and
you use two-third of us to create the
model
you might then test it against an actual
case for the last third to see how well
it comes out how many times was it uh
true positive versus uh
false positive it gave a false positive
response
and you can imagine in medical
situations this is a pretty big deal you
don't want to give a false positive so
you might adjust your model accordingly
so you don't have a false positive say
with a covet virus test it'd be better
to have a false negative and they go
back and get retested than to have 30
false positives where then the test is
pretty much invalid
so in a use case like cancer prediction
let's consider an example where a cancer
prediction model is put to the test for
its accuracy and precision
actual result of a person's medical
report is compared with the prediction
made by the machine learning model
and so you can see here here's our
actual predicted whether they have
cancer or not you know cancer a big one
you don't want to have a
false positive i mean a false negative
in other words you don't want to have it
tell you that you don't have cancer when
you do so that would be something you'd
really be looking for in this particular
domain you don't want a false negative
and this is again you know you've
created a model you have hundreds of
people or thousands of pieces of data
that come in
there's a real famous case study where
they have the imagery and all the
measurements they take and there's about
36 different measurements they take
and then if you run the a basic model
you want to know just how accurate it is
how many negative results do you have
that are either telling people they have
cancer that don't or telling people that
don't have cancer that they do and then
we can take these numbers and we can
feed them into our accuracy our
precision and our recall
so accuracy precision and recall
accuracy metric to measure how
accurately the results are predicted
and this is your
total
true where you got the right results you
add them together the true positive the
two negative
over all the results so what percentage
of them were accurate versus what were
wrong
we talked about precision is a metric to
measure how many of the correctly
predicted cases are actually turned out
to be positive
uh so we have a precision on
true positive again if you're talking
about like covid testing with the
viruses
you really want this to be a high number
you want this true
that to be the center point where you
might have the opposite if you're
dealing with cancer where you want no
false negatives
so this is your metric on here precision
is your test positive uh true positive
plus
false positive
and then your recall how many of the
actual positive cases we were able to
predict quickly with our model so test
positive is the test positive plus the
false negative on there and we'll want
to go ahead and do a demo on the naive
bayes classifier before i get too far
into a naive bayes classifier because
we're going to pull it from the sk learn
or the scikit
let's go ahead kind of an interesting
page here for classifiers when you go
into the sk learn kit there's a lot of
ways to do classification and i'll just
zoom up in here so you can see some of
the titles
there's everything from the nearest
neighbor linear
but we're going to be focusing on the
naive bayes over here
and this is just a sample data set that
they put together and you can see how
some of these have a very different
output
the naive bayes remember is set up as
probably the most simplified
calculator or set of predictions out
there
and so what we've been talking about
with the true false and stuff like that
where there's a
and then a belief that there is a
independent assumption between the
features where the features are very
assumed to have some kind of connection
then we can go ahead and use that for
the prediction and so that's what we're
using is a naive bayes classifier versus
many of the other classifiers that are
out there
for this we're going to use the social
network ads it's a little data set on
here
and let me go and just open that up
the file
here we go it has user id gender age
estimated salary
purchased
and so we have you can see the user id
mail 19
estimated salary 19 000
and purchased zero
so it's either going to make a purchase
or not
so look at that last one zero one we
should be thinking of binomials we
should be thinking of a simple naive
bayes classifier kind of setup
so if we close this out we're going to
go ahead and import our numpy as np
nice to have a good visual of our data
so we'll put in our matplot library
here's our pandas our data frame
and then we're going to go ahead and
import the data set and the data set's
going to be we're going to read it from
the social network ads.csv
then we're going to print the head just
so you can see it again
even though i showed you it in the file
and x equals the data set i location
two three values and y is going to be
the four
column 4. let me just run this it's a
little easier to go over that
you can see right here we're going to be
looking at
0 1 2 as age
and estimated salary so 2 3
and that's what eye location just means
that we're
looking at the number versus a regular
location a regular location you'd
actually say age and estimated salary
and then column four is did they make a
purchase they purchased something
so those are the three columns we're
going to be looking at when we do this
and we've gone ahead and imported these
and
imported the data so now our data set is
all set with this information in it
and we'll need to go ahead and split the
data up so we need our from the sklearn
model selection we can import train test
split
this does a nice job we can set the
random state so randomly picks the data
and we're just going to take uh 25
percent of it's going to go into the
test our x test and our y test and the
75 will go to x train and y train
that way once we
create our model we can then have data
to see just how accurate or how well it
has performed with our prediction
the next step in pre-processing our data
is to go ahead and do feature scaling
now a lot of this is start to look
familiar if you've done a number of the
other modules and setup you should start
noticing that we
bring in our data we take a look at what
we're working with
we go ahead and split it up into
training and testing
in this case we're going to go ahead and
scale it scale it means we're putting it
between a value of minus one and one
uh or someplace in the middle ground
there
this way if you have any huge set you
don't have this huge
setup if we go back up to here where
salary the salary is
20 000 versus age 35
well there's a good chance with a lot of
the back end math that 20 000 will skew
the results and the estimated salary
will have a higher impact than the age
instead of balancing them out and
letting the calculations weigh them
properly
and finally we get to actually create
our naive bayes model
and then we're going to go ahead and
import the gaussian naive bayes
and the gaussian is is the most basic
one that's what we're looking at now it
turns out though if you go to the sk
learn
kit
uh they have a number of different ones
you can pull in there there's a
bernoulli i know i've never used that
one categorical
complement and here's our gaussian
so there's a number of different options
you can look at
gaussian when you come to the naive
bayes is the most commonly used
so we're talking about the naive bayes
that's usually what people are talking
about when they when they're pulling
this in
and one of the nice things about the
gaussian if you go to their website
to sk learn the naive bayes gaussian
there's a lot of cool features one of
them is you can do partial fit on here
that means if you have a huge amount of
data you don't have to process it all i
want you once you can batch it into the
gaussian nb model and there's many other
different things you can do with it as
far as fitting the data and how you
manipulate it
we're just doing the basics so we're
going to go ahead and create our
classifier we're going to equal the
gaussian in b
and then we're going to do a fit we're
going to fit our training data and our
training solution so x train y train
and we'll go ahead and run this and it's
going to tell us that it ran the code
right there
and now we have our trained classifier
model
so the next step is we need to go ahead
and run a prediction we're going to do
our y predict equals the
classifier.predict
x test so here we fit the data and now
we're going to go ahead and predict
and now we get to our confusion matrix
so from
the sk learn matrix metrics you can
import your confusion matrix
just as saves you from doing all the
simple math that does it all for you
and then we'll go ahead and create our
confusion metrics with the y test and
the y predict so we have our actual
and we have our predicted value
and you can see from here this is the
chart we looked at here's predicted so
true positive false positive false
negative true negative
and if we go ahead and run this there we
have it 65 3 7 25.
and in this particular prediction we had
65 or predicted the truth as far as a
purchase they're going to make a
purchase and we guessed three wrong
and then we had 25 we predicted would
not purchase and seven of them did so
there's our our confusion matrix
at this point if you were with your
shareholders or a board meeting
you would start to hear some snoozing if
they were looking at the numbers and you
say hey here's my confusion
matrix
so let's go ahead and visualize the
results
we're going to pull from the matplot
library colors import listed color map
and this is actually my machine is going
to throw an error because
this is being
because of the way the setup is i have a
newer version on here than when they put
together the demo
and we need our x set and our y set
which is our x train and y train
and then we'll create our x1 x2
and we'll put that into a grid
and we set our x set minimum stop and
our x at max stop
and if you come all the way over here
we're going to step .01 this is going to
give us a nice line uh is what that's
doing and then we're going to plot the
contour
plot the x limit plot the y limit
and put the scatter plot in there and
let's go ahead and run this
to be honest when i'm doing these graphs
there's so many different ways to do
that there's so many different ways to
put this code together
to show you what we're doing it's a lot
easier to pull up the graph and then go
back up and explain it so the first
thing we want to note here when we're
looking at the data
is this is the training set
and so we have those who didn't make a
purchase we've drawn a nice area for
that
that's defined by the naive bayes setup
and then we have those who did make a
purchase the green and you can see that
some of the green drops fall into the
red area and some of the red dots fall
into the green
so even our training set isn't going to
be a hundred percent uh we couldn't do
that
and so we're looking at our different
data coming down
uh we can kind of arrange our x1 x2 so
we have a nice plot going on and we're
going to create the
contour
that nice line that's drawn down the
middle on here with the red green
that's where that's what this is doing
right here with the reshape and notice
that we had to
do the dot t if you remember from numpy
if you did the numpy module
you end up with pairs you know x
x1 x2 x1 x2 next row and so forth you
have to flip it so it's all one row you
have all your x1s and all your x2s
so that's what we're kind of looking for
right here on this setup
uh and then the scatter plot is of
course
your scattered data across there we're
just going through all the points that
puts these nice little dots on to our
setup on here and we have our estimated
salary and our h and then of course the
dots are did they make a purchase or not
and just a quick note this is kind of
funny you can see up here where it says
x set y set equals x train y train which
seems kind of a little weird to do
um this is because this is probably
originally a definition
so it was its own module that could be
called over and over again
and which is really a good way to do it
because the next thing we're going to
want to do is do the exact same thing
but we're going to visualize the test
set results
that way we can see what happened with
our test group our 25 percent
and you can see down here we have the
test set
and it
if you look at the two graphs next to
each other this one obviously has
75 of the data so it's going to show a
lot more
this is only 25 of the data you can see
that there's a number that are kind of
on the edge as to whether they could
guess by age and income they're going to
make a purchase or not
but that said it still is pretty clear
it's pretty good as far as how much the
estimate is and how good it does
now
graphs are really effective
for showing people what's going on but
you also need to have the numbers and so
we're going to do from sklearn we're
going to import metrics
and then we're going to print our
metrics classification port from the y
test and the y predict
and you can see here we have precision
uh precision of zeros is 90 there's our
recall
0.96 we have an f1 score and a support
and we have our precision the recall on
getting it right
and then we can do our accuracy the
macro average and the weighted average
so you can see it it pulls in
pretty good as far as how accurate it is
you could say it's going to be about 90
percent is going to guess correctly um
that it that they're not going to
purchase and we had an 89 chance that
they are going to purchase
um and then the other numbers as you get
down
have a little bit different meaning but
it's pretty straightforward on here
here's our accuracy
and here's our micro average and the
weighted average and everything else you
might need and if you forgot the exact
definition of accuracy it is the
true positive true negative over all of
the different setups precision is your
true positive overall positives true and
false
and recall is a true positive over true
positive plus false negative
and we can just real quick flip back
there
so you can see those numbers on here
here's our precision here's our recall
and here's our accuracy on this let's
look at another example machine learning
based on the amount of rainfall how much
would be the crop yield so we here we
have our crops we have our rainfall and
we want to know how much we're going to
get from our crops this year so we're
going to introduce two variables
independent and dependent the
independent variable is a variable whose
value does not change by the effect of
other variables and is used to
manipulate the dependent variable it is
often denoted as x in our example
rainfall is the independent variable
this is a wonderful example because you
can easily see that we can't control the
rain but the rain does control the crop
so we talk about the independent
variable controlling the dependent
variable let's define dependent variable
as a variable whose value change when
there is any manipulation the values of
the independent variables it is often
denoted as y and you can see here our
crop yield is dependent variable and it
is dependent on the amount of rainfall
received now that we've taken a look at
a real life example let's go a little
bit into the theory and some definitions
on machine learning and see how that
fits together with linear regression
numerical and categorical values let's
take our data coming in and this is kind
of random data from any kind of project
we want to divide it up into numerical
and categorical so numerical is numbers
age salary height where categorical
would be
a description the color a dog's breed
gender categorical is limited to very
specific items where numerical is a
range of information now that you've
seen the difference between numerical
and categorical data let's take a look
at some different machine learning
definitions we look at our different
machine learning algorithms we can
divide them into three areas
supervised
unsupervised reinforcement we're only
going to look at supervised today
unsupervised means we don't have the
answers we're just grouping things
reinforcement is where we give positive
and negative feedback to our algorithm
to program it and it doesn't have the
information until after the fact but
today we're just looking at supervised
because that's where linear regression
fits in in supervised data we have our
data already there and our answers for a
group and then we use that to program
our model and come up with an answer the
two most common uses for that is through
the regression and classification now
we're doing linear regression so we're
just going to focus on the regression
side and in the regression we have
simple linear regression we have
multiple linear regression and we have
polynomial linear regression now on
these three simple linear regression is
the examples we've looked at so far
where we have a lot of data and we draw
a straight line through it multiple
linear regression means we have multiple
variables remember where we had the
rainfall and the crops we might add
additional variables in there like how
much food do we give our crops when do
we harvest them those would be
additional information add in to our
model and that's why it'd be multiple
linear regression and finally we have
polynomial linear regression that is
instead of drawing a line we can draw a
curved line through it now that you see
where regression model fits into the
machine learning algorithms and we're
specifically looking at linear
regression let's go ahead and take a
look at applications for linear
regression let's look at a few
applications of linear regression
economic growth used to determine the
economic growth of a country or a state
in the coming quarter can also be used
to predict the gdp of a country product
price can be used to predict what would
be the price of a product in the future
we can guess whether it's going to go up
or down or should i buy today housing
sales to estimate the number of houses a
builder would sell and what price in the
coming months
score predictions cricket fever to
predict the number of runs a player
would score in the coming matches based
on the previous performance i'm sure you
can figure out other applications you
could use linear regression for so let's
jump in and let's understand linear
regression and dig into the theory
understanding linear regression
linear regression is the statistical
model used to predict the relationship
between independent and dependent
variables by examining two factors
the first important one is which
variables in particular are significant
predictors of the outcome variable and
the second one that we need to look at
closely is how significant is the
regression line to make predictions with
the highest possible accuracy if it's
inaccurate we can't use it so it's very
important we find out the most accurate
line we can get
since linear regression is based on
drawing a line through data we're going
to jump back and take a look at some
euclidean geometry the simplest form of
a simple linear regression equation with
one dependent and one independent
variable is represented by y equals
m times x plus c and if you look at our
model here we plotted two points on here
x1 and y1 x2 and y2 y being the
dependent variable remember that from
before
and x being the independent variable so
y depends on whatever x is m in this
case is the slope of the line where m
equals the difference in the y 2 minus y
1 and x2 minus x1 and finally we have c
which is the coefficient of the line or
where it happens to cross the zero axes
let's go back and look at an example we
used earlier of linear regression we're
going to go back to plotting the amount
of crop yield based on the amount of
rainfall and here we have our rainfall
remember we cannot change rainfall and
we have our crop yield which is
dependent on the rainfall so we have our
independent and our dependent variables
we're going to take this and draw a line
through it as best we can through the
middle of the data and then we look at
that we put the red point on the y axis
is the amount of crop yield you can
expect for the amount of rainfall
represented by the green dot so if we
have an idea what the rainfall is for
this year and what's going on then we
can guess how good our crops are going
to be and we've created a nice line
right through the middle to give us a
nice mathematical formula let's take a
look and see what the math looks like
behind this
let's look at the intuition behind the
regression line now before we dive into
the math and the formulas that go behind
this and what's going on behind the
scenes
i want you to note that when we get into
the case study and we actually apply
some python script that this math you're
going to see here is already done
automatically for you you don't have to
have it memorized it is however good to
have an idea what's going on so if
people reference the different terms
you'll know what they're talking about
let's consider a sample data set with
five rows and find out how to draw the
regression line we're only going to do
five rows because if we did like the
rainfall with hundreds of points of data
that would be very hard to see what's
going on with the mathematics so we'll
go ahead and create our own two sets of
data and we have our independent
variable x and our dependent variable y
and when x was 1 we got y equals 2 when
x was
2 y was 4 and so on and so on if we go
ahead and plot this data on a graph we
can see how it forms a nice line through
the middle you can see where it's kind
of grouped going upwards to the right
the next thing we want to know is what
the means is of each of the data coming
in the x and the y the means doesn't
mean anything other than the average so
we add up all the numbers and divide by
the total so 1 plus 2 plus 3 plus four
plus five over five equals three and the
same for y we get four if we go ahead
and plot the means on the graph we'll
see we get three comma four which draws
a nice line down the middle a good
estimate
here we're going to dig deeper into the
math behind the regression line now
remember before i said you don't have to
have all these formulas memorized or
fully understand them even though we're
going to go into a little more detail of
how it works and if you're not a math
wiz and you don't know if you've never
seen the sigma character before which
looks a little bit like an e
that's opened up that just means
summation that's all that is so when you
see the sigma character it just means
we're adding everything in that row and
for computers this is great because as a
programmer you can easily iterate
through each of the x y points and
create all the information you need so
in the top half you can see where we've
broken that down into pieces and as it
goes through the first two points it
computes the squared value of x the
squared value of y and x times y and
then it takes all of x and adds them up
all of y adds them up all of x squared
adds them up and so on and so on and you
can see we have the sum of equal to 15
the sum is equal to 20 all the way up to
x times y where the sum equals 66. this
all comes from our formula for
calculating a straight line where y
equals the slope times x plus the
coefficient c so we go down below and
we're going to compute more like the
averages of these and we'll explain
exactly what that is in just a minute
and where that information comes from is
called the square means error but we'll
go into that in detail in a few minutes
all you need to do is look at the
formula and see how we've gone about
computing it line by line instead of
trying to have a huge
set of numbers pushed into it and down
here you'll see where the slope m equals
and then the top part if you read
through the brackets you have the number
of data points times the sum
of x times y which we computed one line
at a time there and that's just the 66
and take all that and you subtract it
from the sum of x times the sum of y and
those have both been computed so you
have 15 times 20. and on the bottom we
have the number of lines times the sum
of x squared easily computed as 86 for
the sum minus i'll take all that and
subtract the sum of x squared and we end
up as we come across with our formula
you can plug in all those numbers which
is very easy to do on the computer you
don't have to do the math on a piece of
paper or calculator and you'll get a
slope of 0.6 and you'll get your c
coefficient if you continue to follow
through that formula you'll see it comes
out as equal to 2.2 continuing deeper
into what's going behind the scenes
let's find out the predicted values of y
for corresponding values of x using the
linear equation where m equals 0.6 and c
equals 2.2 we're going to take these
values
and we're going to go ahead and plot
them we're going to predict them so y
equals 0.6 times where x equals 1 plus
2.2 equals 2.8 so on and so on and here
the blue points represent the actual y
values and the brown points represent
the predicted y values based on the
model we created the distance between
the actual and predicted values is known
as residuals or errors
the best fit line should have the least
sum of squares of these errors also
known as e-square if we put these into a
nice chart where you can see x
and you can see why what the actual
values were and you can see why i
predict it you can easily see where we
take y minus y predicted and we get an
answer what is the difference between
those two and if we square that y minus
y prediction squared we can then sum
those squared values that's where we get
the 0.64 plus the 0.36 plus 1 all the
way down until we have a summation
equals 2.4 so the sum of squared errors
for this regression line is 2.4 we check
this error for each line and conclude
the best fit line having the least e
square value in a nice graphical
representation we can see here where we
keep moving this line through the data
points to make sure the best fit line
has the least square distance between
the data points and the regression line
now we only looked at the most commonly
used formula for minimizing the distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute errors root mean square error
etc what you want to take away from this
is whatever formula is being used you
can easily using a computer programming
and iterating through the data calculate
the different parts of it that way these
complicated formulas you see with the
different summations and absolute values
are easily computed one piece at a time
up until this point we've only been
looking at two values x and y well in
the real world it's very rare that you
only have two values when you're
figuring out a solution so let's move on
to the next topic
multiple linear regression let's take a
brief look at what happens when you have
multiple inputs so in multiple linear
regression we have well we'll start with
the simple linear regression where we
had y equals m plus x plus c and we're
trying to find the value of y now with
multiple linear regression we have
multiple variables coming in so instead
of having just x we have x1 x2 x3 and
instead of having just one slope each
variable has its own slope attached to
it as you can see here we have m1 m2 m3
and we still just have the single
coefficient so when you're dealing with
multiple linear regression you basically
take your single linear regression and
you spread it out so you have y equals
m1 times x1 plus m2 times x2
so on all the way to m to the nth x to
the nth and then you add your
coefficient on there implementation of
linear regression now we get into my
favorite part let's understand how
multiple linear regression works by
implementing it in python if you
remember before we were looking at a
company and just based on its rnd trying
to figure out its profit we're going to
start looking at the expenditure of the
company we're going to go back to that
we're going to predict his profit but
instead of predicting it just on the r d
we're going to look at other factors
like administration costs marketing
costs
and so on and from there we're going to
see if we can figure out what the profit
of that company is going to be to start
our coding we're going to begin by
importing some basic libraries and we're
going to be looking through the data
before we do any kind of linear
regression we're going to take a look at
the data to see what we're playing with
then we'll go ahead and format the data
to the format we need to be able to run
it in the linear regression model and
then from there we'll go ahead and solve
it and just see how valid our solution
is so let's start with importing the
basic libraries now i'm going to be
doing this in anaconda jupiter notebook
a very popular ide i enjoy it's such a
visual to look at and so easy to use
just any id for python will work just
fine for this so break out your favorite
python ide so here we are in our jupyter
notebook let me go ahead and paste our
first piece of code in there and let's
walk through what libraries we're
importing first we're going to import
numpy as np and then i want you to skip
one line and look at import pandas as pd
these are very common tools that you
need with most of your linear regression
the numpy which stands for number python
is usually denoted as np and you have to
almost have that for your sk learn
toolbox you always import that right off
the beginning pandas although you don't
have to have it for your sklearn
libraries it does such a wonderful job
of importing data setting it up into a
data frame so we can manipulate it
rather easily and it has a lot of tools
also in addition to that so we usually
like to use the pandas when we can and
i'll show you what that looks like the
other three lines are for us to get a
visual of this data and take a look at
it so we're going to import
matplotlibrary.pipelot as plt and then
seaborn as sns seaborn works with the
matplot library so you have to always
import matplot library and then seaborn
sits on top of it and we'll take a look
at what that looks like you could use
any of your own plotting libraries you
want there's all kinds of ways to look
at the data these are just very common
ones and the seaborne is so easy to use
it just looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody and the final
line is the amber scion map plot library
inline that is only because i'm doing an
inline ide my interface in the anaconda
jupiter notebook requires i put that in
there or you're not going to see the
graph when it comes up let's go ahead
and run this it's not going to be that
interesting so we're just setting up
variables in fact it's not going to do
anything that we can see but it is
importing these different libraries and
setup the next step is load the data set
and extract independent and dependent
variables now here in the slide you'll
see companies equals pd.read csv and it
has a long line there with the file at
the end 1000 companies.csv you're going
to have to change this to fit whatever
setup you have and the file itself you
can request just go down to the
commentary below this video and put a
note in there and simply learn we'll try
to get in contact with you and supply
you with that file so you can try this
coding yourself so we're going to add
this code in here and we're going to see
that i have companies equals pd.reader
underscore csv and i've changed this
path to match my computer c colon slash
simply learn slash 1000 underscore
companies dot csv and then below there
we're going to set the x equals to
companies under the i location and
because this is companies as a pd data
set i can use this nice notation that
says take every row that's what the
colon the first colon is comma except
for the last column that's what the
second part is or we have a colon minus
1 and we want the values set into there
so x is no longer a data set a pandas
data set but we can easily extract the
data from our pandas data set with this
notation and then y we're going to set
equal to the last row well the question
is going to be what are we actually
looking at so let's go ahead and take a
look at that and we're going to look at
the companies dot head which lists the
first five rows of data and i'll open up
the file in just a second so you can see
where that's coming from but let's look
at the data in here as far as the way
the panda sees it when i hit run you'll
see it breaks it out into a nice setup
this is what panda is one of the things
pandas is really good about is it looks
just like an excel spreadsheet you have
your rows and remember when we're
programming we always start with zero we
don't start with one so it shows the
first five rows
zero one two three four and then it
shows your different columns r d spend
administration marketing spend state
profit it even notes that the top are
column names it was never told that but
pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows why don't we go ahead and open
this file up in a csv so you can
actually see the raw data so here i've
opened it up as a text editor and you
can see at the top we have rnd spend
comma administration comma marketing
spin comma state comma profit carriage
return i don't know about you but i'd go
crazy trying to read files like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that top part the first five row now as
nice as this format is where i can see
the data to me it doesn't mean a whole
lot maybe you're an expert in business
and investments and you understand what
uh 165 349 dollars and 20 cents compared
to the administration cost of
ninety seven dollars 136
eighty cents so on so on it helps to
create the profit of a hundred ninety
two thousand two hundred sixty one and
eighty three cents that makes no sense
to me whatsoever no pun intended so
let's flip back here and take a look at
our next set of code where we're going
to graph it so we can get a better
understanding of our data and what it
means so at this point we're going to
use a single line of code to get a lot
of information so we can see where we're
going with this let's go ahead and paste
that into our notebook and see what we
got going and so we have the
visualization and again we're using sns
which is pandas as you can see we
imported the map plot library dot pi
plot as plt which then the seaborn uses
and we imported the seaborn as sns and
then that final line of code helps us
show this in our
inline coding without this it wouldn't
display and you could display it to a
file in other means and that's the matte
plot library in line with the amber sign
at the beginning so here we come down to
the single line of code seaborn is great
because it actually recognizes the panda
data frame so i can just take the
companies dot core for coordinates and i
can put that right into the seaborn and
when we run this we get this beautiful
plot and let's just take a look at what
this plot means if you look at this plot
on mine the colors are probably a little
bit more purplish and blue than the
original one we have the columns and the
rows we have r and d spending we have
administration we have marketing
spending and profit and if you cross
index any two of these since we're
interested in profit if you cross index
profit with profit it's going to show up
if you look at the scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data they have an exact
correspondence so rnd spending is going
to be the same as rnd spending and the
same thing with administration costs so
right down the middle you get this dark
row or dark um diagonal row that shows
that this is the highest corresponding
data that's exactly the same and as it
becomes lighter there's less connections
between the data so we can see with
profit obviously profit is the same as
profit and next it has a very high
correlation with r d spending which we
looked at earlier and it has a slightly
less connection to marketing spending
and even less to how much money we put
into the administration so now that we
have a nice look at the data let's go
ahead and dig in and create some actual
useful linear regression models so that
we can predict values and have a better
profit now that we've taken a look at
the visualization of this data we're
going to move on to the next step
instead of just having a pretty picture
we need to generate some hard data some
hard values so let's see what that looks
like we're going to set up our linear
regression model in two steps the first
one is we need to prepare some of our
data so it fits correctly and let's go
ahead and paste this code into our
jupyter notebook and what we're bringing
in is we're going to bring in the
sklearn pre-processing where we're going
to import the label encoder and the one
hot encoder to use the label encoder
we're going to create a variable called
label encoder and set it equal to
capital l label capital e encoder this
creates a class that we can reuse for
transferring the labels back and forth
now about now you should ask what labels
are we talking about let's go take a
look at the data we processed before and
see what i'm talking about here if you
remember when we did the companies dot
head and we printed the top five rows of
data we have our columns going across we
have column zero which is r and d
spending column one which is
administration
column two which is marketing spending
and column three is state
and you'll see under state we have new
york california florida now to do a
linear regression model it doesn't know
how to process new york it knows how to
process a number so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
change that new york california and
florida and we're going to change those
to numbers that's what this line of code
does here x equals and then it has the
colon comma 3 in brackets the first part
the colon comma means that we're going
to look at all the different rows so
we're going to keep them all together
but the only row we're going to edit is
the third row and in there we're going
to take the label coder and we're going
to fit and transform the x also the
third row so we're going to take that
third row we're going to set it equal to
a transformation and that transformation
basically tells it that instead of
having a
new york it has a zero or a one or a two
and then finally we need to do a one hot
encoder which equals one hot inc or
categorical features equals three and
then we take the x and we go ahead and
do that equal to one hot encoder fit
transform x to array this final
transformation preps our data force so
it's completely set the way we need it
as just a row of numbers even though
it's not in here let's go ahead and
print x and just take a look what this
data is doing you'll see you have an
array of arrays and then each array is a
row of numbers and if i go ahead and
just do row 0 you'll see i have a nice
organized row of numbers that the
computer now understands we'll go ahead
and take this out there because it
doesn't mean a whole lot to us it's just
a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding dummy variable trap this is
very important why because the computer
has automatically transformed our header
into the setup and it's automatically
transferring all these different
variables so when we did the encoder the
encoder created two columns and what we
need to do is just have the one because
it has both the variable and the name
that's what this piece of code does here
let's go ahead and paste this in here
and we have x equals x colon comma one
colon all this is doing is removing that
one extra column we put in there when we
did our one hot encoder and our label
encoding let's go ahead and run that and
now we get to create our linear
regression model and let's see what that
looks like here and we're going to do
that in two steps the first step is
going to be in splitting the data now
whenever we create a predictive model of
data we always want to split it up so we
have a training set and we have a
testing set that's very important
otherwise we'd be very unethical without
testing it to see how good our fit is
and then we'll go ahead and create our
multiple linear regression model and
train it and set it up let's go ahead
and paste this next piece of code in
here and i'll go ahead and shrink it
down a size or two so it all fits on one
line so from the sklearn module
selection we're going to import train
test split and you'll see that we've
created four completely different
variables we have capital x train
capital x test smaller case y train
smaller case y test
that is the standard way that they
usually reference these when we're doing
different uh models you usually see that
a capital x and you see the train and
the test and the lowercase y what this
is is x is our data going in that's our
rnd spin our administration our
marketing and then y which we're
training is the answer that's the profit
because we want to know the profit of an
unknown entity that's what we're going
to shoot for in this tutorial the next
part train test split we take x and we
take y we've already created those x has
the columns with the data in it and y
has a column with profit in it and then
we're going to set the test size equals
0.2 that basically means twenty percent
so twenty percent of the rows are going
to be tested we're gonna put them off to
the side so since we're using a thousand
lines of data that means that 200 of
those lines we're going to hold off to
the side to test for later and then the
random state equals zero we're going to
randomize which ones it picks to hold
off to the side we'll go ahead and run
this it's not overly exciting so it's
setting up our variables but the next
step is the next step we actually create
our linear regression model now that we
got to the linear regression model we
get that next piece of the puzzle let's
go ahead and put that code in there and
walk through it so here we go we're
going to paste it in there and let's go
ahead and since this is a shorter line
of code let's zoom up there so we can
get a good look and we have from the
sklearn the linear underscore model
we're going to import linear regression
now i don't know if you recall from
earlier when we were doing all the math
let's go ahead and flip back there and
take a look at that do you remember this
where we had this long formula on the
bottom and we were doing all this
summarization and then we also looked at
uh setting it up with the different
lines and then we also looked all the
way down to multiple linear regression
where we're adding all those formulas
together all of that is wrapped up in
this one section so what's going on here
is i'm going to create a variable called
regressor and the regressor equals the
linear regression that's a linear
regression model that has all that math
built in so we don't have to have it all
memorized or have to compute it
individually and then we do the
regressor.fit
in this case we do x train and y train
because we're using the training data x
being the data in and y being profit
what we're looking at and this does all
that math for us so within one click and
one line we've created the whole linear
regression model and we fit the data to
the linear regression model and you can
see that when i run the regressor it
gives an output linear regression it
says copy x equals true fit intercept
equals true in jobs equal 1 normalize
equals false it's just giving you some
general information on what's going on
with that regressor model now that we've
created our linear regression model
let's go ahead and use it and if you
remember we kept a bunch of data aside
so we're going to do a y predict
variable and we're going to put in the x
test and let's see what that looks like
scroll up a little bit paste that in
here predicting the test set results so
here we have y predict equals regressor
dot predict x test going in and this
gives us y predict now because i'm in
jupiter inline i can just put the
variable up there and when i hit the run
button it'll print that array out i
could have just as easily done print
y predict so if you're in a different
ide that's not an inline setup like the
jupiter notebook you can do it this way
print y predict and you'll see that for
the 200 different test variables we kept
off to the side it's going to produce
200 answers this is what it says the
profit are for those 200 predictions but
let's don't stop there let's keep going
and take a couple look we're going to
take just a short detail here and
calculating the coefficients and the
intercepts this gives us a quick flash
at what's going on behind the line we're
going to take a short detour here and
we're going to be calculating the
coefficient and intercepts so you can
see what those look like what's really
nice about our regressor we created is
it already has a coefficients for us we
can simply just print regressor dot
coefficient underscore when i run this
you'll see our coefficients here and if
we can do the regressor coefficient we
can also do the regressor intercept and
let's run that and take a look at that
this all came from the multiple
regression model and we'll flip over so
you can remember where this is going
into and where it's coming from you can
see the formula down here where y equals
m1 times x1 plus m2 times x2 and so on
and so on plus c the coefficient so
these variables fit right into this
formula y equals slope one times column
one variable plus slope two times column
two variable all the way to the m into
the n and x to the n plus c the
coefficient or in this case you have
minus 8.89
to the power of 2 etc etc times the
first column and the second column and
the third column and then our intercept
is the minus 1 0 3 0 0 9 point boy it
gets kind of complicated when you look
at it this is why we don't do this by
hand anymore this is why we have the
computer to make these calculations easy
to understand and calculate now i told
you that was a short detour and we're
coming towards the end of our script as
you remember from the beginning i said
if we're going to divide this
information we have to make sure it's a
valid model that this model works and
understand how good it works so
calculating the r squared value that's
what we're going to use to predict how
good our prediction is and let's take a
look what that looks like in code and so
we're going to use this from
sklearn.metrics
we're going to import r2 score that's
the r squared value we're looking at the
error so in the r2 score we take our y
test versus our y predict
y test is the actual values we're
testing that was the one that was given
to us that we know are true the y
predict of those 200 values is what we
think it was true and when we go ahead
and run this we see we get a
0.935
that's the r2 score now it's not exactly
a straight percentage so it's not saying
it's 93 percent correct but you do want
that in the upper 90s oh and higher
shows that this is a very valid
prediction based on the r2 score and if
r-squared value of 0.91 or 9-2 as we got
on our model remember it does have a
random generation involved this proves
the model is a good model which means
success yay we successfully trained our
model with certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression all right what
is logistic regression let's say your
car has not been serviced for quite a
few years and now you want to find out
if it is going to break down in the
future so this is like a classification
problem find out whether your car will
break down or not so how are we going to
perform this classification so here's
how it looks if we plot the information
along the x and y axis x is the number
of years since the last service was
performed and why is the probability of
your car breaking down and let's say
this information was this data rather
was collected from several car users
it's not just your car but several car
users so that is our labeled data so the
data has been collected and
for for the number of years and when the
car broke down and what was the
probability and that has been plotted
along x and y axis so this provides an
idea or from this
graph we can find out whether your car
will break down or not we'll see how so
first of all the probability can go from
zero to one as you all aware probability
can be between zero and one and as we
can imagine it is intuitive as well as
the number of years are on the lower
side maybe one year two years or three
years till after the service the chances
of your car breaking down are very
limited right so for example chances of
your car breaking down the probability
of your car breaking down within two
years of your last service are 0.1
probability similarly 3 years is maybe
0.3 and so on but as the number of years
increases let's say if it was six or
seven years there is almost a certainty
that your car is going to break down
that is what this graph shows so this is
an example of a application of the
classification algorithm and we will see
in little details how exactly logistic
regression is applied here one more
thing needs to be added here is that the
dependent variable's outcome
is discrete so if we are talking about
whether the car is going to break down
or not so that is a discrete value the y
that we are talking about the dependent
variable that we are talking about what
we are looking at is whether the car is
going to break down or not yes or no
that is what we are talking about so
here the outcome is discrete and not a
continuous value so this is how the
logistic regression curve looks let me
explain a little bit what exactly how
exactly we are going to
determine the class at the outcome
rather so for a logistic regression
curve a threshold has to be said saying
that because this is a probability
calculation remember this is a
probability calculation and the
probability itself will not be 0 or 1
but based on the probability we need to
decide what the outcome should be so
there has to be a threshold like for
example 0.5 can be the threshold let's
say in this case so any value of the
probability below 0.5
is considered to be 0 and any value
above 0.5 is considered to be 1. so an
output of let's say 0.8 will mean that
the car will break down so that is
considered as an output of 1 and let's
say an output of 0.29 is considered as 0
which means that the car will not break
down so that's the way logistic
regression works now let's do a quick
comparison between logistic regression
and linear regression because they both
have the term regression in them so it
can cause confusion so let's try to
remove that confusion so what is linear
regression linear regression is a
process is once again an algorithm for
supervised learning however here you're
going to find a continuous value you're
going to determine a continuous value it
could be the price of a real estate
property it could be your hike how much
hike you're going to get or it could be
a stock price these are all continuous
values these are not discrete compared
to a yes or no kind of a response that
we are looking for in logistic
regression so this is one example of a
linear regression let's say the hr team
of a company tries to find out what
should be the salary hike of an employee
so they collect all the details of their
existing employees their ratings and
their salary hikes what has been given
and that is the labeled information that
is available and the system learns from
this it is trained and it learns from
this labeled information so that when a
new employees information is fed based
on the rating it will determine what
should be the high so this is a linear
regression problem and a linear
regression example now salary is a
continuous value you can get five
thousand five thousand five hundred
five thousand six hundred it is not
discrete like a cat or a dog or an apple
or a banana these are discrete or a yes
or no these are discrete values right so
this way you are trying to find
continuous values is where we use linear
regression so let's say just to extend
on this scenario we now want to find out
whether this employee is going to get a
promotion or not so we want to find out
if that is a discrete problem right a
yes or no kind of a problem
in this case we actually cannot use
linear regression even though we may
have labeled data so this is the label
data so based on the employee rating
these are the ratings and then some
people got the promotion
and this is the ratings for which people
did not get promotion that is a no and
this is a rating for which people got
promotion we just plotted the data about
whether a person has got an employer's
got promotion or not yes no right so
there is nothing in between and what is
the employees rating okay and ratings
can be continuous that is not an issue
but the output is discrete in this case
whether employee got promotion yes no
okay so if we try to plot that and we
try to find a straight line this is how
it would look and as you can see it
doesn't look very right because looks
like there will be lot of errors thus
root mean square error if you remember
for linear regression would be very very
high and also the the values cannot go
beyond zero or beyond one so the graph
should probably look somewhat like this
clipped at zero and one but still the
straight line doesn't look right
therefore instead of using a linear
equation we need to come up with
something different and therefore the
logistic regression model looks somewhat
like this so we calculate the
probability and if we plot that
probability not in the form of a
straight line but we need to use some
other equation we will see very soon
what that equation is then it is a
gradual process right so you see here
people with some of these ratings are
not getting any promotions and then
slowly uh
at certain rating they get promotion so
that is a gradual process and
this is how the math behind logistic
regression looks so we are trying to
find the odds for a particular event
happening and this is the formula for
finding the odds so the probability of
an event happening divided by the
probability of the event not happening
so p if it is the probability of the
event happening probability of the
person getting a promotion and divided
by the probability of the person not
getting a promotion that is one minus p
so this is how you measure the odds now
the values of the odds range from 0 to
infinity so when this probability is 0
then the odds will the value of the odds
is equal to 0 and when the probability
becomes 1 then the value of the odds is
1 by 0 that will be infinity but the
probability itself remains between 0 and
1. now this is how an equation of a
straight line looks so y is equal to
beta0 plus beta 1 x where beta 0 is the
y intercept and beta 1 is the slope of
the line if we take the odds equation
and take a log of both sides then this
would look somewhat like this and the
term logistic is actually derived from
the fact that we are doing this we take
a log of px by 1 minus px this is an
extension of the calculation of odds
that we have seen right and that is
equal to beta0 plus beta1 x which is the
equation of the straight line and now
from here if you want to find out the
value of px we will see we can take the
exponential on both sides and then if we
solve that equation we will get the
equation of px like this px is equal to
1 by 1 plus e to the power of minus
beta0 plus beta1 x and recall this is
nothing but the equation of the line
which is equal to y y is equal to beta0
plus beta 1 x so that this is the
equation also known as the sigmoid
function and this is the equation of the
logistic regression all right and if
this is plotted this is how the sigmoid
curve is obtained
so let's compare linear and logistic
regression how they are different from
each other let's go back so linear
regression is solved or used to solve
regression problems and logistic
regression is used to solve
classification problems so both are
called regression but linear regression
is used for solving regression problems
where we predict continuous values
whereas logistic regression is used for
solving classification problems where we
have had to predict discrete values the
response variables in case of linear
regression are continuous in nature
whereas here they are categorical or
discrete in nature and
linear regression helps to estimate the
dependent variable when there is a
change in the independent variable
whereas here in case of logistic
regression it helps to calculate the
probability or the possibility of a
particular event happening and linear
regression as the name suggests is a
straight line that's why it's called
linear regression whereas logistic
regression is a sigmoid function and the
curve is the shape of the curve is s
it's an s curve this is another example
of application of logistic regression in
weather prediction whether it's going to
rain or not drain now keep in mind both
are used in weather prediction if we
want to find the discrete values like
whether it's going to rain or not rain
that is a classification problem we use
logistic regression but if we want to
determine what is going to be the
temperature tomorrow then we use linear
regression so just keep in mind that in
weather prediction we actually use both
but these are some examples of logistic
regression so we want to find out
whether it's going to be rain or not is
going to be sunny or not there is going
to snow or not these are all logistic
regression examples a few more examples
classification of objects this is a
again another example of logistic
regression now here of course one
distinction is that these are
multi-class classification so logistic
regression is not used in its original
form but it is used in a slightly
different form so we say whether it is a
dog or not a dog i hope you understand
so instead of saying is it a dog or a
cat or an elephant we convert this into
saying so because we need to keep it to
binary classification so we say is it a
dog or not a dog is it a cat or not a
cat so that's the way logistic
regression can be used for classifying
objects otherwise there are other
techniques which can be used for
performing multi-class classification in
healthcare logistic regression is used
to find the survival rate of a patient
so they take multiple parameters like
trauma score and age and so on and so
forth and they try to predict the rate
of survival all right now finally let's
take an example and see how we can apply
logistic regression to predict the
number that is shown in the image so
this is actually a live demo i will take
you into jupyter notebook and
show the code but before that let me
take you through a couple of slides to
explain what we are trying to do so
let's say you have an eight by eight
image and there the image has a number
one two three four and you need to train
your model to predict what this number
is so
how do we do this so the first thing is
obviously in any machine learning
process you train your model so in this
case we are using logistic regression so
and then we provide a training set to
train the model and then we test how
accurate our model is with the test data
which means that like any machine
learning process we split our initial
data into two parts training set and
test set with the training set we train
our model and then with the test set we
test the model then we get good accuracy
and then we use it for for inference
right so that is typical methodology of
training testing and then deploying of
machine learning models so let's uh take
a look at the code and see what we are
doing so i will not go line by line but
just take you through some of the blocks
so first thing we do is import all the
libraries and then we basically take a
look at the images and see what is the
total number of images we can display
using matplotlib some of the images are
a sample of these images and
then we split the data into training and
test as i mentioned earlier
and we can do some exploratory analysis
and
then we build our model we train our
model with the training set and then we
test it with our test set and find out
how accurate our model is using the
confusion matrix the heat map and use
heat map for visualizing this and i will
show you in the code what exactly is the
confusion matrix and how it can be used
for finding the accuracy in our example
we go we get an accuracy of about 0.94
which is pretty good or 94 which is
pretty good all right so what is the
confusion matrix this is an example of a
confusion matrix and
this is used for identifying the
accuracy of a
classification model or like a logistic
regression model so the most important
part in a confusion matrix is that first
of all this as you can see this is a
matrix and the size of the matrix
depends on how many outputs we are
expecting right
so
the most important part here is that the
model will be most accurate when we have
the maximum numbers in its diagonal like
in this case that's why it has almost 93
94 percent because the diagonal should
have the maximum numbers and the others
other than diagnose the cells other than
the diagonals should have very few
numbers so here that's what is happening
so there is a two here there are there's
a one here but most of them are along
the diagonal this what does this mean
this means that the
number that has been fed is zero and the
number that has been detected is also
zero so the predicted value and the
actual value are the same so along the
diagonals that is true which means that
let's let's take this diagonal right
if the maximum number is here that means
that like here in this case it is 34
which means that 34 of the images that
have been fed or rather actually there
are two misclassifications in there so
36 images have been fed which have
number four and out of which 34 have
been predicted correctly as number four
and one has been predicted as number
eight and another one has been predicted
as number nine so these are two
misclassifications
okay so that is the meaning of saying
that the maximum number should be in the
diagonal so if you have all of them so
for an ideal model which has let's say
100 accuracy everything will be only in
the diagonal there will be no numbers
other than zero in all other cells so
that is like a hundred percent accurate
model okay so that's uh just of how to
use this matrix
how to use this confusion matrix i know
the name
is a little funny sounding confusion
matrix but actually it is not very
confusing it's very straightforward so
you are just plotting what has been
predicted and what is the labeled
information or what is the actual data
that's also known as the ground truth
sometimes okay these are some fancy
terms that are used so predicted label
and the actual name that's all it is
okay yeah so we are showing a little bit
more information here so 38 have been
predicted and here you will see that all
of them have been predicted correctly
there have been 38 zeros and
the predicted value and the actual value
is exactly the same whereas in this case
right it has
there are i think 37 plus five yeah 42
have been fed the images 42 images are
of digit 3 and
the accuracy is only 37 of them have
been accurately predicted three of them
have been predicted as number seven and
two of them have been predicted as
number eight and so on and so forth okay
all right so with that let's go into
jupiter notebook and see how the code
looks so this is the code in
in jupiter notebook for logistic
regression in this particular demo what
we are going to do is train our model to
recognize digits
which are the images which have digits
from let's say 0 to 5 or 0 to 9 and
and then we will see how well it is
trained and whether it is able to
predict these numbers correctly or not
so let's get started so the first part
is as usual we are importing some
libraries that are required and
then the last line in this block is to
load the digits so let's go ahead and
run this code then
here we will visualize the shape of
these digits so we can see here if we
take a look this is how the shape is
by 64. these are like eight by eight
images so that's that's what is
reflected in this uh shape now from here
onwards we are basically once again
importing some of the libraries that are
required like numpy and matplot and we
will take a look at some of the sample
images that we have unloaded so this one
for example creates a figure and then we
go ahead and take a few sample images to
see how they look so let me run this
code and so that it becomes easy to
understand so these are about five
images sample images that we are looking
at zero one two three four so this is
how the image is this is how the data is
okay and uh based on this we will
actually train our logistic regression
model and then we will test it and see
how well it is able to recognize so the
way it works is the pixel information so
as you can see here this is an 8 by 8
pixel kind of a
image and
the each pixel whether it is activated
or not activated that is the information
available for each pixel now based on
the pattern of this activation and
non-activation of the various pixels
this will be identified as a zero for
example right similarly as you can see
so overall each of these numbers
actually has a different pattern of the
pixel activation and that's pretty much
that our model needs to learn uh for
which a number what is the pattern of
the activation of the pixels right so
that is what we are going to train our
model okay so the first thing we need to
do is to split our data into training
and test data set right so whenever we
perform any training we split the data
into training and test so that the
training data set is used to train the
system so we pass this probably multiple
times
and then we test it with the test data
set and the split is usually in the form
of there and there are various ways in
which you can split this data it is up
to the individual preferences in our
case here we are splitting in the form
of 23 and 77 so when we say test size as
20 0.23 that means 23 percent of that
entire data
is used for testing and the remaining 77
percent is used for training so there is
a readily available function which is uh
called train test split so we don't have
to write any special code for the
splitting it will automatically split
the data based on the proportion that we
give here which is test size so we just
give the test size automatically
training size will be determined and
we pass the data that we want to split
and the the results will be stored in x
underscore train and y underscore train
for the training data set and what is x
underscore train these are these are the
features right which is like the
independent variable and why underscore
train is the label right so in this case
what happens is we have the input value
which is or the features value which is
in x underscore train and since this is
the labeled data for each of them each
of the observations we already have the
label information saying whether this
digit is a zero or a one or a two so
that this this is what will be used for
comparison to find out whether the the
system is able to recognize it correctly
or there is an error for each
observation it will compare with this
right so this is the label so the same
way x underscore train y underscore
train is for the training data set x
underscore test y underscore test is for
the test data set okay so let me go
ahead and execute this code as well and
then we can go and check quickly what is
the how many entries are there and in
each of this so x underscore train the
shape is 13 83
by 64. and y underscore train has 1383
because there is nothing like the second
part is not required here and then x
underscore test shape
we see is four one four so actually
there are 414 observations in test and
1383 observations in train so that's
basically what these four lines of code
are saying okay then we import the
logistic regression library and which is
a part of scikit learn so
we we don't have to implement the
logistic regression process itself we
just call this the function and let me
go ahead and execute that so that
we have the logistic regression library
imported now we create an instance of
logistic regression right so logistic
regr is a is an instance of logistic
regression and then we use that for
training our model so let me first
execute this code so these two lines so
the first line basically creates an
instance of logistic regression model
and then the second line is where we are
passing our data the training data set
and this is our the the predictors and
uh this is our target we are passing
this data set to train our model all
right so
once we do this in this case the data is
not large but by and large the training
is what takes usually a lot of time so
we spend in machine learning
activities and machine learning projects
we spend a lot of time for the training
part of it okay so here the data set is
relatively small so it was pretty quick
so all right so now our model has been
trained using the training data set and
we want to see how accurate this is so
what we'll do is we will test it out in
probably faces so let me first try out
how well this is working for
one image okay i will just try it out
with one image my the first entry in my
test data set and see whether it is
correctly predicting or not so
and in order to test it so for training
purpose we use the fit method there is a
method called fit which is for training
the model and once the training is done
if you want to test for a particular
value new input you use the predict
method okay so let's run the predict
method and we pass this particular image
and
we see that the
shape is or the prediction is 4. so
let's try a few more let me see for the
next 10
seems to be fine so let me just go ahead
and test the entire data set okay that's
basically what we will do so now we want
to find out how accurately this has uh
performed so we use the score method to
find what is the percentage of accuracy
and we see here that it has performed up
to 94 to accurate okay so that's on this
part now what we can also do is we can
um also see this accuracy using what is
known as a confusion matrix so let us go
ahead and try that as well so that we
can also visualize how well this model
has
done
so let me execute this piece of code
which will basically import some of the
libraries that are required and
we we basically create a confusion
matrix and instance of confusion matrix
by running confusion matrix and passing
these values so we have so this
confusion underscore matrix method takes
two parameters one is the y underscore
test and the other is the prediction so
what is the y underscore test these are
the labeled values which we already know
for the test data set and predictions
are what the system has predicted for
the test data set okay so this is known
to us
and this is what the system has
the model has generated so we kind of
create the confusion matrix and we will
print it and this is how the confusion
matrix looks as the name suggests it is
a matrix and
the key point out here is that the
accuracy of the model is determined by
how many numbers are there in the
diagonal the more the numbers in the
diagonal the better the accuracy is
okay and first of all the total sum of
all the numbers in this whole matrix is
equal to the number of observations in
the test data set that is the first
thing right so if you add up all these
numbers that will be equal to the number
of
observations in the test data set and
then out of that the maximum number of
them should be in the diagonal that
means the accuracy is pretty good if the
the numbers in the diagonal are less and
in all other places there are a lot of
numbers which means the accuracy is very
low the diagonal indicates a correct
prediction that this means that the
actual value is same as the predicted
value here again actual values same as
the predictive value and so on right so
the moment you see a number here that
means the actual value is something and
the predicted value is something else
right similarly here the actual value is
something and the predicted value is
something else so that is basically how
we read the confusion matrix now how do
we find the accuracy you can actually
add up the total values in the diagonal
so it's like 38 plus 44 plus 43 and so
on and divide that by the total number
of test observations that will give you
the percentage accuracy using a
confusion matrix now let us visualize
this confusion matrix in a slightly more
sophisticated way uh using a heat map so
we will create a heat map with some
we'll add some colors as well it's uh
it's like a more visually visually more
appealing so that's the whole idea so if
we let me run this piece of code and
this is how the heat map looks
and as you can see here the diagonals
again are all the values are here most
of the values so which means reasonably
this seems to be reasonably accurate and
yeah basically the accuracy score is 94
percent this is calculated as i
mentioned by adding all these numbers
divided by the total test value so the
total number of observations in test
data set okay
so this is the confusion matrix for
logistic regression
[Music]
all right so now that we have seen the
confusion matrix let's take a quick
sample and see how well the system has
classified and we will take a few
examples of the data so if we see here
we we picked up randomly a few of them
so this is number four which is the
actual value and also the predicted
value both are four
this is an image of zero so the
predicted value is also zero actual
value is of course zero
then this is the image of nine so this
has also been predicted correctly 9 and
actual value is 9 and this is the image
of 1 and again this has been predicted
correctly as like the actual value okay
so this was a quick demo of logistic
regression how to use logistic
regression to identify
images
what is a decision tree let's go through
a very simple example before we dig in
deep decision tree is a tree shape
diagram used to determine a course of
action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision or
current or reaction let's start with a
simple question how to identify a random
vegetable from a shopping bag so we have
this group of vegetables in here and we
can start off by asking a simple
question is it red and if it's not then
it's going to be the purple fruit to the
left probably an eggplant if it's true
it's going to be one of the red fruits
is the diameter greater than 2 if false
is going to be a what looks to be a red
chili and if it's true it's going to be
a bell pepper from the capsicum family
so it's a capsicum
problems that decision tree can solve so
let's look at the two different
categories the decision tree can be used
on it can be used on the classification
the true false yes no and it can be used
on regression where we figure out what
the next value is in a series of numbers
or a group of data in classification the
classification tree will determine a set
of logical if-then conditions to
classify problems for example
discriminating between three types of
flowers based on certain features in
regression a regression tree is used
when the target variable is numerical or
continuous in nature we fit the
regression model to the target variable
using each of the independent variables
each split is made based on the sum of
squared error
before we dig deeper into the mechanics
of the decision tree let's take a look
at the advantages of using a decision
tree and we'll also take a glimpse at
the disadvantages the first thing you'll
notice is that it's simple to understand
interpret and visualize it really shines
here because you can see exactly what's
going on in a decision tree little
effort is required for data preparation
so you don't have to do special scaling
there's a lot of things you don't have
to worry about when using a decision
tree it can handle both numerical and
categorical data as we discovered
earlier and non-linear parameters don't
affect its performance so even if the
data doesn't fit an easy curved graph
you can still use it to create an
effective decision or prediction
if we're going to look at the advantages
of a decision tree we also need to
understand the disadvantages of a
decision tree the first disadvantage is
overfitting overfitting occurs when the
algorithm captures noise in the data
that means you're solving for one
specific instance instead of a general
solution for all the data high variance
the model can get unstable due to small
variation in data low bias tree a highly
complicated decision tree tends to have
a low bias which makes it difficult for
the model to work with new data
decision tree important terms before we
dive in further we need to look at some
basic terms we need to have some
definitions to go with our decision tree
and the different parts we're going to
be using we'll start with entropy
entropy is a measure of randomness or
unpredictability in the data set for
example we have a group of animals in
this picture there's four different
kinds of animals and this data set is
considered to have a high entropy you
really can't pick out what kind of
animal it is based on looking at just
the four animals as a big clump of
entities so as we start splitting it
into subgroups we come up with our
second definition which is information
gain information gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split so in this case based on the
color yellow we've split one group of
animals on one side as true and those
who aren't yellow as false as we
continue down the yellow side we split
based on the height true or false equals
10 and on the other side height is less
than 10 true or false and as you see as
we split it the entropy continues to be
less and less and less and so our
information gain is simply the entropy
e1 from the top and how it's changed to
e2 on the bottom and we'll look at the
deeper math although you really don't
need to know a huge amount of math when
you actually do the programming in
python because it'll do it for you but
we'll look on the actual math of how
they compute entropy finally we went on
the different parts of our tree and they
call the leaf node leaf node carries the
classification or the decision so it's
the final end at the bottom the decision
node has two or more branches this is
where we're breaking the group up into
different parts and finally you have the
root note the top most decision note is
known as the root node
how does a decision tree work wonder
what kind of animals i'll get in the
jungle today maybe you're the hunter
with the gun or if you're more into
photography you're a photographer with a
camera so let's look at this group of
animals and let's try to classify
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree so
the problem statement is to classify the
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree the
data set is looking quite messy and the
entropy is high in this case so let's
look at a training set or a training
data set and we're looking at color
we're looking at height and then we have
our different animals we have our
elephants our giraffes our monkeys and
our tigers and there of different colors
and shapes let's see what that looks
like and how do we split the data we
have to frame the conditions that split
the data in such a way that the
information gain is the highest note
gain is the measure of decrease in
entropy after splitting so the formula
for entropy is the sum that's what this
symbol looks like that looks like kind
of like a e funky e of k where i equals
1 to k k would represent the number of
animals the different animals in there
where value or p
value of i would be the percentage of
that animal times the log base two of
the same the percentage of that animal
let's try to calculate the entropy for
the current data set and take a look at
what that looks like and don't be afraid
of the math you don't really have to
memorize this math just be aware that
it's there and this is what's going on
in the background and so we have three
giraffes two tigers one monkey two
elephants a total of eight animals
gather and if we plug that into the
formula we get an entropy that equals
three over eight so we have three
giraffes a total of eight times the log
usually they use base two on the log so
log base two of three over eight plus in
this case i say it's the elephants two
over eight two elephants over total of
eight times log base two two over eight
plus one monkey over total of eight log
base two one over eight and plus two
over eight of the tigers log base 2 over
8. and if we plug that into our computer
or calculator i obviously can't do logs
in my head we get an entropy equal to
0.571
the program will actually calculate the
entropy of the data set similarly after
every split to calculate the gain now
we're not going to go through each set
one at a time to see what those numbers
are we just want you to be aware that
this is a formula or the mathematics
behind it gain can be calculated by
finding the difference of the subsequent
entropy values after a split now we will
try to choose a condition that gives us
the highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking that the gain we get out of
them the condition that gives us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split can you guess what that
first split will be just by looking at
this image as a human is probably pretty
easy to split it let's see if you're
right if you guessed the color yellow
you're correct let's say the condition
that gives us the maximum gain is yellow
so we will split the data based on the
color yellow if it's true that group of
animals goes to the left if it's false
it goes to the right the entropy after
the splitting has decreased considerably
however we still need some splitting of
both the branches to attain an entropy
value equal to zero so we decide to
split both the nodes using height as the
condition since every branch now
contains single label type we can say
that entropy in this case has reached
the least value and here you see we have
the giraffes the tigers the monkey and
the elephants all separated into their
own groups this tree can now predict all
the classes of animals present in the
dataset with a hundred percent accuracy
that was easy
use case loan repayment prediction let's
get into my favorite part and open up
some python and see what the programming
code in the scripting looks like in here
we're going to want to do a prediction
and we start with this individual here
who's requesting to find out how good
his customers are going to be whether
they're going to be pay their loan or
not for this bank and from that we want
to generate a problem statement to
predict if a customer will repay loan
amount or not and then we're going to be
using the decision tree algorithm in
python let's see what that looks like
and let's dive into the code in our
first few steps of implementation we're
going to start by importing the
necessary packages that we need from
python and we're going to load up our
data and take a look at what the data
looks like so the first thing i need is
i need something to edit my python and
run it in so let's flip on over and here
i'm using the anaconda jupiter notebook
now you can use any python ide you like
to run it in but i find the jupyter
notebooks really nice for doing things
on the fly and let's go ahead and just
paste that code in the beginning and
before we start let's talk a little bit
about what we're bringing in and then
we're going to do a couple things in
here we have to make a couple changes as
we go through this first part of the
import the first thing we bring in is
numpy as np that's very standard when
we're dealing with mathematics
especially with uh very complicated
machine learning tools you almost always
see the numpy come in for your num your
number it's called number python it has
your mathematics in there in this case
we actually could take it out but
generally you'll need it for most of
your different things you work with and
then we're going to use pandas as pd
that's also a standard the pandas is a
data frame setup and you can liken this
to taking your basic data and storing it
in a way that looks like an excel
spreadsheet so as we come back to this
when you see np or pd those are very
standard uses you'll know that that's
the pandas and i'll show you a little
bit more when we explore the data in
just a minute then we're going to need
to split the data so i'm going to bring
in our train test and split and this is
coming from the sk learn package cross
validation in just a minute we're going
to change that and we'll go over that
too and then there's also the sk.tree
import decision tree classifier that's
the actual tool we're using remember i
told you don't be afraid of the
mathematics it's going to be done for
you well the decision tree classifier
has all that mathematics in there for
you so you don't have to figure it back
out again and then we have
sklearn.metrics
for accuracy score we need to score our
our setup that's the whole reason we're
splitting it between the training and
testing data and finally we still need
the sklearn import tree and that's just
a basic tree function is needed for the
decision tree classifier and finally
we're going to load our data down here
and i'm going to run this and we're
going to get two things on here one
we're going to get an error and two
we're going to get a warning let's see
what that looks like so the first thing
we had is we have an error why is this
error here well it's looking at this it
says i need to read a file and when this
was written
the person who wrote it
this is their path where they stored the
file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and i'm going to put in here my file
path i'm just going to call it full file
name
and you'll see it's on my c drive and
this is very lengthy setup on here where
i stored the data2.csv file
don't worry too much about the full path
because on your computer it'll be
different
the
csv file was generated by simplylearn
if you want a copy of that you can
comment down below and request it here
in the youtube
and then if i'm going to give it a name
full file name
i'm going to go ahead and change it here
to full
file name so let's go ahead and run it
now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding
understanding these different warnings
and these different errors that come up
is probably the hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a opportunity to
understand what's going on here
if you read the warning it says the
cross validation is depreciated so it's
a warning on it's being removed
and it's going to be moved in favor of
the model selection
so if we go up here we have sklearn dot
cross validation and if you research
this and go to the sk learn site you'll
find out that you can actually just swap
it right in there with
model selection
and so when i come in here and i run it
again
that removes a warning
what they've done is they've had two
different developers develop it in two
different branches
and then they decided to keep one of
those and eventually get rid of the
other one that's all that is and very
easy and quick to fix
before we go any further i went ahead
and opened up the data
from this file remember the the data
file we just loaded on here the data
underscore 2.csv let's talk a little bit
more about that and see what that looks
like both as a text file because it's a
comma separated variable file and in a
spreadsheet
this is what it looks like as a basic
text file you can see at the top they've
created a header and it's got one two
three four five columns and each column
has data in it and let me flip this over
because we're also going to look at this
uh in an actual spreadsheet so you can
see what that looks like and here i've
opened it up in the open office calc
which is pretty much the same as excel
and zoomed in and you can see we've got
our columns and our rows of data a
little easier to read in here we have a
result yes yes no we have initial
payment last payment credit score
house number
if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with uh the first one being a column and
then one thousand lines of data
now as a programmer
if you're looking at a small amount of
data i usually start by pulling it up in
different sources so i can see what i'm
working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it'll just be too too large so
you need to either bring in a small
amount that you can look at it like
we're doing right now or we can start
looking at it through the python code so
let's go ahead and move on and take the
next couple steps to explore the data
using python let's go ahead and see what
it looks like in python to print the
length and the shape of the data so
let's start by printing the length of
the database we can use a simple lin
function from python
and when i run this
you'll see that it's a thousand long and
that's what we expected there's a
thousand lines of data in there if you
subtract the column head
this is one of the nice things when we
did the uh balance data from the panda
read csv
you'll see that the header is row zero
so it automatically removes a row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting that data out for us
and then we can use a different function
and let's take a look at that
and again we're going to utilize the
tools in panda
and since the balance underscore data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines it also tells
me there's five columns so we were
looking at the data we had five columns
of data and then let's take one more
step to explore the data using python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape let's go ahead and
use the
pandas module for head another beautiful
thing in the data set that we can
utilize so let's put that on our sheet
here and we have print data set
and balance data dot head and this is a
pandas print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there and
then we went ahead and gave a label for
a print job here of data set just a
simple print statement
and we run that
and let's just take a closer look at
that let me zoom in here
there we go
pandas do such a wonderful job of making
this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it when you put it as the
head
it prints the first five lines of the
data
and we always start with zero so we have
five lines we have zero one two three
four instead of one two three four five
that's a standard scripting and
programming set as you want to start
with the zero position and that is what
the data head does it pulls the first
five rows of data puts in a nice format
that you can look at and view very
powerful tool to view the data so
instead of having to flip and open up an
excel spreadsheet or open office cal or
trying to look at a
word doc where it's all scrunched
together and hard to read you can now
get a nice open view of what you're
working with we're working with a shape
of a thousand long five wide so we have
five columns and we do the full data
head you can actually see what this data
looks like the initial payment last
payment credit scores house number so
let's take this now that we've explored
the data and let's start digging into
the decision tree so in our next step
we're going to train and build our data
tree and to do that we need to first
separate the data out we're going to
separate into two groups so that we have
something to actually train the data
with and then we have some data on the
side to test it to see how good our
model is remember with any of the
machine learning you always want to have
some kind of test set to to weigh it
against so you know how good your model
is when you distribute it let's go ahead
and break this code down and look at it
in pieces
so first we have our x and y
where do x and y come from well x is
going to be our data
and y is going to be the answer or the
target you can look at its source and
target in this case we're using x and y
to denote the data in and the data that
we're actually trying to guess what the
answer is going to be and so to separate
it we can simply put in x equals the
balance of the data.values the first
brackets
means that we're going to select all the
lines
in the database so it's all the data
and the second one says we're only going
to look at columns one through five
remember i always start with zero zero
is a yes or no
and that's whether the loan went default
or not so we want to start with 1. if we
go back up here that's the initial
payment and it goes all the way through
the house number
well if we want to look at 1 through 5
we can do the same thing for y which is
the answers and we're going to set that
just equal to the zero row so it's just
the zero row and then it's all rows
going in there so now we've divided this
into two different data sets
one of them with the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your x training your x
test your y train your y test
simply put we have x going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have x test where we're
going to test that data
and we have to know in the end what the
y was supposed to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules this does it all for us and you
can see they set the test size equal to
0.3 so that's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there and
then finally we get to actually build
our decision tree and they've called it
here clf underscore entropy that's the
actual decision tree or decision tree
classifier and in here they've added a
couple variables which we'll explore in
just a minute and then finally we need
to fit the data to that so we take our
clf entropy that we created and we fit
the x train and since we know the
answers for x trait or the y train we go
ahead and put those in and let's go
ahead and run this and what most of
these sklearn modules do is when you set
up the variable in this case we set the
clf entropy called decision tree
classifier it automatically prints out
what's in that decision tree there's a
lot of variables you can play within
here and it's quite beyond the scope of
this
tutorial to go through all of these and
how they work but we're working on
entropy that's one of the options we've
added that it's completely a random
state of 100 so 100 percent and we have
a max depth of three now the max depth
if you remember above when we were doing
the different graphs of animals means
it's only going to go down three layers
before it stops and then we have minimal
samples of leaves as five so it's going
to have at least five leaves at the end
so i'll have at least three splits i'll
have no more than three layers and at
least five end leaves with the final
result at the bottom now that we've
created
our decision tree classifier not only
created it but trained it let's go ahead
and apply it and see what that looks
like so let's go ahead and make a
prediction and see what that looks like
we're going to paste our predict code in
here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what's it's doing here
we have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our
variable clf entropy that we created
and then you'll see dot predict and it's
very common in the sk learn modules
that their different tools have to
predict when you're actually running a
prediction
in this case we're going to put our x
test data in here
now if you delivered this for use an
actual commercial use and distributed it
this would be the new loans you're
putting in here to guess
whether the person is going to be pay
them back or not
in this case so we need to test out the
data and just see how good our sample is
how good of our tree does at predicting
the loan payments and finally since
anaconda jupiter notebook works as a
command line for python we can simply
put the y predict e in to print it i
could just as easily have put the print
and put brackets around y predict en to
print it out we'll go ahead and do that
it doesn't matter which way you do it
and you'll see right here that runs a
prediction this is roughly 300 in here
remember it's 30 percent of a thousand
so you should have about 300 answers in
here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our test went in there
and this is what our why predict came
out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data and try to
figure out just how good a model we have
so here we go since sklearn does all the
heavy lifting for you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is and let's go
ahead and go through that and see what
that means and what that looks like
let's go ahead and paste this in and let
me zoom in a little bit
there we go
so you have a nice full picture and
we'll see here we're just going to do a
print accuracy is
and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see where that's
coming from
that's coming from here down here from
sklearn.metrics
import accuracy score
and you could probably run a script make
your own script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
do we get right and so we put in our y
test that's the one we ran the predict
on and then we put in our y predict e n
that's the answers we got
and we're just going to multiply that by
a hundred because this is just going to
give us an answer as a decimal and we
want to see it as a percentage
let's run that and see what it looks
like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of 93.66667
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit we
can tell people it has about a 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that we now have accuracy set up on here
and so we have created a model that uses
the decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not the accuracy of the model is
about 94.6 percent the bank can now use
this model to decide whether it should
approve the loan request from a
particular customer or not and so this
information is really powerful we may
not be able to as individuals understand
all these numbers because they have
thousands of numbers that come in but
you can see that this is a smart
decision for the bank to use a tool like
this to help them to predict how good
their profits going to be off of the
loan balances and how many are going to
default or not so why random forest it's
always important to understand
why we use this tool over the other ones
what are the benefits here and so with a
random forest the first one is there's
no overfitting if you use of multiple
trees reduce the risk of overfitting
training time is less overfitting means
that we have fit the data so close to
what we have as our sample that we pick
up on all the weird parts and instead of
predicting the overall data you're
predicting the weird stuff which you
don't want
high accuracy runs efficiently in large
database for large data it produces
highly accurate predictions
in today's world of big data this is
really important and this is probably
where it really shines this is where why
random forest really comes in it
estimates missing data data in today's
world is very messy so when you have a
random forest it can maintain the
accuracy when a large proportion of the
data is missing what that means is if
you have data that comes in from five or
six different areas and maybe they took
one set of statistics in one area
and they took a slightly different set
of statistics in the other so they have
some of the same same shared data but
one is missing like the number of
children in the house if you're doing
something over demographics and the
other one is missing the size of the
house it will look at both of those
separately and build two different trees
and then it can do a very good job of
guessing which one fits better even
though it's missing that data let us dig
deep into the theory of exactly how it
works
and let's look at what is a random
forest
random forest or random decision forest
is a method that operates by
constructing multiple decision trees the
decision of the majority of the trees is
chosen by the random forest as a final
decision and this uh we have some nice
graphics here we have a decision tree
and they actually use a real tree to
denote the decision tree which i love
and given a random some kind of picture
of a fruit this decision tree decides
that the output is it's an apple and we
have a decision tree two where we have
that picture of the fruit goes in and
this one decides that it's a lemon and
the decision three tree gets another
image and it decides it's an apple and
then this all comes together in what
they call the random forest in this
random forest then looks at it and says
okay i got two votes for apple one vote
for lemon the majority is apples so the
final decision is apples to understand
how the random forest works we first
need to dig a little deeper and take a
look at the random forest and the actual
decision tree and how it builds that
decision tree in looking closer at how
the individual decision trees work we'll
go ahead and continue to use the fruit
example since we're talking about trees
and forests a decision tree is a tree
shaped diagram used to determine a
course of action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction so in here we
have a bowl of fruit and if you look at
that it looks like they switch from
lemons to oranges we have oranges
cherries and apples and the first
decision of the decision tree might be
is a diameter greater than or equal to
three and if it says false it knows that
they're cherries because everything else
is bigger than that so all the cherries
fall into that decision so we have all
that data we're training we can look at
that we know that that's what's going to
come up
is the color orange well goes hmm orange
or red well if it's true
then it comes out as the orange and if
it's false that leaves apples so in this
example it sorts out the fruit in the
bowl or the images of the fruit a
decision tree these are very important
terms to know because these are very
central to understanding the decision
tree and when working with them the
first is entropy
everything on the decision tree and how
it makes this decision is based on
entropy entropy is a measure of
randomness or unpredictability in the
data set
then they also have information gain
the leaf node the decision node and the
root node we'll cover these other four
terms as we go down the tree but let's
start with entropy
so starting with entropy we have here a
high amount of randomness what that
means is that whatever is coming out of
this decision if it was going to guess
based on this data
it wouldn't be able to tell you whether
it's a lemon or an apple it would just
say it's a fruit
so the first thing we want to do is we
want to split this apart and we take the
initial data set we're going to create a
data set one and a data set two we just
split it in two and if you look at these
new
data sets after splitting them the
entropy of each of those sets is much
less so for the first one whatever comes
in there it's going to sort that data
and it's going to say okay if this data
goes this direction it's probably an
apple and if it goes into the other
direction it's probably a lemon so that
brings us up to information gain it is
the measure of decrease in the entropy
after the data set is split what that
means in here is that we've gone from
one set which has a very high entropy to
two lower sets of entropy and we've
added in the values of e1 for the first
one and e2 for the second two which are
much lower and so that information gain
is increased greatly in this example and
so you can find that the information
grain simply equals
decision e1
minus e2 as we're going down our list of
definitions we'll look at the leaf node
and the leaf node
carries the classification or the
decision
so we look down here to the leaf node we
finally get to our set one or our set
two
when it comes down there and it says
okay this object's gone into set one
if it's gone into set one
it's going to be split by some means and
we'll either end up with apples on the
leaf node or a lemon on the leaf node
and on the right it'll either be an
apple or lemons those leaf nodes are
those final decisions or classifications
that's the definition of leaf node in
here if we're going to have a final leaf
where we make the decision
we should have a name for the nodes
above it and they call those decision
nodes
a decision node decision node has two or
more branches and you can see here where
we have the
five apples and one lemon and in the
other case the five lemons in one apple
they have to make a choice of which tree
it goes down
based on some kind of measurement or
information given to the tree
and that brings us to our last
definition
the root node the top most decision node
is known as the root node and this is
where you have all of your data and you
have your first decision it has to make
or the first split in information
so far we've looked at a very general
image
with the fruit being split let's look
and see exactly what that means to split
the data and how do we make those
decisions on there
let's go in there and find out how does
a decision tree work
so let's try to understand this and
let's use a simple example and we'll
stay with the fruit we have a bowl of
fruit and so let's create a problem
statement and the problem is we want to
classify the different types of fruits
in the bowl based on different features
the data set in the bowl is looking
quite messy and the entropy is high in
this case so if this bowl was our
decision maker it wouldn't know what
choice to make it has so many choices
which one do you pick apple
grapes or lemons and so we look in here
we're going to start with the dre a
training set
so this is our data that we're training
our data with and we have a number of
options here we have the color and under
the color we have red yellow purple
we have a diameter
and we have a label apple lemon grapes
apple lemon grapes and how do we split
the data we have to frame the conditions
to split the data in such a way that the
information gain is the highest it's
very key to note that we're looking for
the best gain we don't want to just
start sorting out the smallest piece in
there we want to split it the biggest
way we can and so we measure this
decrease in entropy that's what they
call it entropy there's our entropy
after splitting and now we'll try to
choose a condition that gives us the
highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking the gain that we get out of
them the conditions that give us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split so let's take a look at
these different conditions we have color
we have diameter and if we look
underneath that we have a couple
different values we have diameter equals
three color equals yellow red diameter
equals one and when we look at that
you'll see over here we have one two
three four threes that's a pretty hardy
selection so let's say the condition
gives us a maximum gain of three so we
have the most pieces fall into
that range so our first split from our
decision node is we split the data based
on the diameter is it greater than or
equal to three if it's not that's false
it goes into the grape bowl and if it's
true it goes into a bowl fold of lemon
and apples the entropy after splitting
has decreased considerably so now we can
make two decisions if you look at there
very
much
less chaos going on there this note has
already attained an entropy value of 0
as you can see there's only one kind of
label left for this branch so no further
splitting is required for this node
however this node on the right is still
requires a split to decrease the entropy
further so we split the right node
further based on color if you look at
this if i split it on color that pretty
much cuts it right down the middle it's
the only thing we have left in our
choices of color and diameter too and if
the color is yellow it's going to go to
the right bowl and if it's false it's
going to go to the left bowl so the
entropy in this case is now zero so now
we have three bowls with zero entropy
there's only one type of data in each
one of those bowls so we can predict a
lemon with a hundred percent accuracy
and we can predict the apple also with
100 accuracy along with our grapes up
there so we've looked at kind of a basic
tree in our forest but what we really
want to know is how does a random forest
work as a whole so to begin our
random forest classifier let's say we
already have built three trees and we're
going to start with the first tree that
looks like this
just like we did in the example this
tree looks at the diameter if it's
greater than or equal to three
it's true otherwise it's false so one
side goes to the smaller diameter one
side goes to larger diameter and if the
color is orange it's going to go to the
right true we're using oranges now
instead of lemons and if it's red it's
going to go to the left false we build a
second tree very similar but split
differently instead of the first one
being split by a diameter this one when
they created it if you look at that
first bowl it has a lot of red objects
so it says is the color red because
that's going to bring our entropy down
the fastest and so of course if it's
true it goes to the left if it's false
it goes to the right and then it looks
at the shape false are true and so on
and so on and tree three is a diameter
equal to one and it came up with this
because there's a lot of cherries in
this bowl so that would be the biggest
split on there is is the diameter equal
to one that's going to drop the entropy
the quickest and as you can see it
splits it into true if it goes false and
they've added another category does it
grow in the summer and if it's false
it goes off to the left if it's true it
goes off to the right let's go ahead and
bring these three trees so you can see
them all in one image so this would be
three completely different trees
categorizing a fruit and let's take a
fruit now let's try this and this fruit
if you look at it we've blackened it out
you can't see the color on it so it's
missing data remember one of the things
we talked about earlier is that a random
forest works really good if you're
missing data if you're missing pieces so
this fruit has an image but maybe the
person had a black and white camera when
they took the picture and we're going to
take a look at this and it's going to
have
to put the color in there so ignore the
color down there but the diameter equals
3 we find out it grows in the summer
equals yes and the shape is a circle and
if you go to the right you can look at
what one of the decision trees did this
is the third one
is a diameter greater than equal to
three is the color orange well it
doesn't really know on this one but if
you look at the value it'd say true and
you go to the right tree two classifies
it as cherries is the color equal red
is the shape of circle true it is a
circle so this would look at it and say
oh that's a cherry and then we go to the
other classifier and it says is the
diameter equal one well that's false
does it grow in the summer true so it
goes down and looks at as oranges so how
does this random forest work the first
one says it's an orange
the second one said it was a cherry and
the third one says it's an orange
and you can guess if you have two
oranges and one says it's a cherry when
you add that all together the majority
of the vote says orange so the answer is
it's classified as an orange even though
we didn't know the color and we're
missing data on it i don't know about
you but i'm getting tired of fruit so
let's switch and i did promise you we'd
start looking at a case example and get
into some python coding today we're
going to use the case the iris flower
analysis
this is the exciting part as we roll up
our sleeves and actually look at some
python coding before we start the python
coding we need to go ahead and create a
problem statement wonder what species of
iris do these flowers belong to let's
try to predict the species of the
flowers using machine learning in python
let's see how it can be done so here we
begin to go ahead and implement our
python code and you'll find that the
first half of our implementation is all
about organizing and exploring the data
coming in let's go ahead and take this
first step which is loading the
different modules into python and let's
go ahead and put that in our favorite
editor whatever your favorite editor is
in this case i'm going to be using the
anaconda jupiter notebook which is one
of my favorites certainly there's
notepad plus plus and eclipse and dozens
of others or just even using the python
terminal window any of those will work
just fine to go ahead and explore this
python coding so here we go let's go
ahead and flip over to our jupyter
notebook and i've already opened up a
new page for python 3 code and i'm just
going to paste this right in there and
let's take a look and see what we're
bringing into our python the first thing
we're going to do is from the
sklearn.datasets
import load iris now this isn't the
actual data this is just the module that
allows us to bring in the data the load
iris and the iris is so popular it's
been around since 1936 when ronald
fisher published a paper on it and
they're measuring the different parts of
the flower and based on those
measurements predicting what kind of
flower it is and then if we're going to
do a random forest classifier we need to
go ahead and import a random forest
classifier from the sklearn module so
sklearn.ensemble import random fourth
classifier and then we want to bring in
two more modules
and these are probably the most commonly
used modules in python and data science
with any of the
other modules that we bring in and one
is going to be pandas we're going to
import pandas as pd pd is a common term
used for pandas and pandas is basically
creates a data format for us
where when you create a pandas data
frame it looks like an excel spreadsheet
and you'll see that in a minute when we
start digging deeper into the code panda
is just wonderful because it plays nice
with all the other modules in there and
then we have numpy which is our numbers
python and the numbers python allows us
to do different mathematical sets on
here we'll see right off the bat we're
going to take our np and we're going to
go ahead and seed the randomness with it
with 0. so
np.random.seed is seating that is 0.
this code doesn't actually show anything
we're going to go ahead and run it
because i need to make sure i have all
those loaded and then let's take a look
at the next module on here the next six
slides including this one are all about
exploring the data remember i told you
half of this is about looking at the
data and getting it all set so let's go
ahead and take this code right here the
script and let's get that over into our
jupiter notebook and here we go we've
gone ahead and run the imports and i'm
going to paste the code down here
and let's take a look and see what's
going on the first thing we're doing is
we're actually loading the iris data and
if you remember up here we loaded the
module that tells it how to get the iris
data now we're actually assigning that
data to the variable iris and then we're
going to go ahead and use the df to
define data frame
and that's going to equal pd and if you
remember that's pandas as pd so that's
our pandas
and panda data frame and then we're
looking at iris data and columns equals
iris feature names
and we're going to do the df head and
let's run this you can understand what's
going on here
the first thing you want to notice is
that our df has created what looks like
an excel spreadsheet
and in this excel spreadsheet we have
set the columns so up on the top you can
see the four different columns and then
we have the data iris.data down below
it's a little confusing without knowing
where this data is coming from so let's
look at the bigger picture and i'm going
to go print i'm just going to change
this for a moment and we're going to
print all of iris and see what that
looks like
so when i print all of iris i get this
long list of information and you can
scroll through here and see all the
different titles on there
what's important to notice is that first
off there's a brackets at the beginning
so this is a python dictionary
and in a python dictionary you'll have
a key or a label and this label pulls up
whatever information comes after it so
feature names which we actually used
over here under columns is equal to an
array of simple length sepal width pedal
length pedal width these are the
different names they have for the four
different columns and if you scroll down
far enough you'll also see data down
here oh goodness it came up right
towards the top and data is equal to the
different data we're looking at
now there's a lot of other things in
here like target we're going to be
pulling that up in a minute and there's
also the names the target names which is
further down and we'll show you that
also in a minute let's go ahead and set
that back
to the head
and this is one of the neat features of
pandas and panda data frames
is when you do df.head or the
pandadataframe.head it'll print the
first five lines of the data set in
there along with the headers if you have
it in this case we have the column
header set to iris features and in here
you'll see that we have zero one two
three four in python most arrays always
start at zero so when you look at the
first five it's going to be zero one two
three four not one two three four five
so now we've got our iris data imported
into a data frame let's take a look at
the next piece of code in here and so in
this section here
of the code
we're going to take a look at the target
and let's go ahead and get this into our
notebook this piece of code so we can
discuss it a little bit more in detail
so here we are in our jupyter notebook
i'm going to put the code in here and
before i run it
i want to look at a couple things going
on so we have df species
and this is interesting because right
here you'll see where i have df species
in brackets which is uh the key code for
creating another column and here we have
iris iris.target now these are both in
the pandas setup on here so in pandas we
can do either one i could have just as
easily done iris and then in brackets
target depending on what i'm working on
both are acceptable
let's go ahead and run this code and see
how this changes and what we've done is
we've added the target from the iris
data set
as another column on the end
now what species is this is what we're
trying to predict so we have our data
which tells us the answer for all these
different pieces and then we've added a
column with the answer that way when we
do our final setup we'll have the
ability to program our neural network to
look for these this different data and
know what a setosa is or a vera color
which we'll see in just a minute or
virginica those are the three that are
in there and now we're going to add one
more column i know we're organizing all
this data over and over again it's kind
of fun there's a lot of ways to organize
it what's nice about putting everything
onto one
data frame is i can then do a printout
and it shows me exactly what i'm looking
at and i'll show you that where you
where that's different where you can
alter that and do it slightly
differently but let's go ahead and put
this into our script up to that now and
here we go we're going to put that down
here
and we're going to run that
and let's talk a little bit about what
we're doing now we're exploring data
and
one of the challenges is knowing how
good your model is did your model work
and to do this we need to split the data
and we split it into two different parts
they usually call it the training and
the testing and so in here we're going
to go ahead and put that in our database
so you can see it clearly and we've set
it df remember you can put brackets this
is creating another column is train so
we're going to use part of it for
training and this equals np remember
that stands for numpy dot random dot
uniform so we're generating a random
number between 0 and 1 and we're going
to do it for each of the rows that's
where the length df comes from so each
row gets a generated number and if it's
less than 0.75 it's true and if it's
greater than 0.75 it's false this means
we're going to take
75 percent of the data roughly because
there's a randomness involved and we're
going to use that to train it and then
the other 25 we're going to hold off to
the side and use that to test it later
on so let's flip back on over and see
what the next step is so now that we've
labeled our database for which is
training and which is testing
let's go ahead and sort that into two
different variables train and test and
let's take this code and let's bring it
into our project and here we go let's
paste it on down here and before i run
this let's just take a quick look at
what's going on here is we have up above
we created remember there's our def dot
head which prints the first five rows
and we've added a column is train at the
end and so we're going to take that
we're going to create two variables
we're going to create two new data
frames one's called train
one's called test seventy-five percent
in train twenty-five percent in test
and then to sort that out
we're gonna do that by doing df our main
original data frame with the iris data
in it
and if df is trained equals true
that's going to go in the train and if
df is train equals false it goes in the
test
and so when i run this
we're going to print out the number in
each one let's see what that looks like
and you'll see that it puts 118 in the
training module and it puts 32 in the
testing module which lets us know that
there was 150 lines of data in here so
if you went and looked at the original
data you could see that there's 150
lines and that's roughly 75 percent in
one and 25 percent for us to test our
model on afterward so let's jump back to
our code and see where this goes in the
next two steps
we want to do one more thing with our
data and that's make it readable to
humans i don't know about you but i hate
looking at zeros and ones
so let's start with the features and
let's go ahead and
take those and make those readable to
humans and let's put that in our code
let's see here we go paste it in and
you'll see here we've done a couple very
basic things we know that the columns in
our data frame again this is a panda
thing the df
columns and we know the first four of
them zero one two three that'd be the
first four
are going to be the features or the
titles of those columns and so when i
run this
you'll see down here that it creates an
index sipa length sepa width pedal
length and pedal width and this should
be familiar because if you look up here
here's our column titles going across
and here's the first four
one thing i want you to notice here is
that when you're in a command line
whether it's jupiter notebook or you're
running command line in the terminal
window if you just put the name of it
it'll print it out this is the same as
doing print
features
and the shorthand is you just put
features in here if you're actually
writing a code
and saving the script and running it by
remote you really need to put the print
in there but for this when i run it
you'll see it gives me the same thing
but for this we want to go ahead and
we'll just leave it as features because
it doesn't really matter and this is one
of the fun thing about jupiter notebooks
is i'm just building the code as we go
and then we need to go ahead and create
the labels for the other part so let's
take a look and see what that
for our final step in prepping our data
before we actually start running the
training and the testing is we're going
to go ahead and convert the species on
here into something the computer
understands so let's put this code into
our script and see where that takes us
all right here we go we've set y equal
to pd dot factorize
train species of zero
so let's break this down just a little
bit we have our pandas right here pd
what's factorized doing i'm going to
come back to that in just a second
let's look at what train species is
and why we're looking at the group 0 on
there
and let's go up here and here is our
species
remember this on that we created this
whole column here for species
and then it has setosa setosa setosa
setosa and if you scroll down enough
you'd also see virginica and vera color
we need to convert that into something
the computer understands zeros and ones
so the train species of zero because
this is in the format of a of an array
of arrays so you have to have the zero
on the end
and then species is just that column
factorize goes in there looks at the
fact that there's only three of them so
when i run this you'll see that y
generates an array that's equal to in
this case it's the training set and it's
zeros ones and twos representing the
three different kinds of flowers we have
so now we have something the computer
understands and we have a nice table
that we can read and understand and now
finally we get to actually start doing
the predicting so here we go uh we have
two lines of code oh my goodness that
was a lot of work to get to two lines of
code but there is a lot in these two
lines of code so let's take a look and
see what's going on here and put this
into our full script that we're running
and let's paste this in here and let's
take a look and see what this is we have
we're creating a variable clf and we're
going to set this equal to the random
forest classifier and we're passing two
variables in here and there's a lot of
variables you can play with as far as
these two are concerned they're very
standard
in jobs all that does is to prioritize
it not something to really worry about
usually when you're doing this on your
own computer you do in jobs equals two
if you're working in a larger or big
data and you need to prioritize it
differently this is what that number
does is it changes your priorities and
how it's going to run across the system
and things like that and then the random
state is just how it starts
zero is fine for here
but let's go ahead and run this
we also have clf.fit train features
comma y and before we run it let's talk
about this a little bit more clf
dot fit so we're fitting we're training
it we are actually creating our random
forest classifier right here this is a
code that does everything and we're
going to take our training set remember
we kept our test off to the side and
we're going to take our training set
with the features and then we're going
to go ahead and put that in and here's
our target the y
so the y is 0 1 and 2 that we just
created and the features is the actual
data going in that we put into the
training set
let's go ahead and run that
and this is kind of an interesting thing
because it printed out the random force
classifier
and everything around it
and so when you're running this in your
terminal window or in a script like this
this automatically treats this like just
like when we were up here and i typed in
y and it printed out y instead of print
y
this does the same thing it treats this
as a variable and prints it out but if
you're actually running your code that
wouldn't be the case and what is printed
out is it shows us all the different
variables we can change and if we go
down here you can actually see in jobs
equals two
you can see the random state equals 0.
those are the two that we sent in there
you would really have to dig deep to
find out all these different meanings of
all these different settings on here
some of them are self-explanatory if you
kind of think about it a little bit like
max features as auto so all the features
that we're putting in there is just
going to automatically take all four of
them whatever we send it it'll take some
of them might have so many features
because you're processing words there
might be like 1.4 million features in
there because you're doing legal
documents and that's how many different
words are in there at that point you
probably want to limit the maximum
features that you're going to process
and leaf nodes that's the end nodes
remember we had the fruit and we're
talking about the leaf nodes like i said
there's a lot in this we're looking at a
lot of stuff here so you might have in
this case there's probably only think
three leaf nodes maybe four you might
have thousands of leaf nodes at which
point you do need to put a cap on that
and say okay can only go so far and then
we're going to use all of our resources
on processing this
and that really is what most of these
are about is limiting the process and
making sure we don't uh overwhelm a
system and there's some other settings
in here again we're not going to go over
all of them warm start equals false warm
start is if you're programming it one
piece at a time externally since we're
not we're not going to have like we're
not going to continually to train this
particular learning tree and again like
i said there's a lot of things in here
that you'll want to look up more detail
from the sk learn and if you're digging
in deep and running a major project on
here for today though all we need to do
is fit our train our features and our
target y so now we have our training
model what's next if we're going to
create a model
we now need to test it remember we set
aside the test feature test group 25 of
the data so let's go ahead and take this
code and let's put it into our uh script
and see what that looks like okay here
we go
and we're going to run this
and it's going to come out with a bunch
of zeros ones and twos which represents
the three type of flowers the setosa the
virginica and the versacolor and what
we're putting into our predict is the
test features and i always kind of like
to know what it is i am looking at
so real quick we're going to do test
features and remember features is an
array
of sepal length simple width pedal
length pedal width so when we put it in
this way it actually loads all these
different columns that we loaded into
features so if we did just features let
me just do features in here seeing what
features looks like
this is just playing with the with
pandas data frames you'll see that it's
an index so when you put an index in
like this
into
test features into test
it then takes those columns and creates
a panda data frames from those columns
and in this case
we're going to go ahead and put those
into our predict
so we're going to put each one of these
lines of data
the 5.0 3.4 1.5 0.2 and we're going to
put those in and we're going to predict
what our
new
forest classifier is going to come up
with and this is what it predicts it
predicts 0 0 0 1 2 1 1 2 2 2 and and
again this is the
flower type setosa virginica and
versacolor so now that we've taken our
test features
let's explore that let's see exactly
what that data means to us so the first
thing we can do with our predicts is we
can actually generate a different
prediction model when i say different
we're going to view it differently it's
not that the data itself is different so
let's take this next piece of code and
put it into our script
so we're pasting it in here and you'll
see that we're doing uh predict and
we've added underscore proba for
probability so there's our clf.predict
probability so we're running it just
like we ran it up here but this time
with this we're going to get a slightly
different result and we're only going to
look at the first 10.
so you'll see down here instead of
looking at all of them
which was what 27 you'll see right down
here that this generates a much larger
field on the probability and let's take
a look and see what that looks like
and what that means
so when we do the predict underscore
prabha
for probability it generates three
numbers so we had three leaf nodes at
the end and if you remember from all the
theory we did
this is the predictors the first one is
predicting a one for setosa it predicts
a zero for virginica and it predicts a
zero for versa color and so on and so on
and so on and let's um you know what i'm
going to change this just a little bit
let's look at 10
to 20 just because we can
and we start to get a little different
of data and you'll see right down here
it gets to this one this line right here
and this line has 0 0.5 0.5
and so if we're going to vote and we
have two equal votes it's going to go
with the first one so it says uh setosa
gets zero votes virginica gets point
five votes versus color gets point five
votes but let's just go with the
virginica since these two are equal and
so on and so on down the list you can
see how they vary on here so now we've
looked at both how to do a basic predict
of the features and we've looked at the
predict probability
let's see what's next on here so now we
want to go ahead and start mapping names
for the plants we want to attach names
so that it makes a little more sense for
us and this we're going to do in these
next two steps we're going to start by
setting up our predictions and mapping
them to the name so let's see what that
looks like
and let's go ahead and paste that code
in here and run it and this goes along
with the next piece of code so we'll
skip through this quickly and then come
back to a little bit so here's iris
dot target names
and uh if you remember correctly this
was the the names that we've been
talking about this whole time the setosa
virginica versus color and then we're
going to go ahead and do the prediction
again we've run that we could have just
set a variable equal to this instead of
re-running it each time but we'll go
ahead and run it again clf dot predict
test features remember that returns the
zeros the ones and the twos and then
we're going to set that equal to
predictions so this time we're actually
putting it in a variable and when i run
this
it distributes it it comes out as an
array and the array is setosa satosa
satosa satosa setosa we're only looking
at the first five we could actually do
let's do the first 25 just so we can see
a little bit more on there and you'll
see that it starts mapping it to all the
different flower types the versa color
and the virginica in there and let's see
how this goes with the next one so let's
take a look at the top part of our
species in here and we'll take this code
and put it in our script
and let's put that down here and paste
it there we go and we'll go ahead and
run it
and let's talk about both these sections
of code here
and how they go together
the first one is our predictions and i
went ahead and did uh predictions
through 25 let's just do five
and so we have setosa satoshi satosa
satoshi that's what we're predicting
from our test model
and then we come down here we look at
test species i remember i could have
just done test dot species dot head and
you'll see it says setosa satosa setosa
setosa and they match
so the first one is what our forest is
doing
and the second one is what the actual
data is now is we need to combine these
so that we can understand what that
means we need to know how good our
forest is how good it is at predicting
the features so that's where we come up
to the next step which is lots of fun
we're going to use a single line of code
to combine our predictions and our
actuals so we have a nice chart to look
at and let's go ahead and put that in
our script in our jupyter notebook here
let's see let's go ahead and paste that
in and then i'm going to because i'm on
the jupiter notebook i can do a control
minus so you can see the whole line
there
there we go resize it
and let's take a look and see what's
going on here we're gonna create in
pandas remember pd stands for pandas and
we're doing a cross tab this function
takes two sets of data
and creates a chart out of them so when
i run it you'll get a nice chart down
here
and we have the predicted species
so across the top you'll see the setosa
versus color virginica and the actual
species setosa versacolor virginica and
so the way to read this chart and let's
go ahead and take a look on how to read
this chart here when you read this chart
you have setosa where they meet you have
versus color where they meet and you
have virginica where they meet and
they're meeting where the actual and the
predicted agree
so this is the number of accurate
predictions so in this case it equals
30. if you had 13 plus 5 plus 12 you get
30. and then we notice here where it
says virginica but it was supposed to be
versacolor this is inaccurate so now we
have two two inaccurate predictions and
30 accurate predictions so we'll say
that the model accuracy is 93 that's
just 30 divided by 32 and if we multiply
it by a hundred we can say that it is 93
accurate so we have a 93 percent
accuracy with our model i did want to
add one more quick thing in here on our
scripting before we wrap it up so let's
flip back on over to my script in here
we're going to take this line of code
from up above i don't know if you
remember it but predix equals the
dot target underscore names
so we're going to map it to the names
and we're going to run the prediction
and we read it on test features but you
know we're not just testing it we want
to actually deploy it so at this point i
would go ahead and change this
and this is an array of arrays this is
really important when you're running
these to know that
so you need the double brackets and i
could actually create data maybe let's
just do two flowers so maybe i'm
processing more data coming in and we'll
put two flowers in here
and then i actually want to see what the
answer are is so let's go ahead and type
in preds and print that out and when i
run this
you'll see that i've now predicted two
flowers that maybe i measured in my
front yard as versacolor and versacolor
not surprising since i put the same data
in for each one
this would be the actual
end product going out to be used on data
that you don't know the answer for last
week my son and i visited a fruit shop
dad is that an apple or a strawberry so
the question comes up what fruit do they
just pick up from the fruit stand after
a couple of seconds you could figure out
that it was a strawberry so let's take
this model a step further and let's uh
why not build a model which can predict
an unknown data and in this we're going
to be looking at some sweet strawberries
or crispy apples we want to be able to
label those two and decide what the
fruit is and we do that by having data
already put in so we already have a
bunch of strawberries we know our
strawberries and they're already labeled
as such we already have a bunch of
apples we know our apples and are
labeled as such then once we train our
model that model then can be given the
new data and the new data is this image
in this case you can see a question mark
on it and it comes through and goes it's
a strawberry in this case we're using
the support vector machine model svm is
a supervised learning method that looks
at data and sorts it into one of two
categories and in this case we're
sorting the strawberry into the
strawberry site at this point you should
be asking the question how does the
prediction work before we dig into an
example with numbers let's apply this to
our fruit scenario we have our support
vector machine we've taken it and we've
taken labeled sample of data
strawberries and apples and we draw on a
line down the middle between the two
groups this split now allows us to take
new data in this case an apple and a
strawberry and place them in the
appropriate group based on which side of
the line they fall in and that way we
can predict the unknown as colorful and
tasty as the fruit example is let's take
a look at another example with some
numbers involved and we can take a
closer look at how the math works in
this example we're going to be
classifying men and women and we're
going to start with a set of people with
a different height and a different
weight and to make this work we'll have
to have a sample data set a female we
have their height and weight 174 65 174
88 and so on and we'll need a sample
data set of the male they have a height
179 90 180 to 80 and so on let's go
ahead and put this on a graph so we have
a nice visual so you can see here we
have two groups based on the height
versus the weight and on the left side
we're going to have the women on the
right side we're going to have the men
now if we're going to create a
classifier let's add a new data point
and figure out if it's male or female so
before we can do that we need to split
our data first
we can split our data by choosing any of
these lines in this case we draw on two
lines through the data in the middle
that separates them in from the women
but to predict the gender of a new data
point we should split the data in the
best possible way and we say the best
possible way because this line has a
maximum space that separates the two
classes here you can see there's a clear
split between the two different classes
and in this one there's not so much a
clear split this doesn't have the
maximum space that separates the two
that is why this line best splits the
data we don't want to just do this by
eyeballing it and before we go further
we need to add some technical terms to
this we can also say that the distance
between the points in the line should be
as far as possible in technical terms we
can say the distance between the support
vector and the hyperplane should be as
far as possible and this is where the
support vectors are the extreme points
in the data set and if you look at this
data set they have circled two points
which seem to be right on the outskirts
of the woman and one on the outskirts of
the men and hyperplane has a maximum
distance to the support vectors of any
class now you'll see the line down the
middle and we call this the hyperplane
because when you're dealing with
multiple dimensions it's really not just
a line but a plane of intersections and
you can see here where the support
vectors have been drawn in dashed lines
the math behind this is very simple we
take d plus the shortest distance to the
closest positive point which would be on
the min side and d minus is the shortest
distance to the closest negative point
which is on the women's side the sum of
d plus and d minus is called the
distance margin or the distance between
the two support vectors that are shown
in the dashed lines and then by finding
the largest distance margin we can get
the optimal hyperplane once we've
created an optimal hyperplane we can
easily see which side the new data fits
in and based on the hyperplane we can
say the new data point belongs to the
male gender hopefully that's clear how
that works on a visual level as a data
scientist you should also be asking what
happens if the hyperplane is not optimal
if we select a hyperplane having low
margin then there is a high chance of
misclassification this particular svm
model the one we discussed so far is
also called referred to as the ls vm so
far so clear but a question should be
coming up we have our sample data set
but instead of looking like this what if
it looked like this where we have two
sets of data but one of them occurs in
the middle of another set you can see
here where we have the blue and the
yellow and then blue again on the other
side of our data line in this data set
we can't use a hyperplane so when you
see data like this it's necessary to
move away from a 1d view of the data to
a two-dimensional view of the data and
for the transformation we use what's
called a kernel function the kernel
function will take the 1d input and
transfer it to a two-dimensional output
as you can see in this picture here the
1d when transferred to a 2-dimensional
makes it very easy to draw a line
between the two data sets what if we
make it even more complicated how do we
perform an svm for this type of data set
here you can see we have a
two-dimensional data set where the data
is in the middle surrounded by the green
date on the outside in this case we're
going to segregate the two classes we
have our sample data set and if you draw
a line through it's obviously not an
optimal hyperplane in there so to do
that we need to transfer the 2d to a 3d
array and when you translate it into a
three-dimensional array using the kernel
you can see where you can place a
hyperplane right through it and easily
split the data before we start looking
at a programming example and dive into
the script let's look at the advantage
of the support vector machine we'll
start with high dimensional input space
or sometimes referred to as the curse of
dimensionality we looked at earlier one
dimension two dimension three dimension
when you get to a thousand dimensions a
lot of problems start occurring with
most algorithms that have to be adjusted
for the svm automatically does that in
high dimensional space one of the high
dimensional space one high dimensional
space that we work on is sparse document
vectors this is where we tokenize the
words in documents so we can run our
machine learning algorithms over them
i've seen ones get as high as 2.4
million different tokens that's a lot of
vectors to look at and finally we have
regularization parameter the realization
parameter or lambda there's a parameter
that helps figure out whether we're
going to have a bias or overfitting of
the data whether it's going to be
overfitted to a very specific instance
or is going to be biased to a high or
low value with the svm it naturally
avoids the overfitting and bias problems
that we see in many other algorithms
these three advantages of the support
vector machine make it a very powerful
tool to add to your repertoire of
machine learning tools now we did
promise you a used case study we're
actually going to dive in to some python
programming and so we're going to go
into a problem statement and start off
with the zoo so in the zoo example we
have family members going to the zoo we
have the young child going dead is that
a group of crocodiles or alligators well
that's hard to differentiate and zoos
are a great place to start looking at
science and understanding how things
work especially as a young child and so
we can see the parents sitting here
thinking well what is the difference
between a crocodile and an alligator
well one crocodiles are larger in size
alligators are smaller in size snout
width the crocodiles have a narrow snout
and alligators have a wider snout and of
course in the modern day and age the
father is sitting here thinking how can
i turn this into a lesson for my son and
he goes let a support vector machine
segregate the two groups i don't know if
my dad ever told me that but that would
be funny now in this example we're not
going to use actual measurements and
data we're just using that for imagery
and that's very common in a lot of
machine learning algorithms and setting
them up but let's roll up our sleeves
and we'll talk about that more in just a
moment as we break into our python
script so here we arrive in our actual
coding and i'm going to move this into a
python editor in just a moment but let's
talk a little bit about what we're going
to cover first we're going to cover in
the code the setup how to actually
create our svm and you're going to find
that there's only two lines of code that
actually create it and the rest of it is
done so quick and fast that it's all
here in the first page and we'll show
you what that looks like as far as our
data because we're going to create some
data i talked about creating data just a
minute ago and so we'll get into the
creating data here and you'll see this
nice correction of our two blobs and
we'll go through that in just a second
and then the second part is we're going
to take this and we're going to bump it
up a notch we're going to show you what
it looks like behind the scenes but
let's start with actually creating our
setup i like to use the anaconda jupiter
notebook because it's very easy to use
but you can use any of your favorite
python editors or setups and go in there
but let's go ahead and switch over there
and see what that looks like so here we
are in the anaconda python notebook or
anaconda jupiter notebook with python
we're using python 3. i believe this is
3.5 but it should be work in any of your
3x versions and you'd have to look at
the sklearn and make sure if you're
using a 2x version an earlier version
let's go and put our code in there and
one of the things i like about the
jupiter notebook is i go up to view and
i'm going to go ahead and toggle the
line numbers on to make it a little bit
easier to talk about and we can even
increase the size because this is edited
in this case i'm using google chrome
explorer and that's how it opens up for
the editor although anyone any like i
said any editor will work now the first
step is going to be our imports and
we're going to import four different
parts the first two i want you to look
at are line one and line two are numpy
as np and matplot library dot pi plot as
plt now these are very standardized
imports when you're doing work the first
one is the numbers python we need that
because part of the platform we're using
uses that for the numpy array and i'll
talk about that in a minute so you can
understand why we want to use a numpy
array versus the standard python array
and normally it's pretty standard setup
to use np for numpy the map plot library
is how we're going to view our data so
this has you do need the np for the sk
learn module but the map plot library is
purely for our use for visualization and
so you really don't need that for the
svm but we're going to put it there so
you have a nice visual aid and we can
show you what it looks like that's
really important at the end when you
finish everything so you have a nice
display for everybody to look at and
then finally we're going to i'm going to
jump one ahead to line number four
that's the
sklearn.datasets.samplesgenerator
import make blobs and i told you that we
were going to make up data and this is a
tool that's in the sk learning to make
up data i personally don't want to go to
the zoo get in trouble for jumping over
the fence and probably get eaten by the
crocodiles or alligators as i work on
measuring their snouts and width and
length
instead we're just going to make up some
data and that's what that make blobs is
it's a wonderful tool if you're ready to
test your your setup and you're not sure
about what data you're going to put in
there you can create this blob and it
makes it real easy to use and finally we
have our actual svm the sk learn import
svm on line 3. so that covers all our
imports we're going to create remember i
use the make blobs to create data and
we're going to create a capital x and a
lowercase y equals make blobs in samples
equals 40. so we're going to make 40
lines of data it's going to have two
centers with a random state equals 20 so
each each each group is going to have 20
different pieces of data in it and the
way that looks is that we'll have under
x
an x y plane so i have two numbers under
x and y will be 0 1 that's the two
different centers so we have yes or no
in this case alligator or crocodile
that's what that represents and then i
told you that the actual sk learner the
svm is in two lines of code and we see
it right here with clf equals
svm.svc kernel equals linear and i set
sequel to one although in this example
since we are not regularizing the data
because we want to be very clear and
easy to see i went ahead you can set it
to a thousand a lot of times when you're
not doing that but for this thing linear
because it's a very simple linear
example we only have the two dimensions
and it'll be a nice linear hyperplane
it'll be a nice linear line instead of a
full plane so we're not dealing with a
huge amount of data and then all we have
to do is do clf dot fit x comma y and
that's it clf has been created and then
we're going to go ahead and display it
and i'm going to talk about this display
here in just a second but let me go
ahead and run this code and this is what
we've done is we've created two blobs
you'll see the blue on the side and then
kind of an orangish on the other side
that's our two sets of data they
represent one represents crocodiles and
one represents alligators and then we
have our measurements in this case we
have like the width and length of the
snout and i did say i was going to come
up here and talk just a little bit about
our plot and you'll see plt that's what
we imported we're going to do a scatter
plot that means we're just putting dots
on there and then look at this notation
i have the capital x and then in
brackets i have a colon comma 0. that's
from numpy if you did that in a regular
array you'll get an error in a python
array you have to have that in a numpy
array it turns out that our makeblobs
returns a numpy array and this notation
is great because what it means is the
first part is the colon means we're
going to do all the rows that's all the
data in our blob we created under
capital x and then the second part has a
comma 0. we're only going to take the
first value and then if you notice we do
the same thing but we're going to take
the second value remember we always
start with zero and then one so we have
column zero and column one and you can
look at this as our x y plots the first
one is the x plot and the second one is
the y plot so the first one is on the
bottom 0 2 4 6 8 and 10 and then the
second one x of the one is the 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 going up the left hand side s
equals 30 is just the size of the dots
we can see them and said little tiny
dots and then c map equals plt.cm.paired
and you'll also see the c equals y
that's the color we're using two colors
zero one and that's why we get the nice
blue and the two different colors for
the alligator and the crocodile now you
can see here that we did this the actual
fit was done in two lines of code a lot
of times there'll be a third line where
we regularize the data we set it between
like minus one and one and we reshape it
but for this it's not necessary and it's
also kind of nice because you can
actually see what's going on and then if
we wanted to we wanted to actually run a
prediction let's take a look and see
what that looks like and to predict some
new data and we'll show this again as we
get towards the end of digging in deep
you can simply assign your new data in
this case i am giving it a width and
length 3 4 and a width and length 5 6.
and note that i put the data as a set of
brackets and then i have the brackets
inside and the reason i do that is
because when we're looking at data it's
designed to process a large amount of
data coming in we don't want to just
process one line at a time and so in
this case i'm processing two lines and
then i'm just going to print and you'll
see
dot predict new data so the clf and the
dot predict part is going to give us an
answer and let's see what that looks
like and you'll see 0 1. so predicted
the first one the 3 4 is going to be on
the one side and the 5 6 is going to be
on the other side so one came out as an
alligator and one came out as a
crocodile now that's pretty short
explanation for the setup but really we
want to dug in and see what it's going
on behind the scenes and let's see what
that looks like
so the next step is to dig in deep and
find out what's going on behind the
scenes and also put that in a nice
pretty graph
we're going to spend more work on this
and we did actually generating the
original model and you'll see here that
we go through a few steps and i'll move
this over to our editor in just a second
we come in we create our original data
it's exactly identical to the first part
and i'll explain why we redid that and
show you how not to redo that and then
we're going to go in there and add in
those lines we're going to see what
those lines look like and how to set
those up and finally we're going to plot
all that on here and show it and you'll
get a nice graph with the what we saw
earlier when we were going through the
theory behind this where it shows the
support vectors and the hyperplane and
those are done where you can see the
support vectors as the dashed lines and
the solid line which is the hyperplane
let's get that into our jupiter notebook
before i scroll down to a new line i
want you to notice line 13 it has plot
show and we're going to talk about that
here in just a second but let's scroll
down to a new line down here and i'm
going to paste that code in and you'll
see that the plot show has moved down
below let's scroll up a little bit and
if you look at the top here of our new
section one two three
and four is the same code we had before
and let's go back up here and take a
look at that we're gonna fit the values
on our svm and then we're gonna plot
scatter it and then we're gonna do a
plot show so you should be asking why
are we redoing the same code
well when you do the plot show that
blanks out what's in the plot so once
i've done this plot show i have to
reload that data now we could do this
simply by removing it up here re-running
it and then coming down here and then we
wouldn't have to rerun these first four
lines of code now in this it doesn't
matter too much and you'll see the plot
show was down here and then removed
right there on line five i'll go ahead
and just delete that out of there
because we don't want to blank out our
screen we want to move on to the next
setup so we can go ahead and just skip
the first four lines because we did that
before and let's take a look at the ax
equals plt.gca
now right now we're actually spending a
lot of time just graphing that's all
we're doing here okay so this is how we
display a nice graph with our results in
our data ax is very standard note used
variable when you talk about plt and
it's just setting it to that axis the
last axis in the plt it can get very
confusing if you're working with many
different layers of data on the same
graph and this makes it very easy to
reference the ax so this reference is
looking at the plt that we created and
we already mapped out our two blobs on
and then we want to know the limits so
we want to know how big the graph is we
can find out the x limit and the y limit
simply with the get x limit and get y
limit commands which is part of our
metplot library and then we're going to
create a grid and you'll see down here
we have we've set the variable xx equal
to np.line space x limit 0 x limit 1
comma 30 and we've done the same thing
for the y space and then we're going to
go in here and we create a mesh grid and
this is a numpy command so we're back to
our numbers python let's go through what
these numpy commands mean with the line
space and the mesh grid we've taken x x
small s x x equals np line space and we
have our x limit 0 and our x limit 1 and
we're going to create 30 points on it
and we're going to do the same thing for
the y axis now this has nothing to do
with our evaluation it's all we're doing
is we're creating a grid
of data and so we're creating a set of
points between 0 and the x limit we're
creating 30 points and the same thing
with the y and then the mesh grid loops
those all together so it forms a nice
grid so if we were going to do this say
between the limit 0 and 10 and do 10
points we would have a 0 0 1 1 0 1 0 2 0
3 0 4 to 10 and so on you can just
imagine a point at each corner one of
those boxes and the mesh grid combines
them all so we take the yy and the xx we
created and creates the full grid and
we've set that grid into the yy
coordinates and the xx coordinates now
remember we're working with numbi and
python we like to separate those we like
to have instead of it being x comma 1
you know x comma y
and then x 2 comma y 2 and this in the
next set of data it would be a column of
x's and a column of y's and that's what
we have here is we have a column of y's
and we put it as a capital yy and a
column of x's capital x x with all those
different points being listed and
finally we get down to the numpy v stack
just as we created those in the mesh
grid we're now going to put them all
into one array x y array now that we've
created the stack of data points we're
going to do something interesting here
we're going to create a value z and the
z equals the clf that's our that's our
support vector machine we created and
we've already trained and we have a dot
decision function we're going to put the
x y in there so here we have all this
data we're going to put that x y in
there that data and we're going to
reshape it and you'll see that we have
the x x dot shape in here this literally
takes the xx resets it up connected to
the y and the z value lets us know
whether it is the left hand side is
going to generate three different values
the z value does and it'll tell us
whether that data is a support vector to
the left the hyperplane in the middle or
the support vector to the right so it
generates three different values for
each of those points and those points
have been reshaped so they're right on a
line on those three different lines so
we've set all of our data up we've
labeled it to three different areas and
we've reshaped it and we've just taken
30 points in each direction if you do
the math you have 30 times 30 so that's
900 points of data and we separated
between the three lines and reshaped it
to fit those three lines we can then go
back to our map plot library we've
created the ax and we're going to create
a contour and you'll see here we have
contour capital xx capital yy these have
been reshaped to fit those lines z is
the labels so now we have the three
different points with the labels in
there and we can set the colors equals k
and i told you we had three different
labels but we have three levels of data
the alphas just makes it kind of
see-through so it's only 0.5 of the
value in there so when we graph it the
data will show up from behind it
wherever the lines go and finally the
line styles this is where we set the two
support vectors to be dash dash lines
and then a single one is just a straight
line that's what all that setup does and
then finally we take our ax dot scatter
we're going to go ahead and plot the
support vectors but we've programmed it
in there so that they look nice like the
dash dash line and the dashed line on
that grid and you can see here when we
do the clf dot support vectors we are
looking at column zero and column one
and then again we have the s equals 100
so we're going to make them larger and
the line width equals one face colors
equals none let's take a look and see
what that looks like when we show it and
you can see we get down to our end
result it creates a really nice graph we
have our two support vectors and dashed
lines and they have the near data so you
can see those two points or in this case
the four points where those lines nicely
cleave the data and then you have your
hyper plane down the middle which is as
far from the two different points as
possible creating the maximum distance
so you can see that we have our nice
output for the size of the body and the
width of the snout and we've easily
separated the two groups of crocodile
and alligator congratulations you've
done it we've made it of course these
are pretend data for our crocodiles and
alligators but this hands-on example
will help you to encounter any support
vector machine projects in the future
and you can see how easy they are to set
up and look at in-depth so what is
k-means clustering k-means clustering is
an unsupervised learning algorithm in
this case you don't have labeled data
unlike in supervised learning so you
have a set of data and you want to group
them and as the name suggests you want
to put them into clusters which means
objects that are similar in nature
similar in characteristics need to be
put together so that's what k means
clustering is all about the term k is
basically is a number so we need to tell
the system how many clusters we need to
perform so if k is equal to two there
will be two clusters if k is equal to
three three clusters and so on and so
forth that's what the k stands for and
of course there is a way of finding out
what is the best or optimum value of k
for a given data we will look at that so
that is k means clustering so
let's take an example k-means clustering
is used in many many scenarios but let's
take an example of cricket the game of
cricket let's say you received
data of a lot of players from maybe all
over the country or all over the world
and this data has information about
the runs scored by the people ordered by
the player and the wickets taken by the
player and based on this information we
need to cluster this data into two
clusters batsman and bowlers so this is
an interesting example let's see how we
can perform this so we have the data
which consists of primarily two
characteristics which is the runs and
the wickets so the bowlers basically
take wickets and the batsmen score runs
there will be of course a few bowlers
who can
score some runs and similarly there will
be some batsmen who will who would have
taken a few wickets but with this
information we want to cluster those
players into batsmen and bowlers so how
does this work let's say this is how the
data is so there are information there
is information on the y-axis about the
run scored and on the x-axis about the
wickets taken by the players so if we do
a quick plot this is how it would look
and
when we do the clustering we need to
have the clusters like shown in the
third diagram rtms we need to have a
cluster which consists of people who
have scored high runs which is basically
the batsman and then we need a cluster
with people who have taken a lot of
wickets which is typically the bowlers
there may be a certain amount of overlap
but we will not talk about it right now
so with k-means clustering we will have
here that means k is equal to 2 and we
will have two clusters which is batsman
and bowlers so how does this work the
way it works is the first step in
k-means clustering is the allocation of
two centroids randomly so two points are
assigned as so-called centroids so in
this case we want two clusters which
means k is equal to two so two points
have been randomly assigned as centroids
keep in mind
these points can be anywhere there are
random points they are not initially
they are not really the centroids
centroid means it's a central point of a
given data set but in this case when it
starts off it's not really the centroid
okay so these points though in our
presentation here we have shown them one
point closer to these data points and
another closer to these data points they
can be assigned randomly anywhere okay
so that's the first step the next step
is to determine the distance of each of
the data points
from each of the
randomly assigned centroids so for
example we take this point and find the
distance from this centroid and the
distance from this centroid this point
is taken and the distance is found from
this centroid and this center and so on
and so forth so
for every point the distance is measured
from both the centroids
and then
whichever distance is less that point is
assigned to that centroid so for example
in this case visually it is very obvious
that all these data points are assigned
to this centroid and all these data
points are assigned to this centroid and
that's what is represented here in blue
color and in this yellow color the next
step is to actually determine
the central point or the actual centroid
for these two clusters so we have this
one
initial cluster this one initial cluster
but as you can see these points are not
really the centroid centroid means it
should be the
central position of this data set
central position of this data set so
that is what needs to be determined as
the next step so the central point of
the actual centroid is determined and
the original randomly allocated centroid
is repositioned to the actual centroid
of these new clusters and this process
is actually repeated now what might
happen is some of these points may get
reallocated in our example that is not
happening probably but it may so happen
that the distance is found between each
of these data points once again with
these centroids and if there is if it is
required some points may be reallocated
we will see that in a later example but
for now we will keep it simple so this
process is continued till the centroid
repositioning stops and that is our
final cluster so this is our so after
iteration we come to this position this
situation where the centroid doesn't
need any more repositioning and that
means our algorithm has converged
convergence has occurred and we have the
cluster two clusters we have the
clusters with a centroid so this process
is repeated the process of calculating
the distance and repositioning the
centroid is repeated till the
repositioning stops which means that the
algorithm has converged and we have the
final cluster with the data points and
the centroids so this is what you're
going to learn from this session we will
talk about the types of clustering what
is k-means clustering application of
k-means clustering k-means clustering is
done using distance measure so we will
talk about the common distance measures
and then we will talk about how k-means
clustering works and go into the details
of k-means clustering algorithm and then
we will end with a demo and a use case
for k-means clustering so let's begin
first of all what are the types of
clustering there are primarily two
categories of clustering hierarchical
clustering and then partitional
clustering and each of these categories
are further subdivided into
agglomerative and divisive clustering
and k-means and fuzzy c means clustering
let's take a quick look at what each of
these types of clustering are
in hierarchical clustering the clusters
have a tree-like structure and
hierarchical clustering is further
divided into agglomerative and divisive
agglomerative clustering is a bottom-up
approach we begin with each element as a
separate cluster and merge them into
successively larger clusters so for
example we have a b c d e f we start by
combining b and c from one cluster d e
and e form one more then we combine d e
and f one more bigger cluster and then
add bc to that and then finally a to it
compared to that divisive clustering or
divisive clustering is a top down
approach we begin with the whole set and
proceed to divide it into successively
smaller clusters so we have abcdef we
first take that as a single cluster and
then break it down
into a b c d
e and f
then we have partitional clustering
split into two subtypes k means
clustering and fuzzy c means in k means
clustering the objects are divided into
the number of clusters mentioned by the
number k that's where the k comes from
so if we say k is equal to 2 the objects
are divided into two clusters c1 and c2
and the way it is done is the features
or characteristics are compared and all
objects having similar characteristics
are clubbed together so that's how k
means clustering is done we will see it
in more detail as we move forward and
fuzzy c means is very similar to k means
in the sense that it clubs objects that
have similar characteristics together
but while in k means clustering two
objects cannot belong to or any object a
single object cannot belong to two
different clusters in c means objects
can belong to more than one cluster so
that is the primary difference between
k-means and fuzzy c means
so what are some of the applications of
k-means clustering k-means clustering is
used in a variety of examples or variety
of business cases in real life
starting from academic performance
diagnostic systems search engines and
wireless sensor networks and many more
so let us take a little deeper look at
each of these examples academic
performance so based on the scores of
the students students are categorized
into a b c and so on clustering forms a
backbone of search engines when a search
is performed the search results need to
be grouped together the search engines
very often use clustering to do this
and similarly in case of wireless sensor
networks the clustering algorithm plays
the role of finding the cluster heads
which collects all the data in its
respective cluster so clustering
especially k means clustering uses
distance measure so let's take a look at
what is distance measure so while these
are the different types of clustering in
this video we will focus on k-means
clustering so distance measure tells
how similar some objects are so the
similarity is measured using what is
known as distance measure and what are
the various types of distance measures
there is euclidean distance there is
manhattan distance then we have squared
euclidean distance measure and cosine
distance measure these are some of the
distance measures supported by k-means
clustering let's take a look at each of
these
what is euclidean distance measure this
is nothing but the distance between two
points so we have learnt in high school
how to find the distance between two
points this is a little sophisticated
formula for that but we know a simpler
one is square root of y2 minus y1 whole
square plus x2 minus x1 whole square so
this is an extension of that formula so
that is the euclidean distance between
two points what is the squared euclidean
distance measure it's nothing but the
square of the euclidean distance as the
name suggests so instead of taking the
square root we leave the square as it is
and then we have manhattan distance
measure in case of manhattan distance it
is the sum of the distances across the
x-axis and the y-axis
and note that we are taking the absolute
value so that the negative values don't
come into play so that is the manhattan
distance measure then we have cosine
distance measure in this case we take
the angle between the two vectors formed
by joining the points from the origin so
that is the cosine distance measure okay
so that was a quick overview about the
various distance measures that are
supported by k-means now let's go and
check how exactly k-means clustering
works okay so this is how k means
clustering works this is like a
flowchart of the whole process there is
a starting point and then we specify the
number of clusters that we want now
there are a couple of ways of doing this
we can do by trial and error so we
specify a certain number maybe k is
equal to 3 or 4 or 5 to start with and
then as we progress we keep changing
until we get the best clusters or there
is a technique called elbow technique
whereby we can determine the value of k
what should be the best value of k how
many clusters should be formed so once
we have the value of k we specify that
and then the system will assign that
many centroids so it picks randomly that
to start with randomly that many points
that are considered to be the centroids
of these clusters and then it measures
the distance of each of the data points
from these centroids and assigns those
points to the corresponding centroid
from which the distance is minimum so
each data point will be assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it and
thereby we have k number of initial
clusters however this is not the final
clusters the next step it does is
for the new groups for the clusters that
have been formed it calculates the main
position thereby calculates the new
centroid position the position of the
centroid moves compared to the randomly
allocated one so it's an iterative
process once again the distance of each
point is measured from this new centroid
point and if required the data points
are reallocated to the new centroids and
the mean position or the new centroid is
calculated once again if the centroid
moves then the iteration continues which
means the convergence has not happened
the clustering has not converged so as
long as there is a movement of the
centroid this iteration keeps happening
but once the centroid stops moving which
means that the cluster has converged or
the clustering process has converged
that will be the end result so now we
have the final position of the centroid
and the data points are allocated
accordingly to the closest centroid i
know it's a little difficult to
understand from this simple flowchart so
let's do a little bit of visualization
and see if we can explain it better
let's take an example if we have a data
set for a grocery shop so let's say we
have a data set for a grocery shop and
now we want to find out how many
clusters this has to be spread across
so how do we find the optimum number of
clusters there is a technique called the
elbow method so when these clusters are
formed there is a parameter called
within sum of squares and the lower this
value is the better the cluster is that
means
all these points are very close to each
other so we use this within sum of
squares as a measure to find the optimum
number of clusters that can be formed
for a given data set so we create
clusters or we let the system create
clusters of a variety of numbers maybe
of 10
10 clusters and for each value of k the
within ss is measured and the value of k
which has the least amount of within ss
or wss that is taken as the optimum
value of k so this is the diagrammatic
representation so we have on the y axis
the within sum of squares or wss and on
the x-axis we have the number of
clusters so as you can imagine if you
have k is equal to 1 which means all the
data points are in a single cluster the
within s value will be very high because
they are probably scattered all over the
moment you split it into two there will
be a drastic fall in the within ss value
that's what is represented here but then
as the value of k increases the decrease
the rate of decrease
will not be so high it will continue to
decrease but probably the rate of
decrease will not be high so that gives
us an idea so from here we get an idea
for example the optimum value of k
should be
either 2 or 3 or at the most 4 but
beyond that
increasing the number of clusters is not
dramatically changing the value in wss
because that pretty much gets stabilized
okay now that we have got the value of k
and let's assume that these are our
delivery points the next step is
basically
to assign two centroids randomly so
let's say c1 and c2 are the centroids
assigned randomly now the distance of
each
location from the centroid is measured
and each point is assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it so for
example
these points are very obvious that these
are closest to c1 whereas this point is
far away from c2 so these points will be
assigned which are close to c1 will be
assigned to c1 and these points or
locations which are close to c2 will be
assigned to c2 and then so this is the
how the initial grouping is done this is
part of c1 and this is part of c2 then
the next step is to calculate the actual
centroid of this data because remember
c1 and c2 are not the centroids they've
been
randomly assigned points and only thing
that has been done was the data points
which are closest to them have been
assigned
but now in this step the actual centroid
will be calculated which may be for each
of these data sets somewhere in the
middle so that's like the main point
that will be calculated and the centroid
will actually be positioned
or repositioned there
same with c2
so the new centroid for this group is c2
in this new position and c1 is in this
new position
once again the distance of each of the
data points is calculated from these
centroids now remember it's not
necessary that the distance still
remains the or each of these data points
still remain in the same group by
recalculating the distance it may be
possible that some points get
reallocated like so you see this
so this point earlier was closer to c2
because c2 was here
but after recalculating repositioning it
is observed that this is closer to c1
than c2 so this is the new grouping so
some points will be reassigned and again
the centroid will be calculated and if
the centroid doesn't change so that is
the repetitive process iterative process
and if the centroid doesn't change once
the centroid stops changing that means
the algorithm has converged and this is
our final cluster with this as the
centroid c1 and c2 as the centroids
these data points as a part of each
cluster so i hope this helps in
understanding the whole process
iterative process of k-means clustering
so let's take a look at
the k-means clustering algorithm let's
say we have x1 x2 x3 n number of points
as our inputs and we want to split this
into k clusters or we want to create k
clusters so the first step is to
randomly pick k points and call them
centroids they are not real centroids
because centroid is supposed to be a
center point but they are just called
centroids and
we calculate the distance of each and
every input point from each of the
centroids so the distance of x1 from c1
from c2 c3 each of the distances we
calculate and then find out which
distance is the lowest and assign x1 to
that particular random centroid repeat
that process for x2 calculate its
distance from each of the centroids c1
c2 c3 up to ck and find which is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
particular centroid same with x3 and so
on so that is the first round of
assignment that is done now
we have k
groups because there are we have
assigned the value of k so there are k
centroids
and so there are k groups all these
inputs have been split into k groups
however remember we picked the centroids
randomly so they are not real centroids
so now what we have to do we have to
calculate the actual centroids for each
of these groups which is like the mean
position which means that the position
of the randomly selected
centroids will now change
and they will be
the main positions of this newly formed
k groups and once that is done
we once again repeat this process of
calculating the distance right so this
is what we are doing as a part of step
four we repeat step two and three so we
again calculate the distance of x1
from
the centroid c1
c2 c3 and then c which is the lowest
value and assign x1 to that
calculate the distance of x2 from c1 c2
c3 or whatever
up to ck and find whichever is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
centroid and so on in this process there
may be some reassignment x1 pro was
probably assigned to cluster c2 and
after doing this calculation maybe now
x1 is assigned to c1 so that kind of
reallocation may happen so we repeat the
steps 2 and 3 till the position of the
centroids don't change or stop changing
and that's when we have convergence
so let's take a detailed look at each of
these steps so we randomly pick k
cluster centers we call them centroids
because they are not initially they are
not really the centroids so we let us
name them c1 c2 up to ck and then step
two we assign each data point to the
closest center so what we do we
calculate the distance of each x value
from each c value so the distance
between
x1 c1 distance between x1 c2 x1 c3 and
then we find which is the lowest value
right that's the minimum value we find
and assign x1 to that particular
centroid then we go next to x2 find the
distance of x2 from c1 x2 from c2 x2
from c3 and so on up to ck and then
assign it to the point or to the
centroid which has the lowest value and
so on so that is step number two in step
number three we now find the actual
centroid for each group so what has
happened as a part of step number two
we now have all the points all the data
points
grouped into k groups because we we
wanted to create k clusters right so we
have k groups each one may be having a
certain number of input values they need
not be equally distributed by the way
based on the distance we will have k
groups but remember the initial values
of the c1 c2 were not really the
centroids of these groups right we
assigned them randomly so now in step 3
we actually calculate the centroid of
each group which means the original
point which we thought was the centroid
will shift to the new position which is
the actual centroid for each of these
groups okay and we again calculate the
distance so we go back to step two which
is what we calculate again the distance
of each of these points from the newly
positioned centroids and if required we
reassign these points to the new
centroids so as i said earlier there may
be a reallocation so we now have a new
set or a new group we still have k
groups
but the number of items and the actual
assignment may be different from what
was in step
two here okay so that might change then
we perform step three once again to find
the new centroid of this new group so we
have again a new set of clusters new
centroids and new assignments
we repeat this step two again once again
we find and then it is possible that
after iterating through three or four or
five times the centroid will stop moving
in the sense that when you calculate the
new value of the centroid that will be
same as the original value or there will
be very marginal change so that is when
we say convergence has occurred and that
is our final cluster that's the
formation of the final cluster
all right so let's see a couple of demos
of k-means clustering we will actually
see some live demos in
python notebook using pattern notebook
but before that let's find out what's
the problem that we are trying to solve
the problem statement is let's say
walmart wants to open a chain of stores
across the state of florida and
it wants to find the optimal store
locations now the issue here is if they
open too many stores close to each other
obviously they will not make profit but
if they if the stores are too far apart
then they will not have enough sales
so how do they optimize this now
for an organization like walmart which
is an e-commerce giant
they already have the addresses of their
customers in their database so they can
actually use this information or this
data and use k-means clustering to find
the optimal location now before we go
into the python notebook and show you
the live code
i wanted to take you through very
quickly a summary of the code in the
slides and then we will go into the
python notebook so in this
block we are basically
importing all the required libraries
like numpy
matplotlib and so on
and we are loading the data that is
available in the form of let's say the
addresses
for simplicity's sake we will just take
them as some data points then the next
thing we do is quickly do a scatter plot
to see
how they are
related to each other with respect to
each other so in the scatter plot we see
that there are a few distinct
groups
already being formed so you can actually
get an idea about how the cluster would
look and how many clusters what is the
optimal number of clusters and then
starts the actual
k-means clustering process
so we will assign
each of these points to the centroids
and then check whether they are
the optimal distance which is the
shortest distance and assign each of the
points data points to the centroids and
then go through this iterative process
till the whole process converges and
finally we get an output like this
so we have four distinct clusters
and
which is if we can say that this is how
the population is probably distributed
across florida state and
these centroids are
like the location where the store should
be the optimum location where the store
should be so that's the way we determine
the best locations for the store and
that's how we can help walmart find the
best locations for their stores in
florida so now let's
take this into python notebook let's see
how this looks when we are running
running the code live alright so this is
the code for k-means clustering in
jupiter notebook we have a few examples
here which we will demonstrate how
k-means clustering is used and even
there is a small implementation of
k-means clustering as well okay so let's
get started okay so this block is
basically importing the various
libraries that are required like
matplotlib and numpy and so on and so
forth which would be used as a part of
the code then we are going and creating
blobs which are similar to clusters now
this is a very neat feature which is
available in scikit-learn make blobs is
a nice feature which creates clusters of
data sets so that's a wonderful
functionality that is readily available
for us to create some test data kind of
thing okay so that's exactly what we are
doing here we are using make blobs and
we can specify how many clusters we want
so centers we are mentioning here so it
will go ahead and so we just mentioned
four so it will go ahead and create some
test data for us
and this is how it looks as you can see
visually also we can figure out that
there are four distinct classes or
clusters in this data set and that is
what make blobs actually
provides
now from here onwards we will basically
run the standard k-means functionality
that is readily available so we really
don't have to implement k-means itself
the k-means functionality or the
function is readily available you just
need to feed the data and will create
the clusters so this is the code for
that
we import k-means and then we create an
instance of k-means and we specify the
value of k this n underscore clusters is
the value of k remember k means in k
means k is basically the number of
clusters that you want to create and it
is a
integer value so this is where we are
specifying that so we have k is equal to
and so that instance is created we take
that instance and as
with any other machine learning
functionality fit is what we use the
function or the method rather fit is
what we use to train the model here
there is no real training kind of thing
but that's the call okay so we are
calling fit and what we are doing here
we are just passing the data so x has
these values the data that has been
created
right so that is what we are passing
here
and
this will go ahead and create the
clusters and
then we are using
after doing uh fit we run the predict
which uh basically assigns for each of
these observations which cluster where
it belongs to all right so it will name
the clusters maybe this is cluster one
this is two three and so on or i will
actually start from 0 cluster 0 1 2 and
3 maybe and then for each of the
observations it will assign based on
which cluster it belongs to it will
assign a value so that is stored in
y underscore k means when we call
predict that is what it does
and we can take a quick look at these
y underscore k means or with the cluster
numbers that have been assigned for each
observation so this is the cluster
number assigned for observation 1 maybe
this is for observation 2 observation 3
and so on so we have how many about i
think 300 samples right so all the 300
samples there are 300 values here each
of them the cluster number is given and
the cluster number goes from 0 to 3. so
there are four clusters so the numbers
go from 0 1 2 3. so that's what is seen
here okay now so this was a quick
example of generating some dummy data
and then clustering that okay and this
can be applied if you have proper data
you can just load it up into x for
example here and then run the cable so
this is the central part of the k-means
clustering program example so you
basically create an instance and you
mention how many clusters you want by
specifying this parameter and underscore
clusters and that is also the value of k
and then pass the data to get the values
now the next section of this code is the
implementation of a k-means now this is
kind of a rough implementation of the
k-means algorithm so we will just walk
you through i will walk you through the
code uh at each step what it is doing
and then we will see a couple of more
examples of how k-means clustering uh
can be used in maybe some real-life
examples real-life use cases all right
so in this case here what we are doing
is basically implementing k means
clustering and there is a function or a
library calculates for a given two pairs
of points it will calculate the the
distance between them and see which one
is the closest and so on so this is like
this is pretty much like what k means
does right so it calculates the distance
of each point or each data set from
predefined centroid and then based on
whichever is the lowest this particular
data point is assigned to that centroid
so that is basically available as a
standard function and we will be using
that here so as explained in the slides
the first step that is done in case of
k-means clustering is to randomly assign
some centroids so as a first step we
randomly allocate a couple of centroids
which we call here we are calling as
centers
and then we put this in a loop and we
take it through an iterative process
for each of the data points we first
find out using this function pairwise
distance argument
for each of the points we find out which
one which center or which randomly
selected centroid is the closest and
accordingly we assign the data or the
data point to that particular centroid
or cluster and once that is done for all
the data points
we calculate the new centroid by finding
out the mean position because the center
position right so we calculate the new
centroid and then we check if the new
centroid is the coordinates or the
position is the same as the previous
centroid the positions we will compare
and if it is the same that means the
process has converged so remember we do
this process till the centroids or the
centroid doesn't move anymore right so
the centroid gets relocated each time
this reallocation is done so
the moment it doesn't change anymore the
position of the centroid doesn't change
anymore we know that convergence has
occurred so till then so you see here
this is like an infinite loop while true
is an infinite loop it only breaks when
the centers are the same the new center
and the old center positions are the
same and once that is done we return the
centers and the labels now of course as
explained this is not a very
sophisticated and advanced
implementation very basic implementation
because one of the flaws in this is that
sometimes what happens is the centroid
the position
will
keep moving but in the change will be
very minor so in that case
also with that is actually convergence
right so for example the change is
0.0001
we can consider that as convergence
otherwise what will happen is this will
either take forever or it will be never
ending so that's a small flaw here so
that is something additional checks may
have to be added here but again as
mentioned this is not the most
sophisticated implementation uh this is
like a kind of a rough implementation of
the k means clustering okay so if we
execute this code this is what we get as
the output so this is the definition of
this particular function and then we
call that find underscore clusters and
we pass our data x and the number of
clusters which is 4
and if we run that and plot it this is
the output that we get so this is of
course each cluster is represented by a
different color so we have a cluster in
green color yellow color and so on and
so forth and these big points here these
are the centroids this is the final
position of the centroids and as you can
see visually also this appears like a
kind of a center of all these points
here right similarly this is like the
center of all these points here and so
on so this is the example or this is an
example of an implementation of k-means
clustering
and
next we will move on to see a couple of
examples of how k-means clustering is
used
in maybe some real life scenarios or use
cases in the next example or demo
we are going to see how we can use
k-means clustering to perform color
compression we will take a couple of
images so there will be two examples and
we will try to use k-means clustering to
compress the colors this is a common
situation
in image processing when you have an
image with millions of
colors but then you cannot render it on
some devices which may not have enough
memory uh so that is the
scenario where where something like this
can be used
so
before again we go into the python
notebook let's take a look at quickly
the the code
as usual we import the libraries and
then we import the image and
then we will flatten it so the reshaping
is basically we have the image
information is stored in the form of
pixels and if the image is like for
example 427 by 640 and it has three
colors so that's the overall dimension
of the of the initial image we just
reshape it and
then feed this to our algorithm
and this will then create clusters of
only 16 clusters so this this colors
there are millions of colors and now we
need to bring it down to 16 colors so we
use k is equal to 16
and
this is how when we visualize this is
how it looks there are these are all
about 16 million possible colors the
input color space has 16 million
possible colors and we just
sub compress it to 16 colors so this is
how it would look when we compress it to
16 colors and this is how the original
image looks and
after compression to 16 colors this is
how the new image looks as you can see
there is not a lot of information that
has been lost
though
the image quality is definitely reduced
a little bit
so this is
an example which we are going to now see
in python notebook let's go into the
python node and once again as always we
will import some libraries and
load this image called
flower dot jpg okay so let we load that
and this is how it looks this is the
original image which has i think 16
million colors and this is the shape of
this image which is basically what is
the
shape is nothing but the overall size
right so this is
pixel by 640 pixel and then there are
three layers which is this three
basically is for rgb which is red green
blue so color image will have that right
so that is the shape of this now what we
need to do is data let's take a look at
how data is looking so let me just
create a new cell and show you
what is in data basically we have
captured this information
so data is what let me just show you
here
all right so
let's take a look at
china what are the values in china and
if we see here this is how the data is
stored this is nothing but the pixel
values okay so this is like a matrix and
each one has about four for this 427 by
640 pixels all right so this is how it
looks now the issue here is these values
are
large the numbers are a large so we need
to normalize them to between zero and
one right so that's why we will
basically create one more variable which
is data which will contain the values
between zero and one and the way to do
that is divide by 255 so we divide china
by 255 and we get the new values in data
so let's just run this piece of code and
this is the shape so we now have also
yeah what we have done is we changed
using reshape we converted into the
three-dimensional into a two-dimensional
data set and let us also take a look at
how
let me just insert
uh probably a cell here and take a look
at how data is looking all right so this
is how data is looking and now you see
this is
the values are between zero and one
right so if you earlier noticed in case
of china the values were large numbers
now everything is between 0 and 1. this
is one of the things we need to do all
right so after that the next thing that
we need to do is to visualize this and
we can take random set of maybe 10 000
points and plot it and check and see how
this looks let us just plot this
and so this is how the original the
color the pixel distribution is these
are two plots one is red against green
and another is red against blue and this
is the original distribution of the
color so then what we will do is we will
use k-means clustering to create just 16
clusters for the various colors and then
apply that to the image now
what will happen is since the data is
large because there are millions of
colors using regular k-means may be a
little time-consuming so there is
another version of k-means which is
called mini batch came in so we will use
that which is which processes in the
overall concept remains the same but
this basically processes it in smaller
batches that's the only thing okay so
the results will pretty much be the same
so let's go ahead and execute this piece
of code and also visualize this so that
we can see that there are these this is
how the 16 colors
would look
so this is red against green and this is
red against blue there is uh quite a bit
of similarity between this original
color schema and the new one right so it
doesn't look very very completely
different or anything like that now we
apply this the newly created colors to
the image and we can take a look uh how
this is looking now we can compare both
the images so this is our original image
and this is our new image so as you can
see there is not a lot of information
that has been lost it pretty much looks
like the original image yes we can see
that for example here there is a little
bit it appears a little dullish compared
to this one right because we kind of
took off some of the finer details of
the color but
overall the high level information has
been maintained at the same time the
main advantage is that now this can be
this is an image which can be rendered
on a device which may not be that very
sophisticated now let's take one more
example with a different image in the
second example we will take an image of
the summer palace in china and we repeat
the same process this is a
high definition color image with
millions of colors and also
three-dimensional
now we will reduce that to 16 colors
using k-means clustering
and
we do the same process like before we
reshape it and then we cluster the
colors to 16 and then we render the
image once again and we will see that
the color the quality of the image
slightly deteriorates as you can see
here this has much finer details in this
which are probably missing here but then
that's the compromise because there are
some devices which may not be able to
handle
this kind of high density images
so let's run this chord in python
notebook all right so let's apply the
same technique for another picture which
is
even more intricate and has probably
much complicated color schema so this is
the image now once again uh we can take
a look at the shape which is 427 by 640
by 3
and this is the new data would look
somewhat like this compared to the
flower image so we have some new values
here
and we will also bring this as you can
see the numbers are much big so we will
much bigger so we will now have to scale
them down to values between 0 and 1 and
that is done by
dividing by 255 so let's go ahead and do
that
and reshape it okay so we get a two
two-dimensional matrix
and we will then as a next step we will
go ahead and visualize this how it looks
those the 16 colors
and this is basically how it would look
16 million colors and now we can
create the clusters
out of this the 16
k means clusters we will create so this
is how the distribution of the pixels
would look with 16 colors
and then we go ahead and
apply this
and visualize how it is looking for
with the new just the 16 color so once
again as you can see this looks much
richer in color but at the same time and
this probably doesn't have as we can see
it doesn't look as rich as this one but
nevertheless the information is not lost
the shape and all that stuff and this
can be also rendered on a slightly a
device which is probably
not that sophisticated okay so that's
pretty much it so we have seen two
examples of how color compression can be
done
using k-means clustering
and we have also seen in the previous
examples of how to implement k-means the
code to roughly how to implement k-means
clustering and we use some sample data
using blob to just execute the k-means
clustering we talk about the principal
component
analysis we're going to cover
dimensionality reduction principle
component analysis what is it
important pca terminologies and you'll
see it abbreviated normally as pca
principal component analysis pca
properties pca example and then we'll
pull up some python code in our jupyter
notebook and has some hands-on demo on
the pca and how it's used dimensionality
reduction dimensionality reduction
refers to the technique that reduces the
number of input variables in a data set
and so you can see on the table on the
right shows the orders made at an
automobile parts retailer the retailer
sells different automobile parts from
different companies and you can see we
have company b-packs isomax and they
have the item the tire the axle an order
id a price number and a quantity in
order to predict the future cells
we find out that using correlation
analysis
that we just need three attributes
therefore we have reduced the number of
attributes from five to three
and clearly we don't really care about
the part number i don't think the part
number would have an effect on how many
tires are bought
and even the store who's buying them
probably does not have an effect on that
in this case that's what they've
actually done is remove those and we
just have the item the tire the price
and the quantity one of the things you
should be taking away from this is in
the scheme of things
we are in the descriptive phase we're
describing the data and we're
pre-processing the data what can we do
to clean it up
why dimensionality reduction
well number one less dimensions for a
given data set means less computation or
training time
that can be really important if you're
trying a number of different models
and you're re-running them over and over
again and even if you have seven
gigabytes of data that can start taking
days to go through all those different
models
so this is huge this is probably the
hugest part as far as reducing
our data set
redundancy is removed after removing
similar entries from the data set
again pre-processing some of our models
like a neural network if you put in two
of the same data it might give them a
higher weight than they would if it was
just once we want to get rid of that
redundancy
it also increases the processing time if
you have multiple
data coming in
space required to store the data is
reduced
so if we're committing this into a big
data
pool we might not send the company that
bought it why would we want to store two
whole extra columns when we added into
that pool of data makes the data easy
for plotting in 2d and 3d plots this is
my favorite part
very important you're in your
shareholder meeting
you want to be able to give them a
really good
clear
and simplified version you want to
reduce it down to something people can
take in
it helps to find out the most
significant features and skip the rest
which also comes in in post scribing
uh leads to better human interpretation
that kind of goes with number four it
makes data easy for plotting you have a
better interpretation when we're looking
at it principle component analysis
so what is it
uh principal component analysis is a
technique for reducing the
dimensionality of data sets increasing
interpretability but at the same time
minimizing information loss so we take
some very complex data set with lots of
variables we run it through the pca
we reduce the variables we end up with
the reduced variable setup
this is very confusing to look at
because if you look at the end result
we have the different colors all lined
up so what we're going to take a look at
is let's say we have a picture here
let's say you are asked to take a
picture of some toddlers and you are
deciding which angle would be the best
to take the picture from so if we come
up here we look at this we say okay this
is you know one angle
we get the back of a lot of heads not
many faces
so we'll do it from here we might get
the one person up front smiling a lot of
the people in the class are missing so
we have a huge amount off to the right
of blank space maybe from up here again
we have the back of someone's head
and it turns out that the best angle to
click the picture from might be this
bottom left angle you look at it you say
hey that makes sense it's a good
um configuration of all the people in
the picture now when we're talking about
data
it's not you really can't do it by what
you think is going to be the best we
need to have some kind of mathematical
formula so it's consistent and so it
makes sense in the back end
one of the projects i worked on many
years ago
has something similar to the iris and if
you've ever done the iris data sets
probably one of the
most common ones out there where they
have the flower
and they're measuring the stamen in the
petals and they have width and they have
length of the petal
instead of putting through the width and
the length of the petal we could just as
easily do the
width to length ratio we can divide the
width by the length and you get a single
number where you had two
that's the kind of idea that's going on
into this in pre-processing and looking
at what we can do to bring the data down
the very simplified example on my
iris
pedal example
when we look at the similarity in pca we
find the best picture or projection of
the data points
and so we look down at from one angle
we've drawn a line down there
we can see these data points based on in
this case just two variables now keep in
mind we're usually talking about 36 40
variables almost all of your
business models usually have about 26 to
27 different variables they're looking
at
same thing with like a bank loan model
we're talking 26 to 36 different
variables they're looking at that are
going in
so we want to do is we want to find the
best view in this case we're just
looking at the xy
we look down at it and we have our
second
idea pc2 and again we're looking at the
x i this x y this time from a different
direction
here for our e's we can consider that we
get two principal components namely pc1
and pc2
comparing both the principal components
we find the data points are sufficiently
spaced in pc1
so if you look at what we got here we
have
pc1 you can see along the line how the
data points are spaced versus the
spacing in pc2 and that's what they're
coming up with what is going to give us
the best look for these data points when
we combine them and we're looking at
them from just a single angle
whereas in pc2 they are less spaced
which makes the observation and further
calculations much more difficult
therefore we accept the pc one and not
the pc2 as the data points are more
spaced
now obviously the back end calculations
are a little bit more complicated when
we get into the math of how they decide
what is more valuable
this gives you an idea though that when
we're talking about this we're talking
about the perspective
which would help in understanding how
pca analysis works
we want to go ahead and do is dive into
the important terminologies under uh pca
and important terminologies are views
the perspective through which data
points are observed
and so you'll hear that if someone's
talking about a pca presentation and
they're not taking the time to reduce it
to something that the average person
shareholders can understand you might
hear them refer to it as the different
views what view are we taking
dimension number of columns in a data
set are called the dimensions of that
data set
and we talked about you'll hear features
dimensions um
i was talking about features there's
usually when you're running a business
you're talking 25 26 27 different
features minimal and then you have the
principal component new variables that
are constructed as linear combinations
or mixtures of the initial variables
principal component is very important
it's a combination if you remember my
flower example it would be the
width over the length of the petal as
opposed to putting both width and length
in you just put in the ratio instead
which is a single number versus two
separate numbers projections
the perpendicular distance between the
principal component and the data points
and that goes to that line we had
earlier it's that right angle line of
where those point how those points fall
onto the line
important properties important
properties number of principal
components is always less than or equal
to the number of attributes
that just makes common sense uh you're
not going to do
10 principal properties with only three
features
you're trying to reduce them so it's
just kind of goofy but it is important
to remember that people will throw
weird code out there and just randomly
do stuff with instead of really thinking
it through principal components are
orthogonal
and this is what we're talking about
that right angle from the line
when we do pc1 we're looking at how
those points fall on to that line
same thing with pc2 and we want to make
sure that pc1 does not equal pc2 we
don't want to have the same two
principal points
when we do two points the priority of
principal components decreases as their
numbers
increase
this is important to understand
if you're going to create
one principle
component
everything is summarized into that one
component as we go to two components the
priority
how much it holds value decreases as we
go down so if you have five different
points each one of those points is going
to have less value than just the one
point which has everything summarized in
it
how pca works
i said there was more in the back end we
talked about the math this is what we're
talking about is how does it actually
work
so now we have understanding that you're
looking at a perspective
now we want to see how that math side
works pca performs the following
operations in order to evaluate the
principal components for a given data
set
first we start with the standardization
then we have a covariance matrix
computation
and we use that to generate our i gene
vectors and i gene values
which is the feature vector and if you
remember the i gene vector is like a
translation for
moving the data from x equals one to x
equals two or whatever we're altering it
and the ign value is the final value
that we generate
we talk about standardization the main
aim of this step is to standardize the
range of the attributes so that each one
of them lie within similar boundaries
this process involves removal of the
mean from the variable values and
scaling the data with respect to the
standard deviation
and you can see here we have z equals
the variable values minus the mean over
the standard deviation
the covariance matrix computation
covariance matrix is used to express the
correlation between any two or more
attributes in multi-dimensional data set
the covariance matrix has the entries as
the variance and the covariance of the
tribute values the variance is denoted
by var and the covariance is denoted by
cov
on the right we can see the covariance
matrix for two attributes and their
values
when we do a hands-on and look at the
code we'll do a display of this so you
can see what we're talking about and
what that looks like
for now you can just notice that this is
a matrix that we're generating with the
variance and then the covariance of x to
y
on the right side we can see the
covariance
table for more than two attributes in a
multi-dimensional data set
this is what i was talking about we
usually are looking at not just one
feature two features
we're usually looking at 25 30 features
going on
and so if we do a setup like this we
should see all those different features
as the different variables
covariance matrix tells us how the two
or more variables are related positive
covariance indicate that the value of
one variable is directly proportional to
the other variable
negative covariance indicate that the
value of one variable is inversely
proportional to the other variable that
is always important to note whenever
we're doing any of these matrixes that
we're going to be looking at that
positive and negative whether it's
inverted or not
and then we have the iogene values and
the i gene vectors
iogene values and hygiene vectors are
the mathematical value
that are extracted from the covariance
table
they are responsible for the generation
of a new set of variables from the old
set of variables which further lead to
the construction of the principal
components
i gene vectors do not change directions
after linear transformation
i-gene values are the scalars or the
magnitude of the i-gene vectors
and again this is just chain
transforming that data so we're going to
change
the vector b
to the b
prime as denoted on the chart
and so we have like multiple variables
how do we calculate that new variable
and then we have feature vectors feature
vectors is simply a matrix that has igen
vectors of the components that we decide
to keep as the columns
here we decide whether we must keep or
discard the less significant principal
components that we have generated in the
above steps
this becomes really important as we
start looking at
the back end of this and we'll do this
in the demo
but one of the more important steps to
understand
and so we have the pca example consider
matrix x within rows or observations and
k columns or variables now for this
matrix we would construct a variable
space with as many dimensions as the
variable
but for our simplicity let's consider
this three dimensions for now
now each observation row of the matrix x
is placed in the k dimensional variable
space such that the rows in the data
table form a swarm of points in this
space
now we find the mean of all the
observations and then place it along the
data points on the plot
the first principal component
is a line that best accounts for the
shape of the point swarm it represents
the maximum variance direction in the
data
each observation may be projected onto
this line in order to get a coordinate
value along the pc1 this value is known
as a score
the usually only one principal component
is insufficient to model the systematic
variation for a data set thus a second
principal axis is created
the second principle component is
oriented such that it reflects the
second largest source of variation in
the data while being orthogonal to pc1
pc2 also passes through the average
point
let's go ahead and pull this up and just
see what that means
inside our python scripting
i'm going to use the anaconda navigator
and i will be in python 3.6
for this example i believe there's even
like a 3.9 out
i tend to stay in 3.6 because a lot of
the models i use especially with the
neural networks are stable in 3 6.
and then we open up our
jupiter i'm in chrome and we go ahead
and create a new python three
and for ease of use our team in the back
was nice enough to put this together for
me
and we'll go and start with the
libraries the first thing i like to do
whenever i'm looking at
any new setup
well you know what let's do let's do the
libraries first we're going to do our
basic libraries which is matplot library
the plt from the matplot library pandas
our data frame
pd numpy our numbers array np
seaborn for graphing sns that goes with
the plot that actually sits on that plot
library so the seaborn sits on there
and then we have our amber sign because
we're in jupiter notebook map plot
library in line the newer version
actually doesn't require that but i put
it in there either
anyway just because i'm so used to it
and then we want to go ahead and take a
look at the data
and in this case we're going to pull in
certainly you can have lots of fun with
different data but we're going to use
the cancer data set
one of the reasons the cancer data set
is it has like 36 35 different features
so it's kind of fun to use that as our
base for this
and we'll go ahead and run this and look
at our keys
and the first thing we notice in our
keys for the cancer data set
is we have our data we have our target
our frame target names description
feature names and file name
so
what we're looking for in all this
is
let's take a look at the description
let's go in here and pull up the
description on here
i'm not going to spend a huge amount of
time on the description
because this is we don't want to get
into a medical domain we want to focus
on our pca setup
what's important is you start looking at
what the different attributes are what
they mean
if you were in the medical field you'd
want to note all these different things
whether what they're measuring where
it's coming from
you can actually see the actual
different measurements they're taking
no missing attributes
we page all the way to the bottom and
you're going to have your data in this
case our target
and if you dig deep enough to the target
let's actually do this
let's go ahead and print target names
real quick here i always like to just
take a look and see what's on the other
end of this
target
names
run that
yeah so the target name is is it
malignant or is it b9
so in other words is this
a dangerous growth or is it something we
don't have to worry about that's the
bottom line with the cancer in this case
and then we can go ahead and load our
data and you know let me go up a just a
notch here for easy of reading
it's hard to get that just right that's
all you have to do
uh so let's go ahead and look at our
data uh our we're going to use our
pandas and we're going to go ahead and
do our data frame it's going to equal
cancer data columns equals cancer
feature equals feature names so remember
up here we already loaded the
names up of our of the features in there
what is going to come out of this let me
just see if we can get to that
it's at the top of target names
that's just this list of names here in
the setup
and we can go ahead and run this code
and it'll print the head
and you can see here we have the mean
radius the mean texture mean perimeter
i don't know about you this is a
wonderful data set if you're playing
with it because
like many of the data that cut most the
data that comes in half the time we
don't even know we're looking at
uh we're just handed a bunch of stuff as
a data scientist going what the heck is
this and so this is a good place to
start because this has a number of
different features in there we have no
idea what these feature means or where
they come from we want to just look at
the data and figure that out
and now we actually are getting into the
pca side of it as we've noticed before
is difficult to visualize high
dimensional data
we can use pca to find the first two
principal components and visualize the
data this new two-dimensional space with
a single scatter plot
before we do this we need to go ahead
and scale our data
now i haven't run this to see if you
really have to scale the data on this
but as just a general
run time i almost do that as the first
step of any modeling even if it's
pre-modeling as we're doing here
in neural networks that is so important
with pca visualization it's already
going to scale it when we do the means
and deviation inside the pca
but just in case it's always good to
scale it
and then we're going to take our pca
with the scikit learn uses very similar
process to other pre-processing
functions that come with scikit-learn
we instantiate a pca object find the
principal components using the fit
method then apply the rotation and
dimensionality reduction by calling
transform we can also specify how many
components we want to
keep when creating the pca object
and so the code for this
oops getting a little bit ahead
let me go and run this code
so the code for this
is
from sk learn decomposition import pca
pca equals pca in components equals two
and that's really important to note that
um because we're only going to want to
look at two components
i would never go over four components
especially if you're going to demo this
with somebody else if you're showing
this to the shareholders
the whole idea is to reduce it to
something people can see
and then the pca fit we're going to is
going to take the scaled data that we
generated up here
and then you can see we've created our
pca model with in components equals 2.
now whenever i use a new tool
i like to go in there and actually see
what i'm using so let's go to the scikit
uh webpage for the pca
and you can see in here here's our call
statement it describes what all the
different uh setups you have on
there probably the biggest one to look
at would be
well the biggest one is your components
how many components do you want
which you have to put in there pretty
much and then you also might look at the
svd solver it's on auto right now but
you can override that and do different
things with it it does a pretty good job
as it is
and if we
go down all the way down to
um
there we go
to our methods
if you notice we have fit
we have fit transform
nowhere in here is predict because this
is not used for prediction
it's used to look at the data again
we're in the described setup
we're fitting the data we're taking a
look at it
we've already looked at our
minimum maximum we've already looked at
what's in each quarter we've done a full
description of the data this is part of
describing the data
that's the biggest thing i take away
when i come zooming in here and of
course i have examples of it down here
if you forget
and the biggest one of course is the
number of components
and then i mean the rest you can play
with
the actual solver whether you're doing a
full or randomize there's different
things it does pretty good on the auto
and now we can transform this data to
its first two principal components
and so we have our xpca
we're going to set that equal to pca
transform scaled data
so there we go there's our first
transformation
and let's just go ahead and print the
scaled data shape and the xpca data
shape
and the reason we want to do this is
just to show us uh
what's going on here we've taken 30
features i think i said 36 or something
like that but it's 30
and we've compressed it down to two
features and we decided we wanted two
features and that's where this comes
from
we still have 569 data sets
i mean data rows not data sets we still
have 569 rows of data but instead of
computing 30 features we're now only
doing our model on two features
so let's go ahead and
plot these and take a look and see
what's going on
and
we're just going to use our plt figure
we'll set the figure size on here here's
our scatter plot
xpca
x underscore pca of
of one these are two different
perceptions we're using
and then
you'll see right here c for color
cancer equals target
and so remember we have zero we have one
and if i remember correctly zero was
malignant one was b9
uh so everything in the zero column is
going to be one color and the other
color is going to be one and then we're
going to use the plasma map just kind of
telling you what color it is add some
labels first principle component second
principal component and we'll go ahead
and run this
and you can see here instead of having a
chart one of those heat maps with 30
different
columns in it
we can look at this and say hey this one
actually did a pretty good job
of separating the data
and a couple things when i'm looking at
this that i notice is first
we have a very clear area where it's
clumped together
where it's going to be b9
and we have a huge area it's still
clumped together more spread out where
it's going to be malignant or i think i
had that backwards
and then in the middle
because we're dealing with something in
this particular case cancer
we would try to separate i would be
exploring how to separate this middle
group out
in other words there's an area where
everything overlaps and we're not going
to have a clear result on it just
because those are the people you want to
go in there and have extra tests
or treat it differently
versus going in and saying just cutting
into the can into the cancer so the body
absorbs it and it dissipates versus uh
actively going in there removing it
testing it going through chemo and all
the different things that's a big
difference you know as far as what's
going to happen here in that middle line
where the overlap is going to be huge
that's domain specific uh going back to
the data
we can see here
clearly by using these two components we
can easily separate these two classes
so the next step is what does that mean
interpreting the components
unfortunately with this great power of
dimensionality reduction comes the cost
of not being able to easily understand
what these components represent
i don't know what principle component
one looks work represents or second
principle
the components correspond to
combinations of original features the
components themselves are stored as an
attribute of the filtered pca object and
so we talk look at that we can go ahead
and do look at the pca components this
is in our model we built we've trained
it we can run that and you can see
here's the actual components uh it's the
two components have each have their own
array
and within the array you can see the
what the scores they're using
and these actually give weight to what
features are doing what
so in this numpy matrix array each row
represents a principal component and
each column relates back to the original
features what's really neat about this
is we can now go in reverse
and drop this onto a heat map
and start seeing uh what this means and
so let me go ahead and just put this
down up there to get it down here
uh we'll go ahead and put this in here
we're going to use our
df comp data frame and we do our pca
components
and i want you to notice how easy this
is
we're going to set our columns equal to
cancer feature names
that just makes it really easy
and we're dumping it into a data frame
what's neat about a data frame is when
we get to seaborn it will pull that data
frame apart and
and set it up for us what we want
and so we're just going to do the cn the
seaborn heat map
of our data frame composition and we'll
use the plasma coloring
and it creates a nice little
color graph here
you can see we have the mean radius and
all the different features along the
bottom
on the right we have a scale so we can
see we have the dark colors all the way
to the really light colors which are
what's really shining there this is like
the primary stuff we want to look at
so this heat map and the color bar
basically represent the correlation
between the various features and the
principal component
itself so you know very powerful map to
look at and then you can go in here and
we might notice that the mean radius
look how how on the bottom of the map it
is
um on some of this
so you have some interesting
correlations here that change the
variations on that and what means what
this is more when you get to a post
scribe you can also use this to try to
guess as what these things mean and what
you want to change to get a better
result
regularization in machine learning
so our agenda on this one is fitting the
data
understanding linear regression
bias and variance
what is overfitting what is underfitting
and those are like the biggest things
right now in data science is overfitting
and underfitting what does that mean
and what is regularization and then
we'll do a quick hands-on demo to take a
look at this
so fitting the data let's start with
fitting the data and we talk about what
is data fitting it's a process of
plotting a series of data points and
drawing the best fit line to understand
the relationship between the variables
and this is what we called data fitting
and you can see here we have a couple of
lines we've drawn on this graph we're
going to go in a little deeper on there
so we might have in this case just the
two dimensions we have an efficiency of
the car and we have the distance
traveled in 1 000 kilometers
and so what is data fitting well it's a
linear relationship and a linear
relationship
very specifically linear means line
the line used to represent the
relationship is a straight line that
passes through the data points and the
variables have linear relationship
linear regression
so let's start with how linear
regression works a linear regression
finds a line that best fits the data
point and gives a relationship between
the two variables
and so you can see here we have the
efficiency of the car
versus the distance traveled and you can
see this nice straight line drawn
through there
and when you talk about multiple
variables all you're doing is putting
this instead of a line it now becomes a
plane
it gets a little more complicated with
multiple variables but they all come
down to this linear kind of drawing a
line through your data and finding what
fits the the data the best
and so we can consider an example uh
let's say that we want to find the
relationship between the temperature
outside versus the sales of ice cream
and so we start looking at that we're
looking at the how many ice cream cones
we're selling or how much money we sold
in ice cream and we're looking at how
warm it is outside which would hopefully
draw a lot of people into the ice cream
store
and suppose we have two lines we're
going to draw l1 and l2 and we're going
to kind of guess which one we think is
the best fit
and which claim to describe the
relationship between the variables
and so first we find the square of the
distance between the line l1 and each
data point and add them all and find the
mean distance
and i want you to think about that when
we
square something if it's a negative or
positive number it no longer matters
because a minus 2 squared is 4 2 squared
is 4. so we're removing what side of the
line it's on and we're just looking for
the error in this case the mean distance
of each of the little dotted lines you
see here
this way of calculating the square of
the distance adding them and then taking
the mean is called mean square error or
loss function
and we talk about loss how far off are
we that's what we're really talking
about what did we miss
and we have a positive distance and a
negative distance and of course when we
square it it is neither it just becomes
a positive error
and so we take the mean
square error and a lot of times you'll
see it referred to as mse
if i look in the code and i'm going
through my python code and i see mse i
know that's a mean squared error
and we take all the dotted lines and we
calculate this error we add them all
together and then we average it or find
the means
and in this case
they ran a demo on this and it was uh
1127.27
for our l1 line
now we find the loss function for line
l2 in a similar fashion and we get the
mean square error to be 6397
and it's computed the same way so maybe
you put this line just way outside the
data range and this is the error you get
by analyzing our results we find that
the loss function or the mean square
error is less for l1 than l2
hence l1 is the best fit line
this process describes a lot of machine
learning processes it was we're going to
keep guessing and get as close as we can
to find the right answer we have to have
some way to invite to
calculate this and figure out which
one's the best and the mean square error
is one of the better fits to doing for
doing this and most commonly used
we really want to talk about bias and
variance
very important terms to know in machine
learning
and with linear regression
so bias
bias occurs when an algorithm has
limited flexibility to learn from data
variance defines the algorithm's
sensitivity to specific sets of data
let's start with bias and variance you
can see here we have the two different
setups
bias you can think is very generalized
where variance is very specific
and so we talk about bias such models
pay very little attention to the
training data and over simplify the
model
therefore the validation error or
prediction error and training error
follow similar trends
and uh with bias if you over simplify it
so much you're going to miss
your
local
uh if if you have like a really
good fit you're going to miss it you're
you're going to just kind of
guess what the average is and that's
what your answer is going to be
with variance a model with a high
variance pays a lot of attention to
training data and does not generalize
therefore the validation error or
prediction error are far apart from each
other
such models always lead to a high error
on training and test data as a bias does
where variants such models usually
perform very well on training data but
have high error rates on test data
and i want you to think about this um
when we're talking about a bias uh the
error is going to be high both when
you're training it and you're testing it
why because we're just kind of
getting an average we're not really
fitting it close
with variance we're fitting it so close
that the test data does really good it's
going to nail it every time if you're
doing categorical testing that's a car
that's a truck that's a bicycle
but with variants suddenly a
truck has to have certain features
and it might have to be red
because you had so many red pictures so
if it has if it's an 18 wheeler it has
to be red if it's blue then it has to be
a bicycle
that's the kind of variance we're
talking about where it picks up on
something and it cannot get the right
answer unless it gets a very specific
data and we see that so that as you're
testing it your models
and you programmed it you got to look
for
how i trained it what is coming out and
if it's not if it's not looking good on
either bias or if it's not looking good
on the training
or on the test data then your bias then
bias in your data
if it really looks good on the training
data then that's going to be your
variance you've over fitted the data
and those are very important things to
know when you are building your models
in regression of any kind or any kind of
setup for predicting
so in dark games if all the data found a
particular pointer this can be
considered as a biased throw and the
player aims for the particular score
for variance if all the darts fall in
different pointers and no two darts fall
on the same pointer then this can be
considered as a varied throw and the
player aims for various scores
again the bias sums everything up in one
point kind of averages it together where
the variance really looks for the
individual
predictions coming out
so let's go ahead and talk about
overfitting
when we talk about overfitting it's a
scenario where the machine learning
model tries to learn from the details
along with the noise and the data tries
to fit each data point on the curve
you can see that
if you plug in your coordinates you're
just going to get the whatever is fitted
every point on the data stream there's
no average there's no
two points that might have that you know
why might have two different answers
because uh if the wind blows a certain
way um and the efficiency of your car
maybe you have a headwind so your car
might alter how efficient it is as it
goes and so there's going to be this
variance on here and this says no you
can't have any variance with you know
the this is it's going to be exactly
this it can't be any you can't be the
same speed or the same car and have a
slightly different efficiency
so as the model has very less
flexibility it fails to predict new data
points and thus the model rejects every
new data point during the prediction
so you'll get like a really high error
on here
and so
reasons for overfitting
data used for training is not cleaned
and contains noise garbage values in it
you can spend so much time cleaning your
data
and it's so important it's so important
that if you have if you have some kind
of
something wrong with the data coming in
it needs to be addressed whether it's a
source of the data maybe they use in
medical different measuring tools
so you now have to adjust for data that
came in from hospital a versus hospital
b or even off of machine a and machine b
that's testing something and those those
numbers are coming in wrong
the model has a high variance
again wind is a good example i was
talking about that with the car
you may have a hundred tests but because
the wind's blowing it's all over the
place
size of training data used is not enough
so a small amount of data is going to
also cause this problem you only have a
few points and you try to plot
everything
the model is too complex
this comes up a lot
we put too many pieces together and how
they interact can't even be tracked um
and and so you have to go back back
break it up and find out actually what
correlates and what doesn't
so
what is underfitting a scenario where
machine learning models
can either learn
the relationship between the data points
nor predict
or classify a new data point
and you can see here we have our
efficiency of our car and our line drawn
and it's just going to be way off for
both the training and the predicting
data
as the model doesn't fully learn the
patterns it accepts every new data point
during the prediction
so instead of looking for a general
pattern we just kind of accept
everything
data used for training is not cleaned
and contains noise garbage and values
again under fitting and overfitting same
issue you got to clean your data
the model has a high bias
we've seen this in all kinds of things
from
the most common is the driving cars to
facial identification or whatever it is
the model itself when they build it
might have a bias towards one thing and
this would be an underfitted model would
have that bias because it's averaged it
out so if you have
five people
from india and 10 people from
africa and 20 people from the us you
created a bias
because it's looking at the 20 people
and you only have a small amount of data
to work with
size of training data used is not enough
that goes with the size i was just
talking about
so we have a model with a high bias we
have size of training data used it's not
enough the model is too simple
again this is one straight line through
all the data
when it needs a slight shift to it for
other reasons
so what is a good fit
a linear curve that best fits the data
is neither overfitting or under fitting
models but is just right
and of course we have the nice examples
here where we have overfitting
lines going up and down every point
starting to be include gluted
underfitting
the line really is off from where the
data is and then a good fit is got to
get rid of that minimize that
error coming through regularization is
taking the guess work out you're looking
at this graph and you're going oh which
one is that really over fit or is that
under fit that's pretty hard to tell
so we talk about regularization
regularization techniques are used to
calibrate the linear regression models
and to minimize the adjusted loss
function and prevent overfitting or
under fitting
so what that means in this case we're
going to go ahead and take a look at a
couple different things
we're going to look at regularization
which we'll start with a linear model
we'll look at the ridge regularization
and the lasso regularization
and these models are just like just like
we did the
mlp the multi-layered positron in the sk
learn module you could bring in the
ridge module and you can bring in the
lasso module
so when we talk about
ridge regression it modifies the
overfitted or underfitted models by
adding the penalty equivalent to the sum
of the squares of the magnitude of the
coefficients
and so we have a cost function equals
loss equals
lambda times the sum of w
squared or the absolute value of w
depending on how you're doing it now
remember we talked about error whether
we either square it or we absolute value
it
because that removes a plus or minus
sign on there and there's reasons to do
it either way but it is more common to
square the value
and then we have our
in this case the lambda is going to be
the penalty for the errors we've thrown
in a greek character for you just to
confuse everybody
and w is the slope of the curve of the
line
so we're going to look at this and we're
going to draw a line this is going to be
like a linear regression model so if you
had in sk sklearn you could import just
a standard linear regression model
it would plot this line across whatever
data we're working on
and we look at this of course we're just
extrapolating this i know they use some
specific data but you don't want to get
into the actual domain
and so for a linear regression line
let's consider two points that are on
the line
and we'll go ahead and have a loss
equals zero
considering the two points on the line
we'll go ahead and do lambda equals 1.
we'll set our w is going to be 1.4
then the cost function equals 0 plus 1
times 1.4 squared which equals 1.96
uh so really don't get caught up too
much in the math on this other than
understanding um that this is something
that's very easy for a computer to
calculate and if you ever see the loss
plus the plus the lambda times w the sum
of w squared
and then let's say we have a ridge
regression line and it does this we go
ahead and plot it and we do the
calculations on the data
and for the ridge regression let's
assume a loss equals 0.3 squared plus
0.2 squared equals 0.13 so when they put
all the calculations through
of the two points we end up with the
0.0.62
so we've now had a linear regression
model we now had a ridge regression
model
and the ridge regression model plots a
little differently than the standard
linear regression model
and comparing the two models with all
the data points we can see that the
ridge regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression line
and i find this true on a lot of data i
work with i'll end up using either the
ridge regression model or the lasso mars
regression model for fitting especially
dealing with a lot of like stock markets
daily
setup they come out slightly better you
get a slightly better
fit
and so we have our lasso we just talked
about lasso coming in here
and the cost function equals
instead of doing a squared we're just
going to do the absolute value and so if
you remember this is where ridge
regression changes where's my ridge
regression model
we're squaring the value here
and if you look at this we're not
squaring the value we're just finding
the absolute value on here and so the
loss of this of the squared individuals
and here is our
lambda symbol again penalty for errors
and w equals the slope of the curve
and comparing the two models with all
the data points we can see that the
lasso regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression line
and this is like i said i use these two
models a lot uh the ridge and this is
important this is
this is kind of the meat of the matter
how do you know which one to use some of
it is you just do it a bunch of times
and then you figure it out
ridge regularization is useful when we
have many variables with relatively
smaller data samples
the model does not encourage convergence
towards zero but is likely to make them
closer to zero and prevent overfitting
the lasso regularization model is
preferred when we are fitting a linear
model with fewer variables
so in the la in the iris thing we had
four or five variables as you measure
the different leaf pieces
uh you might be doing the measurements
on the cancer project which has 36
different variables
so as we get down to the iris with four
variables
lasso lar will probably work pretty good
where you might use the ridge
regularization with more model with if
you have something significantly larger
and it encourages the coefficients of
the variables to go towards zero because
of the shape of the constraint which is
an absolute value
and with any of this we want to go ahead
and
do a demo and lasso and ridge regression
so let's take a look and see what that
looks like in our code and bring up our
jupiter notebook
we'll start with our imports pandas is
pd import numpy is np import matplot
library as plt
um sklearn we're going to import our
data sets it's kind of more generic
we usually just import one data set
instead of all of them but you know
quick and dirty when you're putting some
of these together
we have our sklearn model selection
we're going to import our train test
split for splitting our data up
and then we'll bring in our linear
regression model
we'll go ahead and run these just to
load them up
and then load our data set we're just
talking about that
you could just um
have imported the load boston and boston
data set in there instead of loading all
the data sets
and then once we've loaded our data set
we want to go ahead and take a look at
that data and see what we got here
let me just go and pop that down there
and go and run it
and so we've gone ahead and taken our
boston
data we're going to look we put it into
our pandas data frame
the boston data set and then the boston
columns we want to see what's going on
with them
we have our target
we have the house price
etc and so our x equals boston
eye location
now remember in pandas the new updates
to pandas they want eye location
if you're going to pull data we used to
be able to leave this off
but it does something different it
creates a slice versus a direct
setup so make sure using that eye
location and the i the output so this is
all just bringing our data together
and we can see here if we do we print
the boston
panda's head
we can see here all of our different
aspects we're looking for
and if you're following the x and the y
the x is um everything
except for the last column
where y is uh all the it's that's what
this means all the rows except for the
last column and then y is all the rows
but just the last column so y is our
house price
and the x is the
crimsian industry chas knox and all
these other different
statistics they've collected for house
sales in boston
there we go oops control
so we'll go ahead and split our data
x train and our x
test y train y test equals the train
test split which we imported
and we have our boston you could have
easily used the x and y on here as
opposed to boston
eye location
and we'll create our test size we're
going to take 25 percent of the data and
put it in as a test
and then we'll go ahead and run this
need an extra drink there
uh so we have our train and test and
then of course the print the train data
shape
i love doing this kind of thing whenever
i'm working with this data print out the
shape
make sure everything looks correct uh so
that we have 127 by 13 and 127 by one
379 by 13 they should match and if
they're if the the data sets are not
quite matching
then you know something's wrong and
you're going to get all those errors i
don't know how many times i've gone
through here and
it's dropped a row on one of them and
not on the other or something weird has
happened when i'm cleaning the data
this is pretty straightforward and
simple because the data comes in a nice
pre-package is all clean for you
so let's go ahead and apply apply the
multiple linear regression model
and uh we'll call this lreg l reg linear
regression and we're going to go ahead
and fit that linear regression model to
x-train and y-train
then we'll generate the prediction on
the test set
so here's our l-reg y predict
with our x-test going into the
prediction
and let's calculate that mean square
error mse i told you you'll see mse used
a lot
people use it in variables and things
like that it's pretty common and we get
our mean squared error equals
this is just the basic formula we've
already been talking about what's the
difference squared
and then we look for the average of that
we'll go ahead and just run this
and you can see when we get through the
end of this we have our mean square
error on test
we have our total and then we have each
column coming down
and at this point unless you really know
the data you're working with it's not
going to mean a whole lot so if it's in
your domain you might be know what
you're looking at when you see these
kinds of numbers coming up
uh but if it's not it's just a bunch of
numbers and that's okay
at least that's okay for this demo uh
and then we're gonna go ahead and plot
these so we can see what's going on and
this is always kind of fun it's always
nice to have a nice visual of what
you're looking at and you can see here
when we plot the coefficient scores on
here
and we
the guys in the back did a great job
putting some pretty colors together
making it look nice and setting up the
columns
you can see here
uh your nox has like just a huge
coefficient
when i look at a table like this i look
for what has very little
different coefficients they're not using
a huge change and what has huge changes
and that flags you for all kinds of
things as you're working with the data
but it depends so much on the domain
you're working with
these are great things though as just a
quick look to see what's going on with
your data and what you're looking for
and of course once we look at this now
our motive is to reduce the coefficient
score so now we want to take these and
and
bring them down as much as we can
and for that we're going to work with
the ridge regression on here
so let's start by going we're going to
import our ridge model
the red regression from the sk learn
library or the psi kit
and we're going to go ahead and train
the model so here's our ridge
r equals alpha equals one and i
mentioned that earlier
when i work with the ridge model you'll
see alpha equals one if you set alpha
equal to zero that's a standard linear
regression model so you have alpha
equals one two three four and you
usually use one two or three four and a
standard integer on there
and we'll go ahead and fit the ridge
model on there with our x train and our
y train data
generate a prediction for that
for our x test
and we'll calculate the mean square
error
just like we did before this should all
look familiar
and we'll go ahead and print that out
and we'll look at the ridge coefficients
for our data and see what that looks
like
now
if i jump up and down between these two
you'll get a headache ah
you'll still see the knox value let's
just look at the knocks because that was
the biggest value it's a minus nine here
and if we go back up here the knox value
is a minus 18. so right off the bat i'm
seeing a huge change
in the biggest coefficient there
so if we're going to do that nice setup
we want to go ahead and just print it
and see what that looks like
there we go and we've uh set up our plot
subplots and again the team put together
some nice colors so it makes it look
good
and we're doing an x bar based on the
columns and our l regress coefficients
color equals color x spine bottom and so
forth
so just put together a nice little graph
and you're starting to see
one this when you compare this if you
put on the same graph as this one up
here this is up here minus 18.
this is at -9
and so this graph is half the size of
the graph above
the same thing with these values here
they might look the same but they're
actually all
almost half the value on here
and then finally you can do the same
thing for the lasso regression
this would all look very similar as far
as what we worked on before
and i'm just going to print that on here
and run it
and again let's go up to
knox
look where nox is it's all the way down
to
zero and if we look at our next biggest
coefficient is minus 0.8 and really
here's our
22.73
let me go up here
16.7
and we go up here and we look at the
same number
uh 16.69
and so we look at this
if i was running this in doing a working
on a project with this i would look at
these numbers i start with the 16.69
come down here and compare it to
16.78
6 9 is better than 7 8.
so from the very beginning we might
start looking at this first model for
overall
predicting
but there's other factors involved we
might know that
the knox value is central and the other
ones aren't quite as good and so we
might start looking at just certain
setups like what is our what is this
particular coefficient because it might
have
a certain meaning to us and so forth and
so you look at all those different
items in there again but the bottom
dollar is our first model did better
than our other two models our mean
square error on the test set
continues to
come down on this
today we're going to look at the need
for feature selection
what is feature selection
feature selection methods
feature selection statistics
so the need for feature selection to
train a model we collect huge quantities
of data to help the machine learn better
consider a table which contains
information on old cars
the model decides which cars must be
crushed for spare parts and when we talk
about huge quantities of data there they
save everything from people's favorite
cat pictures to
and you can imagine there's so much data
out there even in a company they'll save
all these little pieces of information
about people and companies and
corporations
you need some way to sort through
because if you try to run your models on
all of it
you'll end up with these very clunky
models and they might have issues which
we'll talk about later but in this case
we're talking about cars and crushing
but not all this data will be useful to
us some classes or part of the data may
not contribute much to our model and can
be dropped and you can see right here we
have who was the owner of the car
in our data a car will not be crushed
based on its previous owner
so you know that's kind of a clear cut
you can see that why would i care who
owned the car before once it's in the
junkyard and we're crushing the cars
we're not going to really care about
that
so here we have dropped the owner column
as it does not contribute to the model
having too much unnecessary data can
cause the model to be slow the model may
also learn from this irrelevant data and
be inaccurate
so feature selection is a process of
reducing the input variable to your
model by using only relevant data and
getting rid of the noise in the data
consider the database given below a
library wants to donate some old books
to make place in their shells for new
books
we want to train a model to automate
this task
in this case the color of the book does
not matter and keeping it can cause a
model to learn to donate books based on
color we can remove this as a feature
using feature selection we can optimize
our model in several ways
and so the number one is to prevent
learning from noise and overfitting
that's actually the huge one because we
we don't want it to give us the wrong
prediction and that means also improved
accuracy
so instead of giving us a wrong
prediction we also want it to be as
close to the right answer as we can get
and we want to reduce the training time
it's an exponential growth in some of
these models so the each feature you add
in increases that much
more training time we talk about feature
selection methods uh we put together a
lacil nice flowchart that shows the
various methods used for feature
selection
and you have your basic feature
selection and then there is supervised
and unsupervised
under supervised there's intrinsic
wrapper method
filter method
so we talk about unsupervised feature
selection refers to the method which
does not need the output label class for
feature selection and that was uh you
can see here under super unsupervised we
don't have i mean that's really a
growing market right now
unsupervised learning and so feature
selection is the same thing
supervised feature selection refers to
the method which uses the output label
class for the feature selection and if
you remember we looked at three
different
we have intrinsic wrapper and filter
method so we're going to start with the
filter method on this now remember we
know what the output is so we're going
to be looking at that output to see how
well it's doing versus the features in
this method features are dropped based
on their relation to the output or how
they are correlating to the output
you can see here we have a set of
features selecting best feature learning
algorithm and then performance and so we
want to find out which feature
correlates to the performance on the
output consider the example of book
classifier here we drop the color column
based on simple deduction
and that kind of sums it up in the in a
nutshell is we want to filter out things
that clearly do not go with what we're
looking for we look at the wrapper
method in the wrapper method we split
our data into subsets
and train a model using this based on
the output of the model we add and
subtract features and train the model
again
and you can see here in the wrapper
method we have a set of features we
generate a subset we run it through the
algorithm and we see how each one of
those subset of features performs
consider the book data set by using the
wrapper method we would use a subset of
different features to train the machine
and adjust the subset according to the
output and so you can see here let's say
we take a name and number of times read
and we run just those and we look at the
output and if we looked at him with all
four inputs and look at the output
we'd see quite a different variation in
there and we might say you know what
condition of the book and color really
doesn't affect what we're looking for
and you can see here we've run it on
condition of the book and color
depending on the output of the model we
will choose our final set of features
these features will give us the best
result for our model
and it might come up that the name
number of times red is probably pretty
important
the intrinsic method
this method combines the qualities of
both filter and wrapper method to create
the best subset
the model will train and check the
accuracy of different subsets and select
the best among them we kind of looked at
a little overview of some of the stuff
some of the common feature selection
algorithms based on which method they
belong to are given below
and you'll see it's primarily under
supervised there's not like i said a lot
of unsupervised methods and the ones
that are usually used these methods
and finds a way to create a supervised
connection between the data
and we talk about supervised methods we
have our filter method which we talked
about and it uses like the pearson's
coefficient
t squared anova coefficient those are
all under the filter method and in the
wrapper method
recursive feature elimination so
remember we're choosing a subset and we
want to go through there and look at
each one so you're just doing a lot of
loops or recursive calculations to see
which one works best and which ones
don't have an impact on the output
and there's a lot of genetic algorithms
to go with this too on the wrapper
method and how they evaluate it and with
the intrinsic method uh there's the two
main ones we're looking at is the lasso
regularization
the lasso algorithms are basically your
standard
regression model so it's finding out how
these different methods fit together and
which ones have the best
add together to have the least amount of
error
the other one used in the intrinsic
method is the decision tree it says hey
if this one is this one produces this
result this one produces this result yes
no which way do we go based on the input
and the output variables we can choose
our feature selection model so you have
your numeric input coming in you have a
numeric output if you use the pearson's
correlation coefficient
or spearman's rank coefficient
you can then
select what features you're going to
feed into that specific model and you
maybe have a numerical input and a
categorical input so we're going to be
looking more at a nova correlation
coefficient or kindle's rank coefficient
and if you have a core categorical input
and a numerical output we might be
looking at anova correlation coefficient
in kindle's rank coefficient
so based on the input and the output
variables we can choose our feature
selection model and you can see we have
categorical to categorical we might be
looking at the
chi squared test
contingency tables and mutual
information let's go and take a look and
see uh in the python code what we're
talking about here
and i'm going to go ahead and use for my
ide the jupiter notebook in the and i
always launch it out of anaconda on here
and we'll go ahead and go up here and
create a new python 3 module
and we'll call it
feature
select
since we're in python we're going to be
working mainly with your numpy your
pandas your matplot library so we have
our number array our data frame setup
which goes with the number array the
numpy the pandas data frame and then we
want to go ahead and graph everything so
we're going to import these three
modules
and then we put together some data
we're going to read this in it's kobe
bryant i guess he's a basketball player
our guys in the back uh we have a number
of them guys
both we have a lot of men and women so
it's probably a misnomer our team in the
back
um they have a some of them have a
liking for basketball and they know who
kobe bryant is and they want to learn a
little bit more about kobe bryant what's
going in for what whatever is going on
with his game
in basketball so we're going to take a
look at him
uh and once we import the data we can
see what columns are available
original features count so we can see
how many features there are
the length of it we'll actually have a
list of them and then print just
the data head the top five rows
and so when we do this
we can see from the csv file
we have 25 original features
our original features are your action
type combine shot type game event id and
so forth there's a lot of features in
here that they're recorded on all of his
shots this is we talk about like a
massive amount of data
i mean
people are sitting there and they record
all this stuff and they import this
stuff for different reasons
but depending on what we want to look at
do we really want all those features
maybe the question we're going to ask is
what's the chance of him making any one
specific shot
in right from the beginning we can look
at the some of these things and say team
name uh team name probably
i don't know maybe it does matter
because the other team might be really
good at defense
game date maybe we don't really want to
look at the game date team id definitely
not of importance in any of this
so we look at this we have 25 features
and some of these features just really
don't matter to us we also have location
x location y latitude and longitude i'm
guessing that's the same data we've
actually imported the
the very similar data maybe they're
slightly zoned differently
but as far as our program we don't want
to repeat data some of the models when
you repeat data into them and this is
true for most models create a huge bias
they weigh that data over other data
so just at a glance these are the things
we're looking at we want to find out
well how do we get this these features
down and get rid of this bias and all
these
extraneous features that we don't really
want to
spend time running our models on and
programming on
and as i pointed out there's a location
x location y latitude and longitude
let's take a look at that and see what
we're looking at here uh we'll go ahead
and create a plot of these
and we'll just plot we'll do a scatter
plot of location x and location y
and then we'll do a
scatter plot of
data lawn data lat which is probably
longitude and latitude
and the scatter plot let's go ahead and
actually put a little title here
location and scatter on there and we'll
just go ahead and plot these and when
you look at this
coming in
these two graphs are pretty identical
except they're flipped
and so when we look at the location from
which they're shooting from
they're probably the same and at this
point we can say okay we can get rid of
one of these sets of datas we don't need
both x and y and latitude and longitude
because it's the same data coming in and
as we look at this particular data the
latitude longitude we might also ask
does it really make a difference which
side of the court you're on whether
you're on the left side or the right
side
and so we might go ahead and explore
instead of looking at this as
x y we might look at it as a distance
and an angle and we can easily compute
that and you can see we can create our
data distance equals location x plus the
location y squared standard euclidean
geometry or
triangular geometry
hypotenuse squared equals the each side
squared
and then once we've done that
we can also compute the angle
so the data angle is based on the arc
tangent
and so forth on here so this is all this
is we're just going to compute the angle
here
and then set that up
pi over 2 to get our angle
and we'll go ahead and run that
and you'll see some errors run come up
and that's because when we took slices
over here we took a slice of a slice
there's ways to fix that but it's really
not important for this example
so if you do see that you want to start
looking up here for
um instead of data location x of uh
not location x0
this would be like um i believe the term
is ilo dot eye location uh if this was
yeah this is in pandas
uh so there's different things in there
but for this it doesn't really matter
these are just warnings that's all they
are and then let's combine our remaining
minutes and seconds column into one
there's another one so if you remember
up here we're trying to get rid of these
columns
do we really need let me see if i can
find it on here there we go there's our
minutes remaining
and then they had
what was it it was minus remaining and
seconds column so there's also a seconds
column on here
you see i can find that one
this is where it really gets kind of
crazy because here's our seconds
remaining so you can see that here's our
minutes remaining this gets crazy when
you're looking at hundreds of these
features and you can see that if if i'm
going to
say
write a model that's going to predict a
lot of this and i wanted to run in this
case it's a basketball and how good his
shots are as the data comes in let's say
i want to have it run on your phone
if i'm running it across hundreds of
features
it's going to just hang up on your phone
or if i can get it down to just a
handful
we'll actually be able to come in here
and run it on a smaller device and not
use up as much memory
or processing power
so we'll go ahead and take data
remaining time here
and data minutes remaining times 60 plus
data seconds remaining so we're just
going to combine those
and we'll go ahead and reprint our data
so we can see what we got
coming across we have our action type
combined and this is we do this a lot
we want to take a look at oops i got so
so zoomed in let me see if i can zoom
out just a little bit
there we go
boom
all right so we come up here you can see
that we now have our distance our angle
remaining time which is now just a
number
uh that computes both the minutes and
seconds together
and we still have we've
we've been adding columns i thought you
said we're supposed to subtract columns
right
um we're going to delete the obsolete
columns when we get to them uh so we're
just filtering out and this is a filter
method we're just filtering through the
things
that we really
don't need and next let's go ahead and
explore team id and team name
let me just go ahead and run that and if
you look at this we have los angeles
lakers and then they have the team id
here and they're unique
there's not that's not really anything
that's going to come up because that's
this particular
athlete's
works for that team so it's the same on
every line so there's another thing we
can filter out on there team id and t
name is just useless the whole column
contains only one value each and
it's pretty much useless
let's go ahead and take a look at match
up an opponent that's an interesting one
and we see here that we have
the lal versus o r and the opponent is p
o r and i n d
again here's a lot of duplicate
information
so
this basically contains the same
information on here
again we're filtering all this stuff out
and this is because we're only looking
at one athlete and this might change if
you're looking at multiple athletes that
kind of thing now these are easy to see
but we might have something that looks
more like this
we might have something where we're
looking at the distance which we
computed and the shot distance are they
the same thing
and what we can do is we can plot that
and plot them against each other on here
and we see it just draws a nice straight
line
and so
again we're looking at the same
information
so again we're repeating stuff and we
really don't want to be running our
model on
uh repeat information on here so again
it contains the same information so now
let's look at the shot zone area
shot zone basic shot zone range
so now we're looking at the zones and
what does that mean and we'll go ahead
and do this also in a scatter plot
in this case we're going to just create
three of these side by side so we're
going to create
our plot figure side 20 by 10
and then we're going to define our
scatter plot by category feature and
we're going to do each one
set up on here give it a slightly
different color and so our shot zone
area is going to be plot
subplot 131 scatter 131 is how that's
red by the way
meaning that
it's number one
we have three across
and this is the first one down so one
one one our scatter plot by category is
going to be the shot zone area we're
going to plot that
and then we're going to do the
shot zone basic and then the shot zone
range and he's just pushing through our
definition so each of those areas go
through and you'll see one three one one
three two one three three
again it's a one by three
setup and then it's just a place on each
one and so we look at this we can see
that these shots
they map out the same so it's very again
redundant information
that should be intuitive
when we're looking at this
in this color graphs
it kind of helps you start looking at
something you that it's very intuitive
like this is and you start to realize
that some of this stuff
you'll be looking for in data you might
not understand
and you'll see these circular patterns
where they match or they mostly match
and you start to realize
when you're looking at these that
they're repetitive data and then you
want to explore them more closely
depending on what domain you're working
in so we look at these we look at them
and they look just like the regions of
the court but we already have stored
this information in angle and distance
columns so we've seen this image before
we go back up here
and here's our the similar image
and repeating that image is down here
and so let's go ahead and drop some of
this in this stuff so now let's drop all
the useless columns
and we can drop the shot id team id team
name
shot zone area shot zone range shot zone
basic
the match up
the longitude and latitude because we're
putting that into distance
seconds remaining minutes remaining
because we combine that into one column
shot distance because we have just
distance on there location x location y
the game event id game id all this stuff
is just being dropped on here and we'll
just go ahead and loop through our drops
and this is a nice way of doing this
because as you're playing with this
this kind of data
putting your list into one setup
helps because then you're just running
it through an iteration
and you can come back and change it you
might be playing with different models
and do this with models you might be
looking at all kinds of different things
that you can drop and add in as you test
these out and again we're working in the
filter method so this is a lot of human
interaction with the data and it takes a
lot of critical thinking to look at this
stuff and say what matches and what
doesn't
and so we look at the remaining features
let me go ahead and just run this
uh the original to the new count we had
25 features now we have 11 features you
can see that right there we just circle
that there's our 25 and there's uh old
new now we're down to 11. so we've cut
it down to less than half
and you can just see
the actual different information on here
and the remaining time
at this point we filtered it through and
then we'd move into the next process
which would be to run our model on this
and maybe we would drop
some of the features and see if it runs
better or worse and what happens
that's kind of would be the next step on
there versus the filter setup and that
would be one of the other setups
depending on which algorithm you use so
that wraps up our demo on
filter the feature selection and going
through and seeing how these different
features are being repeated in this
particular in a basketball
setup why reinforcement learning
training a machine learning model
requires a lot of data which might not
always be available to us
further the data provided might not be
reliable learning from a small subset of
actions will not help expand the vast
realm of solutions that may work for a
particular problem
you can see here we have the robot
learning to walk
very complicated setup when you're
learning how to walk and you'll start
asking questions like if i'm taking one
step forward and left
what happens if i pick up a 50 pound
object how does that change how a robot
would walk
these things are very difficult to
program because there's no actual
information on it until it's actually
tried out learning from a small subset
of actions will not help expand the vast
realm of solutions that may work for a
particular problem
and we'll see here learned how to walk
this is going to slow the growth that
technology is capable of machines need
to learn to perform actions by
themselves and not just learn off humans
you see the objective climb a mountain
real interesting point here
is that as human beings we can go into a
very unknown environment
and we can adjust for it and kind of
explore and play with it
most of the models the non-reinforcement
models in computer
machine learning aren't able to do that
very well there's a couple of them that
can be used or integrated to see how it
goes
is what we're talking about with
reinforcement learning so what is
reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning is a sub-branch
of machine learning that trains a model
to return an optimum solution for a
problem by taking a sequence of
decisions by itself
consider a robot learning to go from one
place to another
the robot is given a scenario must
arrive at a solution by itself the robot
can take different paths to reach the
destination
it will know the best path by the time
taken on each path it might even come up
with a unique solution all by itself
and that's really important is we're
looking for unique solutions
we want the best solution but you can't
find it unless you try it
so we're looking at uh our different
systems our different model we have
supervised versus unsupervised versus
reinforcement learning and with the
supervised learning that is probably the
most controlled environment we have a
lot of different supervised learning
models whether it's linear regression
neural networks
there's all kinds of things in between
decision trees the data provided is
labeled data with output values
specified
and this is important because we talk
about supervised learning you already
know the answer for all this information
you already know the picture has a
motorcycle in it so you're supervised
learning you already know that
the outcome for tomorrow for you know
going back a week you're looking at
stock you can already have like the
graph of what the next day looks like so
you have an answer for it
and you have labeled data which is used
you have an external supervision and
solves problems by mapping labeled input
to known output
so very controlled
unsupervised learning and unsupervised
learning is really interesting because
it's now taking part in many other
models they start with and you can
actually insert an unsupervised learning
model
in almost either supervised or
reinforcement learning as part of the
system which is really cool
data provided is unlabeled data the
outputs are not specified machine makes
its own predictions
used to solve association with
clustering problems unlabeled data is
used no supervision solves problems by
understanding patterns and discovering
output
so you can look at this and you can
think
some of these things go with each other
they belong together so it's looking for
what connects in different ways and
there's a lot of different algorithms
that look at this
when you start getting into those are
some really cool images that come up
of what unsupervised learning is how it
can pick out say
the area of a donut
one model will see the area of the donut
and the other one will divide it into
three sections based on its location
versus what's next to it so there's a
lot of stuff that goes in with
unsupervised learning
and then we're looking at reinforcement
learning probably the biggest industry
in today's market
in machine learning or growing market is
very it's very infant stage
as far as how it works and what it's
going to be capable of
the machine learns from its environment
using rewards and errors used to solve
reward based problems
no predefined data is used no
supervision
follows trail and error problem solving
approach
so again we have a random first you
start with a random i try this it
works and this is my reward doesn't work
very well maybe or maybe doesn't even
get you where you're trying to get it to
do and you get your reward back and then
it looks at that and says well let's try
something else
and it starts to play with these
different things finding the best route
so let's take a look at important terms
in today's reinforcement model
and this has become pretty standardized
over the last few years
so these are really good to know
we have the agent
agent is the model that is being trained
via reinforcement learning so this is
your actual
entity that has however you're doing it
with using a neural network or a
cue table or whatever combination
thereof
this is the actual agent that you're
using this is the model
and you have your environment uh the
training situation that the model must
optimize to is called its environment
and you can see here i guess we have a
robot who's trying to get uh chest full
of gyms or whatever and that's the
output and then you have your action
this is all possible steps that can be
taken by the model and it picks one
action and you can see here it's picked
three different routes to get to the
chest of diamonds and gyms
we have a state the current position
condition returned by the model
and you could look at this if you're
playing like a video game
this is the screen you're looking at so
when you go back here
the environment is a whole
game board so if you're playing one of
those mobius games
you might have the whole game board
going on uh but then you have your
current position where are you on that
game board what's around that what's
around you
if you were talking about a robot the
environment might be moving around the
yard
where it is in the yard and what it can
see what input it has in that location
that would be the current position
condition returned by the model and then
the reward
to help the model move in the right
direction it is rewarded points are
given to it to appraise some kind of
action
so yeah you did good or didn't do as
good trying to maximize the reward and
have the best reward possible
and then policy policy determines how an
agent will behave at any time it acts as
a mapping between action and present
state
this is part of the model what what is
your action that you're you're going to
take what's the policy you're using to
have an output from your agent
one of the reasons they separate
policy as its own entity
is that you usually have a prediction
of a different options
and then the policy well how am i going
to pick the best based on those
predictions i'm going to guess at
different options
and we'll actually weigh those options
in and find the best option we think
will work
so it's a little tricky but the policy
thing is actually pretty cool how it
works
let's go and take a look at a
reinforcement learning example
and just in looking at this we're going
to take a look consider what a dog
that we want to train
so the dog would be like the agent so
you have your your puppy or whatever
and then your environment is going to be
the whole house or whatever it is where
you're training them
and then you have an action we want to
teach the dog to fetch
so action equals fetching
and then we have a little biscuit so we
can get the dog perform various actions
by offering incentives such as a dog
biscuit as a reward
the dog will follow a policy to maximize
this reward and hence will follow every
command and might even learn new actions
like begging by itself
uh so you have a you know so we start
off with fetching it goes oh i get a
biscuit for that it tries something else
you get a handshake or begging or
something like that and it goes oh this
is also reward based and so it kind of
explores things to find out what will
bring his biscuit
and that's very much like how a
reinforced model goes as it
looks for different rewards how do i
find can i try different things and find
a reward that works
the dog also will want to run around and
play an explorer's environment
this quality of model is called
exploration so there's a little
randomness going on in exploration
and explores new parts of the house
climbing on the sofa doesn't get a
reward in fact it usually gets kicked
off the sofa
so let's talk a little bit about
markov's decision process
is a reinforcement learning policy used
to map a current state to an action
where the agent continuously interacts
with the environment to produce new
solutions and receive rewards
and you'll see here's all of our
different
vocabulary we just went over we have a
reward our state our agent our
environment interaction and so even
though the environment kind of contains
everything
that you really when you're actually
writing the program your environment is
going to put out a reward in state that
goes into the agent
the agent then looks at this state or it
looks at the reward usually
first and it says okay i got rewarded
for whatever i just did or it didn't get
rewarded
and it looks at the state
and then it comes back and if you
remember from
policy the policy comes in
and then we have a reward the policy is
that part that's connected at the bottom
and so it looks at that policy and says
hey what's a good action that will
probably be similar to what i did or
sometimes they're completely random but
what's a good action that's going to
bring me a different reward
so taking the time to just understand
these different pieces as they go
is pretty important in most of the
models today
and so a lot of them actually have
templates
based on this you can pull in and start
using
pretty straightforward as far as once
you start seeing how it works
uh you can see your environment
sends it says hey this is the agent did
this if you're a character in the game
this happened and it shoots out a reward
in a state the agent looks at the reward
looks at the new state and then takes a
little guess and says i'm going to try
this action and then that action goes
back into the environment it affects the
environment the environment then changes
depending on what the action was
and then it has a new state and a new
reward that goes back to the agent
so in the diagram shown we need to find
the shortest path between node a and d
each path has a reward associated with
it and the path with a maximum reward is
what we want to choose
the nodes a b c d denote the nodes to
travel from node
a to b
is an action reward is the cost of each
path and policy is each path taken
and you can see here a can go uh to b
or a can go to c right off the bat or
can go right to d and if explored all
three of these
you would find that a going to d was a
zero reward
a going to c and d would generate a
different reward
or you could go a c b d there's a lot of
options here
and so when we start looking at this
diagram you start to realize
that even though today's reinforced
learning models do really good at
finding an answer they end up trying
almost all the different directions you
see
and so they take up a lot of work
or a lot of processing time for
reinforcement learning they're right now
in their infant stage and they're really
good at solving simple problems
and we'll take a look at one of those in
just a minute in the tic-tac-toe game
but you can see here
once it's gone through these and it's
explored it's going to find the a c d
is the best reward he gets a full 30
points for it
so let's go ahead and take a look at a
reinforcement learning
demo
uh in this demo we're going to use
reinforcement learning to make a
tic-tac-toe game you'll be playing this
game against the machine learning model
and we'll go ahead and we're doing it in
python so let's go ahead and go through
i always not always actually have a lot
of python tools let's go through
anaconda which will open up a jupiter
notebook seems like a lot of steps but
it's worth it to keep all my stuff
separate and it's also has a nice
display when you're in the jupiter
notebook for doing python
so here's our anaconda navigator i open
up the notebook which is going to take
me to a webpage and i've gone in here
and created a new python folder in this
case i've already done it and enabled it
to change the name to tic-tac-toe and
then for this example we're going to go
ahead and
import a couple things we're going to
import numpy as np we'll go ahead and
import pickle numpy of course is our
number array and then pickle is just a
nice way sometimes for
storing uh different information
different states that we're going to go
through on here
and so
we're going to create a class called
state we're going to start with that
and there's a lot of lines of code to
this class that we're going to put in
here
don't let that scare you too much
there's not as much here
it looks like there's going to be a lie
here but there really is just a lot of
setup going on in the in our class state
and so we have up here we're going to
initialize it um we have our board
it's a tic tac toe board so we're only
dealing with nine spots on the board
uh we have player one player two
uh is end we're gonna create a board
hash we'll look at that in just a minute
we're just going to store some
information in there symbol player
equals one
so there's a few things going on as far
as the initialization
then something simple we're just going
to get the hash
of the board you get the information
from the board on there which is columns
and rows we want to know when a winner
occurs uh so if you get three in a row
that's what this whole section here is
for
uh let me go ahead and
scroll up a little bit and you can get a
copy of this code if you send a note
over to simply learn we'll send you over
this particular file and you can play
with it yourself and see how it's put
together
i don't want to spend a huge amount of
time on this because this is just some
real general python coding
but you can see here we're just going
through all the rows
and you add them together and if it
equals three three in a row same thing
with
columns
diagonals so you got to check the
diagonal that's what all this stuff does
here is it just goes through the
different areas actually let me go ahead
and put
there we go
and then it comes down here and we do
our sum and it says true
minus three just says did somebody win
or is it a tie
so you gotta add up all the numbers on
there anyway just in case they're all
filled up
and next we also need to know available
positions
these are ones that don't no one's ever
used before
this way when you try something or the
computer tries something
it's not going to give it an illegal
move that's what the available positions
is doing
then we want to update our state
and so you have your position going in
we're just sending in the position that
you just chose and you'll see there's a
little user interface we put in there we
can
pick the row and column in there
and again
i mean this is a lot of code
so really it's kind of a thing you'd
want to go through and play with a
little bit and just read through it get
a copy of it a great way to understand
how this works
and here is a given reward
so we're going to give a reward result
equals self winner
this is one of the hearts of what's
going on here
is we have a result self.winner
so if there's a winner then we have a
result that the result equals one here's
our feedback
if it doesn't equal one then it gets a
zero so it only gets a reward in this
particular case
if it wins
and that's important to know because
different
systems of reinforced learning
do rewarding a lot differently depending
on what you're trying to do this is a
very simple example with a
three by three board
imagine if you're playing a video game
uh certainly you only have so many
actions but your environment is huge you
have a lot going on in the environment
and suddenly a reward system like this
is going to be just
is going to have to change a little bit
it's going to have to have different
rewards and different setup and there's
all kinds of advanced ways to do that as
far as weighing you add weights to it
and so
they can add the weights up depending on
where the reward comes in so it might be
that you actually get a reward in this
case you get the reward at the end of
the game
and i'm spending just a little bit of
time on this this is an important thing
to note but there's different ways to
add up those rewards it might have like
if you take a certain path
the first reward
is going to be weighed a little bit less
than the last reward because the last
reward is actually winning the game or
scoring or whatever it is
so this reward system gets really
complicated in some of the more advanced
uh setups
in this case though
you can see right here that they give a
a 0.1 and a 0.5 reward
just for getting picking the right value
and something that's actually valid
instead of picking an invalid value so
rewards again that's like key it's huge
how do you
feed the rewards back in
then we have a board reset that's pretty
straightforward it just goes back and
resets the board to the beginning
because it's going to try out all these
different things while it's learning
it's going to do it by trial and error
so you have to keep resetting it
and then of course there's the play we
want to go ahead and play rounds equals
depends on what you want to do on here
you can set this
different you can obviously set that to
higher level but this is just going to
go through and you'll see in here
that we have player 1 and player 2.
this is this is the computer playing
itself
one of the more powerful ways to learn
to play a game
or even learn something that isn't a
game is to have two of these models
that are basically trying to beat each
other and so they always they keep
finding explore new things this one
works for this one so this one tries new
things it beats this we've seen this in
chess i think with some big one where
they had the two players in chess with
reinforcement learning uh it was one of
the ways they trained one of the top
computer chess playing algorithms
uh so this is just what this is it's
going to choose an action it's going to
try something and the more i try stuff
um the more we're going to record the
hash we actually have a board hash where
they self get the hash
setup on here where it stores all the
information
and then once you get to a win
one of them wins it gets the reward
uh then we go back and reset and try
again and then kind of the fun part we
actually get down here is we're going to
play
with a human so we'll get a chance to
come in here and see what that looks
like
when you put your own information in
and then it just comes in here and does
the same thing it did above it gives it
a reward for its things
or sees if it wins or ties
looks at available positions all that
fun of fun stuff
and then finally we want to show the
board
so it's going to print the board out
each time
really
as an integration is not that exciting
what's exciting
in here is one looking at this reward
system whoops play one more up the
reward system is really the heart of
this how do you reward the different
setup
and the other one is when it's playing
it's got to take an action
and so
what it chooses for an action is also
the heart of reinforcement learning how
do we choose that action
and those are really
key to right now where reinforcement
learning is
in
today's technology is
figuring this out
how do we reward it and how do we guess
the next best action so we have our
environment and you can see the
environment is we're going to be or the
state
which is kind of like what's going on
we're going to return the state
depending on what happens
we want to go ahead and create our agent
in this case our player so each one is
let me go and grab that
until we look at a class player um
this is where a lot of the magic is
really going on is what how is this
player figuring out how to maneuver
around the board and then the board of
course returns a state
that it can look at and a reward uh so
we want to take a look at this we have
uh name
self-state this is class player and when
you say class player we're not talking
about a human player we're talking about
just
the computer players
and this is kind of interesting so
remember i told you depending on what
you're doing there's going to be a decay
gamma
explore rate
these are what i'm talking about is how
do we train it um
as you try different moves it gets to
the end the first move is important but
it's not as important as the last one
and so you could say that the last one
has the heaviest weight and then as you
as you get there the first one let's see
the first move gives you a five reward
the second gives you a two reward and
the third one gives you a 10 reward
because that's the final ending you got
it
the ten is going to count more than the
first step
and here's our we're going to get the
board information coming in and then
choose an action this was the second
part that i was talking about that was
so important
so once you have your training going on
we have to do a little randomness and
you can see right here is our np random
uniform so it's picking out a
random number
take a random action
this is going to just pick which row and
which column it is
um and so choosing the action
this one you can see we're just doing
random states um choice length of
positions action position
and then it skips in there and takes a
look at the board
for p in positions it's actually storing
the different boards each time you go
through
so it has a record of what it did so it
can properly weigh the values
and this simply just depends a hash
state what's the last date pinned it to
the
to our states on here
here's our feedback
rewards the reward comes in and it's
going to take a look at this and say is
it none
what is the reward and here is that
formula remember i was telling you about
up here
that was important because it has
decay gamma times the reward
this is where
as it goes through each step
and this is really important this is
this is kind of the heart of this of
what i was talking about earlier uh you
have step one
and this might have a reward of two
you have step two i should probably
should have done abc this has a step
three
uh step 4
and so on until you get to step in
and this might have a reward of 10.
so reward a 10
we're going to add that but we're not
adding uh let's say this one right here
uh let's see this reward here right
before 10 was
um let's see it's also 10. it just makes
the the
math easy
so we had 10 and 10.
we had 10 this is 10 and 10 in whatever
it is but it's time it's 0.9
so instead of putting a full 10 here
we only do 9 that's a
0.9
times
10.
and so this formula
as far as the decay times the reward
minus the cell state value
uh it basically adds in it says here's
one or here's two i'm sorry i should
have done this abc would have been
easier
so the first move goes in here and it
puts two in here
uh then we have our self
set up on here you can see how this gets
pretty complicated in the math but this
is really the key is how do we train
our states and we want the the final
state the win to get the most points if
you win you get most points
and the first step gets the least amount
of points
so you're really training this almost in
reverse you're training you're training
it from the last place where you have
like it says okay this is now i was need
to sum up my rewards and i want to sum
them up going in reverse and i want to
find the answer in reverse kind of an
interesting
play on the mind when you're trying to
figure this stuff out
and of course we want to go ahead and
reset the board down here
save the policy
load policy
these are the different things that are
going in between the agent and the state
to figure out what's going on
let's go ahead and load that up
and then finally we want to go ahead and
create a human player
and the human player is going to be a
little different
in that
you choose an action row and column
here's your action
uh if action is
if action in positions meaning positions
that are available
you return the action
if not it just keeps asking you until
you get the action that actually works
and then we're going to go ahead and
append to the hash state which we don't
need to worry about because it returns
the action up here
and feed forward uh
again this is because it's a human
um at the end of the game bat propagate
and update state values
this part isn't being done because
it's not programming uh
the model the model is getting its own
rewards
so we've gone ahead and loaded this in
here
so here's all our pieces and the first
thing we want to do
is set up p1 player 1
p2 player 2
and then we're going to send our players
to our state so now it has p1 p2
and it's going to play and it's going to
play 50 000 rounds
now we can probably do a lot less than
this and it's not going to get the full
results in fact you know what
let's go ahead and just do five
just to play with it because i want to
show you something here
oops
somewhere in there i forgot to load
something
there we go i must just forgot to run
this run
oops forgot a reference there for the
board rows and columns three by three
there is actually in the state it
references that we just tack it on on
the end it was supposed to be at the
beginning
so now i've only set this up
with
see where we go in here i've only set
this up to train
five times
and the reason i did that is we're going
to
come in and actually play it and then
i'm going to change that and we can see
how it differs on there
there we go and then you make it through
a run and we're going to go ahead and
save the policy
so now we have our player 1 and our
player 2 policy
the way we set it up it has two separate
policies loaded up in there
and then we're going to come in here and
we're going to do uh player 1 is going
to be the computer experience rate 0
load policy 1
human player human and we're going to go
ahead and play this i remember only went
through it
just one round of training in fact
minimal training and so it puts an x
there and i'm going to go ahead and do
row 0
column 1.
you can see this is very
basic on here
and
so i put in my zero and then i'm gonna
go zero block it zero zero
and you can see right here it let me win
uh just like that i was able to win zero
two
and whoo human wins
so i only trained it five times we're
going to run this again
and this time
instead of five let's do five thousand
or fifty thousand i think that's what
the guys in the back had
and this takes a while to train it
this is where reinforcement learning
really falls apart
look how simple this game is we're
talking about a three by three set of
columns
and so for me to train it on this
um i could do a q table which would take
which would go much quicker um you could
build a quick cue table with almost all
the different options on there
and
you would probably get a the same result
much quicker
we're just using this as an example
so when we look at reinforcement
learning you need to be very careful
what you apply it to it sounds like a
good deal until you do like a large
neural network
where you're doing you set the neural
network to a learning increment of one
so every time it goes through it learns
and then you do your actions you pick
from the learning
setup and you actually try actions on
the learning setup until you get the
what you think is going to be the best
action
so you actually feed what you think is
right back through the neural network
there's a whole layer there which is
really fun to play with
and then it has an output well think of
all those processes i mean that is just
a huge amount of work it's going to do
let's go ahead and skip ahead here give
it a moment it's going to take a
minute or two to go ahead and run
now to train it
we went ahead and let it run and it took
a while this this took um i got a pretty
powerful processor and it took about
five minutes plus to run it
and we'll go ahead and uh
run our player setup on here oops
brought in the last
whoops i brought in the last round so
give me just a moment to re
do the policy save there we go i forgot
to save the policy back in there
and then go ahead and run our player
again
so we've saved the policy then we want
to go ahead and load the policy for p1
as the computer
and we can see the computer's gone in
the bottom right corner i'm going to go
ahead and go one one which is the center
and it's gone right up the top and if
you i've ever played tic-tac-toe you
know the computer has me but we'll go
ahead and play it out
row zero
column two
there it is and then it's gone here and
so i'm going to go ahead and go row zero
one
two
no zero one there we go and column zero
that's where i want it
oh and it says okay you your action
there we go boom
uh so you can see here we've got a
didn't catch the win on this it said tie
kind of funny they didn't catch the win
on
there but if we play this a bunch of
times you'll find it's going to win more
and more the more we train it the more
the reinforcement happens
this lengthy training process
is really the stopper on reinforcement
learning
as this changes reinforcement learning
will be one of the more powerful
packages evolving over the next decade
or two
in fact i would even go as far as to say
it is the most important
machine learning tool an artificial
intelligence tool out there
as it learns not only a simple tic tac
toe board but we start learning
environments and the environment would
be like in language
if you're translating a language or
something from one language to the other
so much of it is lost if you don't know
the context it's in what the
environments it's in and so being able
to attach environment and context and
all those things together is going to
require reinforcement learning to do
so again if you want to get a copy of
the tic tac toe board it's kind of fun
to play with uh run it you can test it
out you can do
you know test it for different uh values
you can switch from p1 computer
where we loaded the policy one to load
the policy two and just see how it
varies there's all kinds of things you
can do on there so what is q learning q
learning is reinforcement learning
policy which will fill the next best
action given a current state it chooses
this action at random and aims to
maximize the reward
and so you can see here's our standard
reinforcement learning graph
by now if you're doing any reinforcement
learning
you should
be familiar with this where you have
your agent your agent takes an action
the action affects the environment
and then the environment sends back the
reward or the feedback and the state
it's the new state the agent's in where
is it at on the chessboard where is it
at in the video game
if your robots out there picking trash
up off the side of the road where is it
at on the road
consider an ad recommendation system
usually when you look up a product
online
you get ads which will suggest the same
product over and over again
using q learning
we can make an ad recommendation system
which will suggest related products to
our previous purchase
the reward will be if user clicks on the
suggested product
and again you can see
you might have a lot of products on your
web advertisement or your pages but it's
still not a float number it's still a
set number and that's something to be
aware of when you're using q learning
and you can see here that if you have a
hundred people clicking on ads
and you click on one of the ads it might
go in there and say okay this person
clicked on this ad
what is the best set of ads based on
clicking on this ad or these two ads
afterwards based on where they are
browsing
so let's go ahead and look at some
important terms we talk about cue
learning
we have states the state s represents
the current position of an agent in an
environment
the action the action a is the step
taken by the agent when it is particular
state
rewards for every action the agent will
get a positive or negative reward
and again when we talk about states
we're usually not with when you're using
a q table you're not usually talking
about float variables you're talking
about
true false
and we'll take a closer look at that in
a second
and episodes when an agent ends up in a
terminating state and can't take a new
action
this might be if you're playing a video
game your character stepped in and is
now dead or whatever
q values
used to determine how good an action a
taken at a particular state s is q a of
s
and temporal difference a formula used
to find the q value by using the value
of the current state
and action and previous state in action
and various i mean there's bellman's
equation which basically is the equation
that
kind of covers what we just looked at in
all those different terms
the bellman equation is used to
determine the values of a particular
state and deduce how good it is to be in
take that state the optimist the optimal
state will give us the highest optimal
value
factor influencing q values the current
state and action that's your sa so your
current state and your action
then you have your previous date in
action which is your s
i guess prime i'm not sure how how they
reference that s prime a prime so this
is what happened before
uh then you have a reward for action so
you have your r reward
and you have your maximum expected
future reward
and you can see there's also a learning
rate put in there and a discount rate
so we're looking at these just like any
other model we don't want to have an
absolute uh
final value on here we don't want it to
if you do absolute values instead of
taking smaller steps you don't really
have that approach to
the solution you just have a jump
and then pretty soon if you jump one
solution out that's what's going to be
the new solution whichever one jumps up
really high first
kind of ruining the whole idea of doing
a random selection
i'll go into the random selection just a
second
steps in q learning
step one create an initial q table with
all values initialized to zero
again we're looking at
zero one
so are you you know here's our action we
start we're an idol we took a wrong
action we took a correct action and end
and then we have our actions fetching
sitting and running
of course we're just using the dog
example and choose an action and perform
it update values in the table and of
course when we're choosing an action
we're going to kind of do something
random and just randomly pick one so you
start out and you sit and you have then
then depending on that
action you took you can now update the
value for sitting after you start from
start to sitting
get the value of the reward and
calculate the value the value q value
using the bellman equation
and so now we attach a reward to sitting
and we attach all those rewards we
continue the same until the table is
filled with or an episode ends
and
my machine is going to come back to the
random side of this and there's a few
different formulas i use for the random
setup to pick it i usually look whatever
q model i'm using
do their standard one because someone's
usually gone in and done the math
for the optimal
spread
but you can look at this if i have
running has a reward of 10 sitting as a
reward of seven fetching has a reward of
five
um
just kind of without doing like a a
means to you know using the bell curve
for the means value and like i said
there's some math you can put in there
to pick so that you're more like so that
running has even a higher chance
but even if you're just going to do an
average on this
you could do an average a random number
by adding them all together
so you get 10 plus 7 plus 5 is
22 you do 0 to 22
or 0 to 21 but 1 to 22
1 to 5 would be fetching
and so forth you know the last 10. so
you can just look at this as what
percentage are you going to go for that
particular option
and then that gets your random setup in
there and then as you slowly increment
these up
you see that
if your idle where's one here we go
sitting at the end
if you're at the end of wherever you're
at sitting gets a reward of one
um where's the good one on here oh wrong
action running for a wrong action gets
almost no reward so that becomes very
very less likely to happen but it still
might happen it still might have a
percentage of coming up
and that's where the random programming
and q learning comes in the below table
gives us an idea of how many times an
action has been taken and how positively
correct action or negatively wrong
action it is going to affect the next
state
so let's go ahead and dive in and pull
up a little piece of code and see what
this looks like
[Music]
in python
in this demo we'll use q learning to
find the shortest path between two given
points
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
if you've seen my videos before
i like to do it in the
anaconda jupiter notebook
setup just because it's really easy to
see and it's a nice demo uh and so
here's my anaconda this one i'm actually
using a python36 environment that i set
up in here
and we'll go ahead and launch the
jupiter notebook on this
and once we're in our jupiter notebook
which has the kernel loaded with python
3. we'll go ahead and create a new
python 3
folder in here
and we'll call this
q
learning
and to start this
demo let's go ahead and import our numpy
array we'll just run that so it's
imported
and like a lot of these model programs
when you're building them you spend a
lot of time putting it all together
and then you end up with this really
short answer at the end
uh and we'll we'll take a look at that
as we come into it so we we go ahead and
start with our location to state uh so
we have uh l1 l2 these are our nine
locations one to nine and then of course
the state is going to be 0 1 2 3 4. it's
just a mapping of our location to a
integer on there and then we have our
actions our actions are simply
moving from
um one location
to another so i can go to i can go to
location zero and go to location one two
three four five six seven eight uh so
these are my actions i can choose these
are the locations of our state
and if you remember earlier i mentioned
that the limitation is that you you
don't want to put in
a continually growing table because you
can actually create a dynamic queue
table where you continually add in new
values as they arise
because
if you have float values this just
becomes infinite and then you're
remembering your computer is gone or you
know does it's not going to work
at the same time you might think well
that kind of really limits the the q uh
learning setup
but there are ways to use it in
conjunction with other systems
and so you might look at
uh well i do um i've been doing some
work in stock
um and one of the questions that comes
out is to buy or sell the stock
and the stake coming in
might be
you might take a concrete way called
buckets
um where anything that you predict is
going to return more than a certain
amount of money
um the error for that stock that you've
had in the past you put those in buckets
and suddenly you start putting creating
these buckets
you realize you do have a limited amount
of information coming in you no longer
have a float number you now have
bucket one two three and four
and then you can take those buckets
put them through a
q learning table and come up with the
best action which stock should i buy
it's like gambling stock is pretty much
gambling if you're doing day trading
you're not doing long term
um investments and so you can start
looking at it like that a lot of the
current feeds say that the best
algorithms used for day traders redoing
it on your own
is really to ask the question do i want
to trade the stock yes or no and now you
have it in a q learning table and now
you can take it to that next level and
you can see where that can be a really
powerful tool at the end of doing a
basic linear regression model or
something
what is the best investment and you
start getting the best reward on there
and so if we're gonna have rewards these
rewards we just create
um it says uh if basically if you're uh
this should match our cue table because
it's gonna be uh you have your state and
you have your action across the top if
you remember from the dog
and so we have whatever state we're in
going down and then the next action and
what the reward is for it
and of course if you were actually doing
a
something more connected your reward
would be based on the actual environment
it's in
and then we want to go ahead and create
a state to location
so we can map the indexes
so just like we defined our rewards
we're going to go and do state to
location
and you can see here it's a dictionary
set up for location state and location
to state with items
and
we also need to
define what we want for learning rates
uh you remember
we had our two different rates um
as far as like learning from the past
and learning from the current so we'll
go ahead and set those to 0.75 and the
alpha set to 0.9 and we'll see that when
we do the formula
and of course any of this code send a
note to our simply learn team they'll
get you a copy of this code
on here let's go ahead and pull
there we go
on the new next two sections
um
since we're going to keep it
short and sweet
here we go so let's go ahead and create
our agent um so our agent is going to
have our initialization where we send it
all the information uh we'll define
ourself gamma equals gamma we could have
just set the gamma rate down here
instead of uh submitting it
it's kind of nice to keep them separate
because you can play with these numbers
on our self alpha
then we have our location state we'll
set that in here we have our choice of
actions
we're going to go ahead and just embed
the rewards right into the agent so
obviously this would be coming from
somewhere else
instead of from
self-generated and then a self state to
location equals our state to location
dictionary
and we go ahead and create a q learning
table and i went ahead and just set the
q learning table up to um
zero to zero what what what the setup is
location to state how many of them are
there
and this just creates an array of zero
to zero set up on there
and then the big part is the training we
have our rewards new equals a copy of
self.rewards
ending state equals the self-location
state in location so this is whatever we
end up at rewards new equals ending
state plus ending state equals 999 just
kind of goes
to a dead end
and
we start going through iterations
and we'll go ahead um let's do this
uh so this we're going to come back and
we're going to call call it on here
let me just erase that
switch it to an arrow
there we go
so what we're doing is we're going to
send in here to train it we're going to
say hey
i want to iterate through this a
thousand times
and see what happens now this part would
actually be
instead of iterating you might have your
external environment
and they're going back and forth and you
iterate through
outside of here
but just for ease of use our agent is
going to come in here and iterate
through this
sometimes i'll put this iteration in
here
and i'll have it call the environment
and say hey this is what i did what's
the next state and the environment does
this thing right in here as i iterate
through it
and then we want to go ahead and pick a
random state to start with
that's what's going on here you have to
start somewhere
and then you have your playable actions
we're going to start with just an empty
thing for playable actions and we'll
fill that up
so that's what choices i have
and so we're going to iterate through
the rewards matrix to get the states
directly reachable from the randomly
chosen current state assign those states
to a list named playable actions
and so you can see here we have a range
nine i usually use length of whatever
i'm looking at which is our locations
or states as they are
we have a reward
so we want to look at the current the
rewards the new reward
is our
is in our chart here of rewards
underscore new uh current state
plus j uh j being what is the next date
we want to try
and so we go and do our playable actions
and we append j
and so we're doing is we're randomly
trying different things in here to see
what's going to generate a better reward
and then of course we go ahead and
choose our next state
so we have our random choice playable
actions
and if you remember
i mentioned on this let me just go ahead
and let's do a free form
when we were talking about the next
state
this right here just does a random
selection
instead of a random
selection you might do something where
whatever the best selection is
which might be option three
here and then so you can see that it
might use a bell curve and then option
two over here might have a belt curve
like this oops
and we start looking at these averages
and these spreads
or we can just add them all together and
pick the one that kind of goes in all of
those so those are some of the options
we have in here we just go with a random
choice that's usually where you start
play with it
and then we have our
reward section down here
and so we want to go ahead and find well
in this case the temporal difference
so you have your rewards new
plus the self gamma and this is the
formula we were looking at
this is bellman's equation here
so we have our current value our
learning rate our discount rate involved
in there the reward system coming in for
that
and we can add it all together
this is of course our
maximum expected future setup in here
so this is all of our our bellman's
equation that we're looking at here
and then we come up in here and we
update our q table that's all this is on
this one and that's right here we have
self cue current state next date and we
add in our alpha because we don't want
to we don't want to train all of it at
once in case there's slight differences
coming in there we want to slowly
approach the answer
and then we have our route equals the
start location
and next location equals start location
so we're just incrementing we took a
step forward
and then finally
remember i was telling you how we're
going to do all this and just have some
simple thing at the end or just
generates a simple path we're going to
go ahead and get the optimal route we
want to find the best route in here
and so we've created a definition for
the optimal route down here
just scroll down for that
and we get the optimal route we go ahead
and put the information including the q
table self
start location in location next location
route q and it says while next location
is not equal to in location so while we
can still go
our start location equals self location
to state start location so we already
have our best value for the start
location
uh the next state looks at the q table
and says hey what's uh the next one with
the best value and then the next
location we go ahead and pull that in
and we just append it that's what's
going on down here
and then our start location equals the
next location and we just go through all
the steps and we'll go ahead and run
this
and now that we have our q table our
q agent loaded
we're going to go ahead and take our q
agent
load them up with their alpha gamma that
we set up above
along with the location step action
reward state to location
and
our goal is to plot a course between l9
and l1
and we're gonna go through a hundred a
thousand iterations on here
and so when i run that it runs pretty
quick
uh why is this so fast um
if you've been running neural networks
and you've been doing all these other
models you sit here and wait a long time
well we're very small amount of data
these are all integers these aren't
float values there's not a the math is
not heavy on the on the processing end
and this is where q tables are so
powerful if you have a small amount of
information coming in you very quickly
uh get an answer off of this even though
we went through it a thousand times to
train it and you'll see here we have l
nine eight five two and one and that's
based on our reward table we had set up
on there and this is the shortest path
going between these different uh setups
in here
and if you remember on our reward table
you can see that if you start here you
can go to here there's places you can't
go that's how this reward table was set
up so i can only go to certain places
uh so kind of a little maze set up in
there and you can play with it this is
really fun uh set up to play with
and you can see how you can take this
whole code and you can like i was saying
earlier you can embed it into another
setup and model and predictions where
you put things into buckets and you're
trying to guess the best investment the
best course of action
long as you can take that course into
action and
reduce it down to a yes no
or if you're using text
you can use a one hot encoder which word
is next there's all kinds of things you
can do with a cue table
depending on just how much information
you're putting in there
so that wraps up our demo in this demo
we've found the shortest distance
between two paths based on whatever
rules or state rewards we have to get
from point a to point b and what
available actions there are and of
course the bottom line is um where's the
money you know it's if we're going to
train depending on where you're at in
your career a resume of machine learning
engineer is important to understand and
they've changed so much i remember my
first we won't talk about how long ago
my first paper machine learning was my
first resume i put out for work and job
and applications resumes have changed so
much and when we talk about
something like a machine learning
engineer they're going in leaps and
bounds and let's just go ahead and pop
open a quick template here and just show
you some ideas of what we're looking at
so and i've opened this up into a simple
pdf reader adobe acrobat reader one of
the first things is that and this always
catches me off guard as we're starting
to see where we want to see the person
and you can actually put your photo on
the resume it stands out they're going
to remember you you know wear a tie a
suit and tie look nice be a professional
on this one but that's a big thing now
it catches people eyes and we i've seen
that forever say in the real estate
industry they hand you their business
card and it has their photo on it even
back in the 90s they didn't care long as
they had that visual uh so we want a
name a face an email id contact number
but we really want that name in bold and
we really want to see who you are this
is such a shift from the way it used to
be it used to be that you did not want
your personal stuff on your resume now
you do and of course the summary is very
important you can see right here and
again there's different options on this
so this format isn't necessarily the
only format you need to use but this is
a really good place to start as you can
see here we're actually using almost a
third of the page to put your name put
your summary and this next part is
another one another huge one your
linkedin profile if you have it
they start looking at that and you have
all you post all of your stuff on there
nowadays they ask you hey what's your
history what's your employment history
and they can go down with your
certifications suddenly this linkedin
has all this massive amount information
that they can go pull and find out more
about you without having to go through
the resume so the resume is almost
secondary at some point and another
really important shift we see is where's
your github link or someplace maybe you
have a personal website
someplace you can show your skills in
coding your skills and what you do so
they no longer want to just have a
resume that says yeah i'm good they want
to actually see what you're capable of
this is a huge shift in resumes today
and with that i'm going to give a quick
warning
as a as i come in there and i look up
people and they say hey do i want this
person to work for me i'm going to do a
search on them they're going to do a
search on your name when you're looking
for a job so remember your facebook and
all your personalized stuff if it is
public make sure it's professional you
know you don't want to have somebody go
in there and decide they don't like you
because your favorite rock band is
imagine dragons or and also keep in mind
that sometimes those facebook posts show
up on somebody else's feed so even
though you think you're private remember
any of that stuff could end up public
and your employer might be looking at
that in some jobs you might want to
highlight that if your specialty is
marketing and you're using facebook and
marketing put that in here uh so again
it gives them another link of what you
do and what you're doing on your resume
we come down to experience this can go
in different areas a lot of times if you
have been in the programming industry
for years
you know i have over two decades as a
programmer this is almost a secondary
page sometimes where i just have all the
companies listed that i've worked for
with the blurb about what i did for them
again a lot of people just go to
linkedin and they already see that
information so they're going to skip
right over it so you might even bump it
down to the bottom and then your
education and skills in a lot of cases
you might take your skills and bump them
to the top um highlight yourself and
then have your education certifications
again it depends on your history and
what your strength is if you have very
specific skills you're highlighting you
might want to bump this to the top so
the company is aware of it but again we
have a very basic blurb experience
education skills certifications this
goes with education sometimes arrange
that that's going to highlight you and
show you off the best so if you're
really big on certifications you might
put those next and just have two columns
of all the certifications you've gone
through and where they came from and
then maybe your education maybe you have
oh an associate's degree so you might
have 20 different certifications and a
two-year associate's degree so the
education might go underneath your
certifications and so on again organize
this to highlight you and your strengths
and also to target the company you're
looking for in a resume i just love the
switch over here on the top and there's
even another suggestion you could even
do a personalized video again now they
have a this is a sales and marketing
thing we're starting to talk about where
we have a physical page they're looking
at hopefully you've talked to them on
the telephone so they have their voice
in the air and a video would be a third
input so the more the different inputs
they have fourth being the website maybe
a personal website would be fifth if you
have a facebook that's somewhat you know
professional on there and addressing and
addressing what you're going after put
that stuff in here the more input
somebody gets the more rounded they see
you and the more they might want to
employ you as a human being instead of
just another page on their stack of
people to go through hello everyone
welcome to this session i'm mohan from
simply learn and today we'll talk about
interview questions for
machine learning now this video will
probably help you when you're attending
interviews for machine learning
positions and the attempt here is to
probably consolidate 30 most commonly
asked questions and to help you in
answering these questions we tried our
best to give you the best possible
answers but of course what is more
important here is rather than the
theoretical knowledge you need to kind
of add to the answers or supplement your
answers with your own experience so the
responses that we put here are a bit
more generic in nature so that if there
are some concepts that you are not clear
this video will help you in kind of
getting those concepts cleared up as
well but what is more important is that
you need to supplement these responses
with your own practical experience okay
so with that let's get started so one of
the first questions that you may face is
what are the different types of machine
learning now what is the best way to
respond to this there are three types of
machine learning if you read any
material you will always be told there
are three types of machine learning but
what is important is you would probably
be better off emphasizing that there are
actually two main types of machine
learning which is supervised and
unsupervised and then there is a third
type which is reinforcement learn so
supervised learning is where
you have some historical data and then
you feed that data to your model to
learn now you need to be aware of a
keyword that they will be looking for
which is labeled data right so if you
just say past data or historical data
the impact may not be so much you need
to emphasize on labeled data so what is
label data basically let's say if you
are trying to do train your model for
classification you need to be aware of
for your existing data which class each
of the observations belong to right so
that is what is labeling so it is
nothing but a fancy name you must be
already aware but just make it a point
to throw in that keyword labeled so that
will have the right impact okay so that
is what is supervised learning when you
have existing labeled data which you
then use to train your model that is
known as supervised learning and
unsupervised learning is when you don't
have this labeled data so you have data
it is not labeled so the system has to
figure out a way to do some analysis on
this okay so that is unsupervised
learning and you can then add a few
things like what are the ways of
performing uh supervised learning and
unsupervised learning and what are some
of the techniques so supervised learning
we perform or we do
regression and classification and
unsupervised learning uh we do
clustering and clustering can be of
different types similarly regression can
be of different types but you don't have
to probably elaborate so much if they
are asking
for uh just the different types you can
just mention these and just at a very
high level but if they want you to
elaborate give examples then of course i
think there is a different question for
that we will see that later then the
third so we have supervised then we have
unsupervised and then reinforcement you
need to provide a little bit of
information around that as well because
it is sometimes a little difficult to
come up with a good definition for
reinforcement learning so you may have
to little bit elaborate on how
reinforcement learning works right so
reinforcement learning works in in such
a way that it basically has two parts to
it one is the agent and the environment
and the agent basically is working
inside of this environment and it is
given a target that it has to achieve
and
every time it is moving in the direction
of the target so the agent basically has
to take some action and every time it
takes an action which is moving
the agent towards the target right
towards a goal a target is nothing but a
goal
then it is rewarded and every time it is
going in a direction where it is away
from the goal then it is punished so
that is the way you can little bit
explain and
this is used primarily or very very
impactful for teaching the system to
learn games and so on examples of this
are basically used in alphago you can
throw that as an example where alphago
used reinforcement learning to actually
learn to play the game of go and finally
it defeated the co world champion all
right this much of information that
would be good enough okay then there
could be a question on overfitting
so the question could be what is
overfitting and how can you avoid it so
what is overfitting so let's first try
to understand the concept because
sometimes overfitting may be a little
difficult to understand overfitting is a
situation where the model has kind of
memorized the data so this is an
equivalent of memorizing the data so we
can draw an analogy so that it becomes
easy to explain this now let's say
you're teaching a child about
recognizing some fruits or something
like that okay and you're teaching this
child about recognizing let's say three
fruits apples oranges and pineapples
okay so this is a small child and for
the first time you're teaching the child
to recognize fruits then so what will
happen so this is very much like that is
your training data set so what you will
do is you will take a basket of fruits
which consists of apples oranges and
pineapples okay and you take this basket
to this child and
there may be let's say hundreds of these
fruits so you take this basket to this
child and keep showing each of this food
and then first time obviously the child
will not know what it is so you show an
apple and you say hey this is apple then
you show maybe an orange and say this is
orange and so on and so forth and then
again you keep repeating that right so
till that basket is over this is
basically how training work in machine
learning also that's how training works
so till the basket is completed maybe
100 fruits you keep showing this child
then the process what has happened the
child has pretty much memorized these so
even before you finish that basket right
by the time you are halfway through the
child has learnt about recognizing the
apple orange and pineapple now what will
happen after halfway through initially
you remember it made mistakes in
recognizing but halfway through now it
has learned so every time you show a
fruit it will exactly 100 accurately it
will identify it will say the child will
say this is an apple this is an orange
and if you show a pineapple it will say
this is a pineapple right so that means
it has kind of memorized this data now
let's say you bring another basket of
fruits and it will have a mix of maybe
apples which were already there in the
previous set but it will also have in
addition to apple it will probably have
a banana or maybe another fruit like a
jackfruit right so this is an equivalent
of your test data set which the child
has not seen before some parts of it it
probably has seen like the apples it has
seen but this banana and jackfruit it
has not seen so then what will happen in
the first round which is an equivalent
of your training data set towards the
end it has 100 percent it was telling
you what the fruits are right apple was
accurately recognized orange was
accurately recognized and pineapples
were accurately recognized right so that
is like 100 accuracy but now when you
get another a fresh set which we're not
of the original one what will happen all
the apples maybe it will be able to
recognize correctly but all the others
like the jackfruit or the banana will
not be recognized by the child right so
this is an analogy this is an equivalent
of overfitting so what has happened
during the training process it is able
to recognize or reach 100 accuracy maybe
very high accuracy okay and we call that
as very low loss right so that is the
technical term so the loss is pretty
much zero and accuracy is pretty much
whereas when you use testing there will
be a huge error which means the loss
will be pretty high and therefore the
accuracy will be also low okay this is
known as overfitting this is basically a
process where training is done training
processes it goes very well almost
reaching 100 accuracy but while testing
it really drops down now how can you
avoid it so that is the extension of
this question there are multiple ways of
avoiding overfitting there are
techniques like what you call
regularization that is the most common
technique that is used for
avoiding overfitting and within
regularization there can be a few other
sub types like drop out in case of
neural networks and a few other examples
but i think if you give example or if
you give regularization as the technique
probably that should be sufficient so so
there will be some questions where the
interviewer will try to test your
fundamentals and your knowledge and
depth of knowledge and so on and so
forth and then there will be some
questions which are more like trick
questions that will be more to stump you
okay then the next question is around
the methodology so when we are
performing machine learning training we
split the data into training and test
right so this question is around that so
the question is what is training set and
test set in machine learning model and
how is the split done so the question
can be like that so in machine learning
when we are trying to train the model so
we have a three-step process we train
the model and then we test the model and
then once we are satisfied with the test
only then we deploy the model so what
happens in the train and test is that
you remember
the labeled data so let's say you have
1000 records with labeling information
now one way of doing it is you use all
the thousand records for training and
then maybe right which means that you
have exposed all these thousand records
during the training process and then you
take a small set of the same data and
then you say okay i will test it with
this okay and then you probably what
will happen you may get some good
results all right but there is a flaw
there what is the flaw this is very
similar to human beings it is like you
are showing this model the entire data
as a part of training okay so obviously
it has become familiar with the entire
data so when you are taking a part of
that again and you are saying that i
want to test it obviously you will get
good results so that is not a very
accurate way of testing so that is the
reason what we do is we have the label
data of this thousand records or
whatever we set aside before starting
the training process we set aside a
portion of that data and we call that
test set and the remaining we call as
training set and we use only this for
training our model now the training
process remember is not just about
passing one round of this data set so
let's say now your training set has 800
records it is not just one time you pass
this 800 records what you normally do is
you actually as a part of the training
you may pass this data through the model
multiple times so this thousand records
may go through the model maybe 10 15 20
times till the training is perfect till
the accuracy is high till the errors are
minimized okay now so which is fine
which means that your that is what is
known as the model has seen your data
and gets familiar with your data and now
when you bring your test data what will
happen is this is like some new data
because that is where the real test is
now you have trained the model and now
you are testing the model with some data
which is kind of new that is like a
situation like like a realistic
situation because when the model is
deployed that is what will happen it
will receive some new data not the data
that it has already seen right so this
is a realistic test so you put some new
data so this data which you have set
aside is for the model it is new and if
it is able to accurately predict the
values that means your training has
worked okay the model got trained
properly but let's say while you're
testing this with this test data you're
getting lot of errors that means you
need to probably either change your
model or retrain with more data and
things like that now coming back to the
question of how do you split this what
should be the ratio there is no fixed uh
number again this is like individual
preferences some people split it into 50
50 50 test and 50 training some people
prefer to have a larger amount for
training and a smaller amount for test
so they can go by either 60 40 or 70 30
or some people even go with some odd
numbers like 65 35 or
63.33 and 33 which is like one third and
two thirds so there is no fixed rule
that it has to be something that the
ratio has to be this you can go by your
individual preferences all right then
you may have questions around data
handling data manipulation or what you
call data management or preparation so
these are all some questions around that
area there is again no one answer one
single good answer to this it really
varies from situation to situation and
depending on what exactly is the problem
what kind of data it is how critical it
is what kind of data is missing and what
is the type of corruption so there are a
whole lot of things this is a very
generic question and therefore you need
to be little careful about responding to
this as well so probably have to
illustrate this again if you have
experience in doing this kind of work in
handling data you can illustrate with
example saying that i was on one project
where i received this kind of data these
were the columns where data was not
filled or these were the this many rows
where the data was missing that would be
in fact a perfect way to respond to this
question but if you don't have that
obviously you have to provide some good
answer i think it really depends on what
exactly the situation is and there are
multiple ways of handling the missing
data or corrupt data now let's take a
few examples now let's say you have data
where some values in some of the columns
are missing and you have pretty much
half of your data having these missing
values in terms of number of rows okay
that could be one situation another
situation could be that you have records
or data missing but
when you do some initial calculation how
many records are correct or how many
rows or observations as we call it has
this missing data let's assume it is
very minimal like 10
okay now
between these two cases how do we so
let's assume that this is not a mission
critical situation and in order to fix
this ten percent of the data the effort
that is required is much higher and
obviously effort means also time and
money right so
it is not so mission critical and it is
okay to let's say get rid of these
records so obviously one of the easiest
ways of handling the data part or
missing data is remove those records or
remove those observations from your
analysis so that is the easiest way to
do but then the downside is as i said in
as in the first case if let's say 50
percent of your data is like that
because some column or the other way is
missing so it is not like every in every
place in every row the same column is
missing but you have in maybe 10 percent
of the records column 1 is missing and
another 10 percent column two is missing
another ten percent column three is
missing and so on and so forth so it
adds up to maybe half of your data set
so you cannot completely remove half of
your data set then the whole purpose is
lost okay so then how do you handle then
you need to come up with ways of filling
up this data with some meaningful value
right that is one way of handling so
when we say meaningful value what is
that meaningful let's say for a
particular column you might want to take
a mean value for that column and fill
wherever the data is missing fill up
with that mean value so that when you're
doing the calculations your analysis is
not completely way off so you have
values which are not missing first of
all so your system will work number two
these values are not so completely out
of whack that your whole analysis goes
for a task right there may be situations
where if the missing values instead of
putting mean may be a good idea to fill
it up with the minimum value or with a
zero so or with the maximum value again
as i said there are so many
possibilities so there is no like one
correct answer for this you need to
basically talk around this and
illustrate with your experience as i
said that would be the best otherwise
this is how you need to handle this
question okay so
then the next question can be how can
you choose a classifier based on a
training set data size so again this is
one of those questions
where you probably do not have like a
one size fits all
first of all
you may not let's say
decide your classifier based on the
training set size maybe not the best way
to decide the type of the classifier and
even if you have to there are probably
some thumb rules which we can use but
then again every time so in my opinion
the best way to respond to this question
is you need to try out few classifiers
irrespective of the size of the data and
you need to then decide on your
particular situation which of these
classifiers are the right ones this is a
very generic issue so
you will never be able to just by if
somebody defines a problem to you and
somebody even if they show the data to
you or tell you what is the data or even
the size of the data i don't think there
is a way to really say that yes this is
the classifier that will work here no
that's not the right way so you need to
still
you know test it out get the data try
out a couple of classifiers and then
only you will be in a position to decide
which classifier to use you try out
multiple classifiers see which one gives
the best accuracy and only then you can
decide then you can have a question
around confusion matrix so the question
can be explained confusion matrix right
so confusion matrix i think the best way
to explain it is by taking an example
and drawing like a small diagram
otherwise it can really become tricky so
my suggestion is to take a piece of pen
and paper and
explain it by drawing a small matrix and
confusion matrix is about to find out
this is you especially in classification
uh learning process and when you get the
results and our model predicts the
results you compare it with the actual
value and try to find out what is the
accuracy okay so
in this case let's say this is an
example of a confusion matrix and
it is a binary matrix so you have the
actual values which is the labeled data
right and which is so you have how many
yes and how many know so you have that
information and you have the predicted
values how many yes and how many know
right so the total actual values the
total yes is 12 plus 130 and they are
shown here and the actual value those
are 9 plus 3 12 okay so that is what
this information here is so this is
about the actual and this is about the
predicted similarly the predicted values
there are yes are 12 plus 3 15 yeses and
no are one plus nine ten knows okay so
this is the way to look at this
confusion matrix okay and uh out of this
what is the meaning conveying so there
are two or three things that needs to be
explained outright the first thing is
for a model to be accurate the values
across the diagonal should be high like
in this case right that is one number
two the total sum of these values is
equal to the total observations in the
test data set so in this case for
example you have 12 plus 3 15 plus 10 25
so that means we have 25 observations in
our test data set okay so these are the
two things you need to first explain
that the total sum in this matrix the
numbers is equal to the size of the test
data set and the diagonal values
indicate the accuracy so by just by
looking at it you can probably have a
idea about is this uh an accurate model
is the model being accurate if they're
all spread out equally in all these four
boxes that means probably the accuracy
is not very good okay now how do you
calculate the accuracy itself right how
do you calculate the accuracy itself so
it is a very simple mathematical
calculation you take some of the
diagonals right so in this case it is 9
plus 12 21 and divide it by the total so
in this case what will it be let me take
a pen so your your diagonal values is
equal to if i say d is equal to 12 plus
9 so that is 21 right and the total data
set is equal to right we just calculated
it is 25 so what is your accuracy it is
21 by your accuracy is equal to 21 by 25
and this turns out to be about 85
percent right so this is 85
so that is our accuracy okay so this is
the way you need to explain draw diagram
give an example maybe it may be a good
idea to be prepared with an example so
that it becomes easy for you don't have
to calculate those numbers on the fly
right so a couple of uh hints are that
you take some numbers which are with
which add up to 100 that is always a
good idea so you don't have to really do
this complex calculations so the total
value will be 100 and then diagonal
values you divide once you find the
diagonal values that is equal to your
percentage okay all right so the next
question can be a related question about
false positive and false negative so
what is false positive and what is false
negative now once again the best way to
explain this is using a piece of paper
and pen otherwise it will be pretty
difficult to explain this so we use the
same example of the confusion matrix
and
we can explain that so a confusion
matrix looks somewhat like this and
when we just
yeah it looks somewhat like this and we
continue with the previous example where
this is the actual value this is the
predicted value and
in the actual value we have 12 plus 1 13
yeses and 3 plus 9 12 nos and the
predicted values there are 12 plus 3 15
yeses and
1 plus 9 10 nos okay now this particular
case which is the false positive what is
a false positive first of all the second
word which is positive okay is referring
to the predicted value so that means the
system has predicted it as a positive
but the real value so this is what the
false comes from but the real value is
not positive okay that is the way you
should understand this term false
positive or even false negative so false
positive so positive is what your system
has predicted so where is that system
predicted this is the one positive is
what yes so you basically consider this
row okay now if you consider this row so
this is this is all positive values this
entire row is positive values okay now
the false positive is the one which
where the value actual value is negative
predicted value is positive but the
actual value is negative so this is a
false positive right and here is a true
positive so the predicted value is
positive and the actual value is also
positive okay i hope this is making
sense now let's take a look at what is
false negative false negative so
negative is the second term that means
that is the predicted value that we need
to look for so which are the predicted
negative values this row corresponds to
predicted negative values all right so
this row corresponds to predicted
negative values and what they are asking
for false so this is the row for
predicted negative values and the actual
value is this one right this is
predicted negative and the actual value
is also negative therefore this is a
true negative so the false negative is
this one predicted is negative but
actual is positive right so this is the
false negative so this is the way to
explain and this is a way to look at
false positive and false negative same
way there can be true positive and true
negative as well so again positive the
second term you will need to use to
identify the predicted row right so if
we say true positive positive we need to
take for the predicted part so predicted
positive is here okay and then the first
term is for the actual so true positive
so true in case of actual is yes right
so true positive is this one okay and
then in case of actual the negative now
we are talking about let's say true
negative true negative negative is this
one and the true comes from here so this
is true negative right nine is true
negative the actual value is also
negative and the predicted value is also
negative okay so that is the way you
need to explain this the terms false
positive false negative and true
positive true negative then uh you might
have a question like what are the
steps involved in the machine learning
process or what are the three steps in
the process of developing a machine
learning model right so it is around the
methodology that is applied so basically
the way you can probably answer in your
own words but the way the model
development of the machine learning
model happens is like this so first of
all you try to understand the problem
and try to figure out whether it is a
classification problem or a regression
problem based on that you select a few
algorithms and then you start the
process of training these models okay so
you can either do that or you can after
due diligence you can probably decide
that there is one particular algorithm
which is most suitable usually it
happens through trial and error process
but at some point you will decide that
okay this is the model we are going to
use okay so in that case we have the
model algorithm and the model decided
and then you need to do the process of
training the model and testing the model
and this is where if it is supervised
learning you split your data the label
data into training data set and test
data set and you use the training data
set to train your model and then you use
the test data set to check the accuracy
whether it is working fine or not so you
test the model before you actually put
it into production right so once you
test the model you're satisfied it's
working fine then you go to the next
level which is putting it for production
and then in production obviously new
data will come and
the inference happens so the model is
readily available and only thing that
happens is new data comes and the model
predicts the values whether it is
regression or classification now so this
can be an iterative process so it is not
a straightforward process where you do
the training through the testing and
then you move it to production now so
during the training and test process
there may be a situation where because
of either overfitting or things like
that the test doesn't go through which
means that you need to put that back
into the training process so that can be
an iterative process not only that even
if the training and test goes through
properly and you deploy the model in
production there can be a situation that
the data that actually comes the real
data that comes with that this model is
failing so in which case you may have to
once again go back to the drawing board
or initially it will be working fine but
over a period of time maybe due to the
change in the nature of the data once
again the accuracy will deteriorate so
that is again a recursive process so
once in a while you need to keep
checking whether the model is working
fine or not and if required you need to
tweak it and modify it and so on and so
forth so net net this is a continuous
process of
tweaking the model and testing it and
making sure it is up to date then you
might have question around deep learning
so because deep learning is now
associated with ai artificial
intelligence and so on so can be as
simple as what is deep learning so i
think the best way to respond to this
could be deep learning is a part of
machine learning and
then obviously the question would be
then what is the difference right so
deep learning you need to mention there
are two key parts that interviewer will
be looking for when you are defining
deep learning so first is of course deep
learning is a subset of machine learning
so machine learning is still the bigger
let's say uh scope and deep learning is
one part of it so then what exactly is
the difference deep learning is
primarily when we are implementing these
our algorithms or when we are using
neural networks for doing our training
and classification and regression and
all that right so when we use neural
network then it is considered as deep
learning and the term deep comes from
the fact that you can have several
layers of neural networks and these are
called deep neural networks and
therefore the term deep
deep learning the other difference
between machine learning and deep
learning which the interviewer may be
wanting to hear is that in case of
machine learning the feature engineering
is done manually what do we mean by
feature engineering basically when we
are trying to train our model we have
our training data right so we have our
training label data and
this data has several let's say if it is
a regular table it has several columns
now each of these columns actually has
information about a feature right so if
we are trying to predict the height
weight and so on and so forth so these
are all features of human beings let's
say we have census data and we have all
this so those are the features now there
may be probably 50 or 100 in some cases
there may be 100 such features now all
of them do not contribute to our model
right so we as a data scientist we have
to decide whether we should take all of
them all the features or we should throw
away some of them because again if we
take all of them number one of course
your accuracy will probably get affected
but also there is a computational part
so if you have so many features and then
you have so much data it becomes very
tricky so in case of machine learning we
manually take care of identifying the
features that do not contribute to the
learning process and thereby we
eliminate those features and so on right
so this is known as feature engineering
and in machine learning we do that
manually whereas in deep learning where
we use neural networks the model will
automatically determine which features
to use and which to not use and
therefore feature engineering is also
done automatically so this is a
explanation these are two key things
probably
will add value to your response all
right so the next question is what is
the difference between or what are the
differences between machine learning and
deep learning so here this is a quick
comparison table between machine
learning and deep learning and in
machine learning learning enables
machines to take decisions on their own
based on past data so here we are
talking primarily of supervised learning
and it needs only a small amount of data
for training and then works well on
low-end systems so you don't need large
machines and most features need to be
identified in advance and manually coded
so basically the feature engineering
part is done manually and the problem is
divided into parts and solved
individually and then combined so that
is about the machine learning part in
deep learning deep learning basically
enables machines to take decisions with
the help of artificial neural network so
here in deep learning we use neural
lines so that is the key differentiator
between machine learning and deep
learning and usually deep learning
involves a large amount of data and
therefore the training also requires
usually the training process requires
high-end machines because it needs a lot
of computing power and the machine
learning features are the or the feature
engineering is done automatically so the
neural networks takes care of doing the
feature engineering as well and in case
of deep learning therefore it is said
that the problem is handled end-to-end
so this is a quick comparison between
machine learning and deep learning in
case you have that kind of a question
then you might get a question around the
uses of machine learning or some real
life applications of machine learning in
modern business the question may be
worded in different ways but the meaning
is how exactly is machine learning used
or actually supervised machine learning
it could be a very specific question
around supervised decision learning so
this is like give examples of supervised
machine learning use of supervised
machine learning in modern business so
that could be the next question so there
are quite a few examples or quite a few
use cases if you will for supervised
machine learning the very common one is
email spam detection so you want to
train your application or your system to
detect between spam and non-spam so this
is a very common business application of
supervised machine learning so how does
this work the way it works is that you
obviously have historical data above
your emails and they are categorized as
spam and not spam so that is what is the
labeled information and then you feed
this information or the all these emails
as an input to your model right and the
model will then get trained to detect
which of the emails are to detect which
is spam and which is not spam so that is
the training process and this is
supervised machine learning because you
have label data you already have emails
which are tagged as spam or not spam and
then you use that to train your model
right so this is one example now there
are a few industry specific applications
for supervised machine learning one of
the very common ones is in healthcare
diagnostics in healthcare diagnostics
you have these images and you want to
train models to detect whether from a
particular image whether it can find out
if the person is sick or not whether a
person has cancer or not right so this
is a very good example of supervised
machine learning here the way it works
is that existing images it could be
x-ray images it'd be mri or any of these
images are available and they are tagged
saying that okay this x-ray image is
defective or the person has an illness
or it could be cancer whichever illness
right so it is tagged as defective or
clear or good image and defective
something like that so we come up with a
binary or it could be multi-class as
well saying that this is defective to 10
percent this is 25 and so on but let's
keep it simple you can give an example
of just a binary classification that
would be good enough so
you can say that in healthcare
diagnostics using image we need to
detect whether a person is ill or
whether a person is having cancer or not
so here the way it works is you feed
labeled images and you allow the model
to learn from that so that when new
image is fed it will be able to predict
whether this person is having that
illness or not having cancer or not
right so i think this would be a very
good example for supervised machine
learning in modern business all right
then we can have a question like so
we've been talking about supervised and
unsupervised and so there can be a
question around semi-supervised machine
learning so what is semi-supervised
machine learning now semi-supervised
learning as the name suggests it falls
between supervised learning and
unsupervised learning but for all
practical purposes it is considered as a
part of supervised learning and the
reason this has come into existence is
that in supervised learning you need
labeled data so all your data for
training your model has to be labeled
now this is a big problem in many
industries or in many under many
situations getting the label data is not
that easy because there's a lot of
effort in labeling this data let's take
an example of the diagnostic images we
can just let's say take x-ray images now
there are actually millions of x-ray
images available all over the world but
the problem is they are not labeled so
their images are there but whether it is
effective or whether it is good that
information is not available along with
it right in a form that it can be used
by a machine which means that somebody
has to take a look at these images and
usually it should be like a doctor and
then say that okay yes this image is
clean and this image is cancerous and so
on and so forth now that is a huge
effort by itself so this is where semi
learning comes into play so what happens
is there is a large amount of data maybe
a part of it is labeled then we try some
techniques to label the remaining part
of the data so that we get completely
labeled data and then we train our model
so i know this is a little long winding
explanation but unfortunately there is
no
quick and easy definition for semi
supervised machine learning this is the
only way probably to explain this
concept
we may have another question as
what are unsupervised machine learning
techniques or what are some of the
techniques used for performing
unsupervised machine learning so it can
be worded in different ways so how do we
answer this question so unsupervised
learning you can say that there are two
types clustering and association and
clustering is a technique where similar
objects are put together and there are
different ways of finding similar
objects so their characteristics can be
measured and if they have in most of the
characteristics if they are similar then
they can be put together this is
clustering then association you can i
think the best way to explain
association is with an example in case
of association you try to find out how
the items are linked to each other so
for example if somebody bought
maybe a laptop the person has also
purchased a mouse so this is more in an
e-commerce scenario for example so you
can give this as an example so people
who are buying laptops are also buying a
mouse so that means there is an
association between laptops and mouse or
maybe people who are buying bread are
also buying butter so that is the
association that can be created so this
is unsupervised learning one of the
techniques okay all right then we have
very fundamental question what is the
difference between supervised and
unsupervised machine learning so
machine learning these are the two main
types of machine learning supervised and
unsized and in case of supervised and
again here probably the key word that
the person may be wanting to hear is
labeled data very often people say we
have historical data and if we run it it
is supervised and if we don't have
historical data yes but you may have
historical data but if it is not labeled
then you cannot use it for supervised
learning so it is it's very key to
understand that we put in that keyword
label okay so when we have labeled data
for training our model then we can use
supervised learning and if we do not
have label data then we use unsupervised
learning and there are different
algorithms available to perform both of
these types of trainings so there can be
another question a little bit more
theoretical and conceptual in nature
this is about inductive machine learning
and deductive machine learning so the
question can be what is the difference
between inductive machine learning and
deductive machine learning or
somewhat in that manner so that the
exact phrase or exact question can vary
they can ask for examples and things
like that but that could be the question
so let's first understand what is
inductive and deductive training
inductive training is induced by
somebody and you can illustrate that
with a small example i think that always
helps so whenever you're doing some
explanation try as much as possible as i
said to give examples from your work
experience or give some analogies and
that will also help a lot in explaining
as well and for the interviewer also to
understand so here we'll take an example
or rather we will use an analogy so
inductive training is when we induce
some knowledge or the learning process
into a person without the person
actually experiencing it okay what can
be an example so we can probably tell
the person or show a person a video that
fire can burn the thing burn his finger
or fire can cause damage so what is
happening here this person has never
probably seen a fire or never seen
anything getting damaged by fire but
just because he has seen this video he
knows that okay fire is dangerous and if
a fire can cause damage right so this is
inductive learning compared to that what
is deductive learning so here you draw a
conclusion or the person draws
conclusion out of experience so we will
stick to the analogy so compared to the
showing a video let's assume a person is
allowed to play with fire right and then
he figures out that if he puts his
finger it's burning or if throw
something into the fire it burns so he
is learning through experience so this
is known as deductive learning okay so
you can have applications or models that
can be trained using inductive learning
or deductive learning all right i think
probably that explanation will be
sufficient
the next question is are knn and k means
clustering
for k nearest neighbors and k means of
course is the clustering mechanism now
these two are completely different
except for the letter k being common
between them knn is completely different
k means clustering is completely
different k nnn is a classification
process and
therefore it comes under supervised
learning whereas k means clustering is
actually unsupervised okay when you have
k and n when you want to implement k n
which is basically k nearest neighbors
the value of k is a number so you can
say k is equal to 3 you want to
implement k and n with k is equal to 3
so which means that it performs the
classification in such a way that how
does it perform the classification so it
will take three nearest objects and
that's why it's called nearest neighbor
so basically based on the distance it
will try to find out its nearest objects
that are let's say three of the nearest
objects and then it will check whether
the class they belong to which class
right so if all three belong to one
particular class obviously this new
object is also classified as that
particular class but it is possible that
they may be from two or three different
classes okay so let's say they are from
two classes and then if they are from
two classes now usually you take a odd
number you assign an odd number to so if
there are three of them and two of them
belong to one class and then one belongs
to another class so this new object is
assigned to the class to which the two
of them belong now the value of k is
sometimes tricky whether should you use
three should you use five should you use
seven that can be tricky because the
ultimate classification can also vary so
it's possible that if you're taking k as
three the object is probably in one
particular class but if you take uh k is
equal to five maybe the object will
belong to a different class because when
you are taking three of them probably
two of them belong to a class one and
one belong to class two whereas when you
take five of them it is possible that
only two of them belong to class 1 and 3
of them belong to class 2 so which means
that this object will belong to class 2
right so you see that so it is the class
allocation can vary depending on the
value of k now k means on the other hand
is a clustering process and it is
unsupervised where what it does is the
system will basically identify how the
objects are how close the objects are
with respect to some of their features
okay and but similarity of course is the
the letter k and in case of k means also
we specify its value and it could be
three or five or seven there is no
technical limit as such but it can be
any number of clusters that you can
create okay so based on the value that
you provide the system will create that
many clusters of similar objects so
there is a similarity to that extent
that k is a number in both the cases but
actually these two are completely
different processes
we have what is known as naive bayes
classifier and people often get confused
thinking that naive bayes is the name of
the person who found this classifier or
who developed this classifier which is
not 100 true base is the name of the
person bays is the name of the person
but naive is not the name of the person
right so naive is basically an english
word and that has been added here
because of the nature of this particular
classifier naive bayes classifier is a
probability based classifier and
it makes some assumptions that
presence of one feature of a class is
not related to the presence of any other
feature of maybe other classes right so
which is not a very strong or not a very
what do you say accurate assumption
because these features can be related
and so on but even if we go with this
assumption this whole algorithm works
very well even with this assumption and
that is the good side of it but the term
comes from that so that is the
explanation that you can
then there can be question around
reinforcement learning it can be
paraphrased in multiple ways one could
be can you explain how a system can play
a game of chess using reinforcement
learning or it can be any game so the
best way to explain this is again to
talk a little bit about what
reinforcement learning is about and then
elaborate on that to explain the process
so first of all reinforcement learning
has an environment and an agent and the
agent is basically performing some
actions in order to achieve a certain
goal and this goals can be anything
either if it is related to game then the
goal could be that you have to score
very high score high value high number
or it could be that your
number of lives should be as high as
possible don't lose life so this could
be some of them more advanced examples
could be for driving the automotive
industry self-driving cars they actually
also make use of reinforcement learning
to teach the car how to navigate through
the roads and so on and so forth that is
also another example now how does it
work so if the system is basically there
is an agent and environment and every
time the agent takes a step or performs
a task which is taking it towards the
goal the final goal let's say to
maximize the score or to minimize the
number of lives and so on or minimize
the deaths for example it is rewarded
and every time it takes a step which
goes against that code right contrary or
the reverse direction it is penalized
okay so it is like a carrot and a stick
system now how do you use this to create
a game of chess or to create a system to
play a game of chess now the way this
works is and this could probably go back
to this alphago example where alphago
defeated a human champion so the way it
works is in reinforcement learning the
system is allowed for example in this
case we are talking about chess so we
allow the system to first of all watch
playing a game of chess so it could be
with a human being or it could be the
system itself there are computer games
of chess right so
either this new learning system has to
watch that game or watch a human being
play the game because this is
reinforcement learning is pretty much
all visual so when you're teaching the
system to play a game the system will
not actually go behind the scenes to
understand the logic of your software of
this game or anything like that it is
just visually watching the screen and
then it learns okay so reinforcement
learning to a large extent it works on
that so you need to create a mechanism
whereby your model will be able to watch
somebody playing the game and then you
allow the system also to start playing
the game so it pretty much starts from
scratch okay and as it moves forward it
it's at right at the beginning and the
system really knows nothing about the
game of chess okay so initially it is a
clean slate it just starts by observing
how you're playing so it will make some
random moves and keep losing badly but
then what happens is over a period of
time so you need to now
allow the system or you need to play
with the system not just one two three
four or five times but hundreds of times
thousands of times maybe even hundreds
of thousands of times and that's exactly
how alphago has done it played millions
of games between itself and the system
right so for the game of chess also you
need to do something like that you need
to allow the system to purchase and then
learn on its own over a period of
repetitions so i think you can probably
explain it to this much to this extent
and it should be sufficient
now this is another question which is
again somewhat similar but here the size
is not coming into picture so the
question is how will you know which
machine learning algorithm to choose for
your classification problem now this is
not only classification problem it could
be a regression problem i would like to
generalize this question so if somebody
asks you how will you choose how will
you know which algorithm to use the
simple answer is there is no way you can
decide exactly saying that this is the
algorithm i am going to use in a variety
of situations there are some guidelines
like for example you will obviously
depending on the problem you can say
whether it is a classification problem
or a regression problem and then in that
sense you are kind of restricting
yourself to if it is a classification
problem there are you can only apply a
classification algorithm right to that
extent you can probably let's say limit
the number of algorithms but now within
the classification algorithms you have
decision trees you have svm you have
logistic regression is it possible to
outright say yes so for this particular
problem since you have explained this
now this is the exact algorithm that you
can use that is not possible okay so we
have to try out a bunch of algorithms
see which one gives us the best
performance best accuracy and then
decide to go with that particular
algorithm so in machine learning a lot
of it happens through trial and error
there is no real possibility that
anybody can just by looking at the
problem or understanding the problem
tell you that okay in this particular
situation this is exactly the algorithm
that you should use then the questions
may be around application of machine
learning and this question is
specifically around how amazon is able
to recommend other things to buy so this
is around recommendation engine how does
it work how does the recommendation
engine work so this is basically the
question is all about so the
recommendation engine again works based
on various inputs that are provided
obviously something like uh you know
amazon a website or e-commerce site like
amazon collects a lot of data around the
customer behavior who is purchasing what
and if somebody is buying a particular
thing they are also buying something
else so this kind of association right
so this is the unsupervised learning we
talked about they use this to associate
and link or relate items and that is one
part of it so they kind of build
association between items saying that
somebody buying this is also buying this
that is one part of it then they also
profile the users right based on their
age their gender their geographic
location they will do some profiling and
then when somebody is logging in and
when somebody is shopping kind of the
mapping of these two things are done
they try to identify obviously if you
have logged in then they know who you
are and your information is available
like for example your age may be your
agenda and where you're located what you
purchased earlier right so all this is
taken and the recommendation engine
basically uses all this information and
comes up with recommendations for a
particular user so that is how the
recommendation engine work all right
then the question can be something very
basic like when will you go for
classification versus regression right
when do you do classification instead of
regression or when will you use
classification instead of regression now
yes so so this is basically going back
to the understanding of the basics of
classification and regression so
classification is used when you have to
identify or categorize things into
discrete classes so the best way to
respond to this question is to take up
some examples and use it otherwise it
can become a little tricky the question
may sound very simple but explaining it
can sometimes be very tricky in case of
regression we use of course there will
be some keywords that they will be
looking for so just you need to make
sure you use those keywords one is the
discrete values and other is the
continuous values so for regression if
you are trying to find some continuous
values you use regression whereas if you
are trying to find some discrete values
you use classification and then you need
to illustrate what are some of the
examples so classification is like let's
say there are images and you need to put
them into classes like cat dog elephant
tiger something like that so that is a
classification a problem or it can be
that is a multi-class classification
problem it could be binary
classification problem like for example
whether a customer will buy or he will
not buy that is a classification binary
classification it can be in the weather
forecast area now weather forecast is
again combination of regression and
classification because on the one hand
you want to predict whether it's going
to rain or not that's a classification
problem that's a binary classification
right whether it's going to rain or not
rain however you also have to predict
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow right now temperature is a
continuous value you can't answer the
temperature in a yes or no kind of a
response right so what will be the
temperature tomorrow so you need to give
a number which can be like 20 degrees 30
degrees or whatever right so that is
where you use regression one more
example is stock price prediction so
that is where again you will use
regression so these are the various
examples so you need to illustrate with
examples and make sure you include those
keywords like discrete and continuous so
the next question is more about a little
bit of a design related question to
understand your concepts and things like
that so it is how will you design a spam
filter so how do you basically design or
develop a spam filter so i think the
main thing here is he is looking at
probably understanding your concepts in
terms of what is the algorithm you will
use or what is your understanding about
difference between classification and
regression and things like that and the
process of course the methodology and
the process so the best way to go about
responding to this is we say that okay
this is a classification problem because
we want to find out whether an email is
a spam or not spam so that we can apply
the filter accordingly so first thing is
to identify what type of a problem it is
so we have identified that it is a
classification then the second step may
be to find out what kind of algorithm to
use now since this is a binary
classification problem logistic
regression is a very common very common
algorithm but however right as i said
earlier also we can never say that okay
for this particular problem this is
exactly the algorithm that we can use so
we can also probably try decision trees
or even support vector machines for
example svm so we will kind of list down
a few of these algorithms and we will
say okay we want to we would like to try
out these algorithms and then we go
about taking your historical data which
is the labeled data which are marked so
you will have a bunch of emails and then
you split that into training and test
data sets you use your training data set
to train your model that or your
algorithm that you have used or rather
the model actually
so and you actually will have three
models let's say you are trying to test
out three algorithms so you will
obviously have three models so you need
to try all three models and test them
out as well see which one gives the best
accuracy and then you decide that you
will go with that model okay so training
and test will be done and then you zero
in on one particular model and then you
say okay this is the model will you use
we will use and then go ahead and
implement that or put that in production
so that is the way you design a spam
file the next question is about random
forex what is random forest so this is a
very straightforward question however
the response you need to be again a
little careful while we all know what is
random forest explaining this can
sometimes be tricky so one thing is
random forest is kind of in one way it
is an extension
of decision trees because it is
basically nothing but you have multiple
decision trees and
trees will basically you will use for
doing if it is classification mostly it
is classification you will use the trees
for classification and then you use
voting for finding that the final class
so that is the underlyings but how will
you explain this how will you respond to
this so first thing obviously we will
say that random forest is one of the
algorithms and the more important thing
that you need to probably the
interviewer is waiting to hear is
ensemble learner right so this is one
type of ensemble learner what is
ensemble learner ensemble learner is
like a combination of algorithms so it
is a learner which consists of more than
one algorithm or more than one maybe
models okay so in case of random forest
the algorithm is the same but instead of
using one instance of it we use multiple
instances of it and we use so in a way
that is a random forest is an ensemble
learner there are other types of
ensemble learners where we have like we
use different algorithms itself so you
have one maybe logistic regression and a
decision tree combined together and so
on and so forth or there are other ways
like for example splitting the data in a
certain way and so on so that's all
about ensembl we will not go into that
but random foreign i think the
interviewer will be happy to hear this
word ensemble learners and so then you
go and explain how the random forest
works so if the random forest is used
for classification then we use what is
known as a voting mechanism so basically
how does it work let's say your random
forest consists of 100 trees
and each observation you pass through
this forest and each observation let's
say it is a classification problem
binary classification 0 or 1 and you
have 100 trees now if 90 trees say that
it is a 0 and 10 of the trees say it is
a one you take the majority you may take
a vote and since 90 of them are saying
zero you classify this as zero then you
take the next observation and so on so
that is the way uh random forest works
for classification if it is a regression
problem somewhat similar but only thing
is instead of vote what we will do is
sorry in regression remember what
happens you actually calculate a value
right so for example you are using
regression to predict the temperature
and you have 100 trees and each tree
obviously will probably predict a
different value of the temperature they
may be close to each other but they may
not be exactly the same value so these
100 trees so how do you now find the
actual value the output for the entire
forest right so you have outputs of
individual trees which are a part of
this forest but then you need to find
the final output of the forest itself so
how do you do that so in case of
regression you take like an average or
the mean of all the 100 trees right so
this is also a way of reducing the error
so maybe if you have only one tree and
if that one tree makes a error it is
basically hundred percent wrong or 100
right right but if you have on the other
hand if you have a bunch of trees you
are basically mitigating that
reducing that error okay so that is the
way random forest works so the next
question is considering the long list of
machine learning algorithms how will you
decide on which one to use so once again
here there is no way to outright say
that this is the algorithm that we will
use for a given data set this is a very
good question but then the response has
to be like again there will not be a
size fits all so we need to first of all
you can probably shorten the list in
terms of by saying okay whether it is a
classification problem or it is a
regression problem to that extent you
can probably shorten the list because
you don't have to use all of them if it
is a classification problem you only can
pick from the classification algorithms
right so for example if it's a
classification you cannot use linear
regression algorithm there or if it is a
regression problem you cannot use svm or
maybe now you can use svm but maybe a
logistic regression right so to that
extent you can probably shorten the list
but still you will not be able to 100
decide on saying that this is the exact
algorithm that i am going to use so the
way to go about is you choose a few
algorithms based on what the problem is
you try out your data you train some
models of these algorithms check which
one gives you the lowest error or the
highest accuracy and based on that you
choose that particular algorithm okay
all right then they can be questions
around bias and variance so the question
can be what is bias and variance in
machine learning so you just need to
give out a definition for each of these
for example a bias in machine learning
it occurs when the predicted values are
far away from the actual values so that
is a bias okay and whereas they are all
all the values are probably they are far
off but they are very near to each other
though the predicted values are close to
each other right while they are far off
from the actual value but they are close
to each other you see the difference so
that is bias and then the other part is
your variance now variance is when the
predicted values are all over the place
right so the variance is high that means
it may be close to the target but it is
kind of very scattered so the point the
predicted values are not close to each
other right in case of bias the
predicted values are close to each other
but they are not close to the target but
here they may be close to the target but
they may not be close to each other so
they are a little bit more scattered so
that is what in case of a variance okay
then the next question is about again
related to bias and variance what is the
trade-off between bias and variance yes
i think this is a interesting question
because these two are
heading in different directions so for
example if you try to minimize the bias
variance will keep going high and if you
try to minimize the variance bias will
keep going high and there is no way you
can minimize both of them so you need to
have a trade-off saying that okay this
is the level at which i will have my
bias and this is the level at which i
will have variance so the trade-off is
that pretty much attack you you decide
what is the level you will tolerate for
your bias and what is the level you will
tolerate for variance and a combination
of these two in such a way that your
final results are not way off and having
a trade-off will ensure that the results
are consistent right so that is
basically the output is consistent and
which means that they are close to each
other and they are also accurate that
means they are as close to the target as
possible right so if either of these is
high then one of them will go off the
track define precision and recall now
again here i think it would be best to
draw a diagram and take
the confusion matrix and it is very
simple the definition is like a formula
your precision is true positive by true
positive plus false positive and your
recall is true positive by true positive
plus false negative okay so that's you
can just show it in a mathematical way
that's pretty much uh you know that can
be shown that's the easiest way to
define so the next question can be about
decision tree what is decision tree
pruning and why is it so
basically decision trees are really
simple to implement and understand but
one of the drawbacks of decision trees
is that it can become highly complicated
as it grows right and the rules and the
conditions can become very complicated
and this can also lead to overfitting
which is basically that during training
you will get 100 accuracy but when
you're doing testing you will get a lot
of errors so that is the reason pruning
needs to be done so the purpose or the
reason for doing
decision tree pruning is to reduce
overfitting or to cut down on
overfitting and what is decision tree
pruning it is basically that you reduce
the number of branches because as you
may be aware a tree consists of the root
node and then there are several internal
nodes and then you have the leaf nodes
now if there are too many of these
internal nodes that is when you face the
problem of overfitting and pruning is
the process of reducing those internal
nodes all right so the next question can
be what is logistic regression uh so
basically logistic regression
is um one of the techniques used for
performing classification especially
binary classification now there is
something special about logistic
regression and there are a couple of
things you need to be careful about
first of all the name is a little
confusing it is called logistic
regression but it is used for
classification so this can be sometimes
confusing so you need to probably
clarify that to the interviewer if it's
really you know if it is required and
they can also ask this like a trick
question right so that is one part
second thing is the term logistic has
nothing to do with the usual logistics
that we talk about but it is derived
from log so that the mathematical
derivation involves log and therefore
the name logistic regression so what is
logistic regression and how is it used
so logistic regression is used for
binary classification and the output of
a logistic regression is either a zero
or a one and it varies so it's basically
it calculates a probability between zero
and one and we can set a threshold that
can vary typically it is 0.5 so any
value above 0.5 is considered as 1 and
if the probability is below 0.5 it is
considered as 0. so that is the way we
calculate the probability or the system
calculates the probability and based on
the threshold it sets a value of zero or
one which is like a binary
classification zero or one okay then we
have a question around k nearest
neighbor algorithm so explain k nearest
neighbor algorithm so first of all what
is a k nearest neighbor algorithm this
is a classification algorithm so that is
the first thing we need to mention and
we also need to mention that the k is a
number it is an integer and this is
variable and we can define what the
value of k should be it can be 2 3 5 7
and usually it is an odd number so that
is something we need to mention
technically it can be even number also
but then typically it would be odd
number and we will see why that is okay
so based on that we need to classify
objects okay we need to classify objects
so again it will be very helpful to draw
a diagram you know if you are explaining
i think that will be the best way so
draw some diagram like this and let's
say we have three clusters or three
classes existing and now you want to
find for a new item that has come you
want to find out which class this
belongs to right so you go about as the
name suggests it you go about finding
the nearest neighbors right the points
which are closest to this and how many
of them you will find that is what is
defined by k now let's say our initial
value of k was five
so you will find the k the five nearest
data points so in this case as it is
illustrated these are the five nearest
data points but then all five do not
belong to the same class or cluster so
there are one belonging to this cluster
one the second one belonging to this
cluster two three of them belonging to
this third cluster okay so how do you
decide that's exactly the reason we
should as much as possible try to assign
an odd number so that it becomes easier
to assign this so in this case you see
that the majority actually if there are
multiple classes then you go with the
majority so since three of these items
belong to this class we assign which is
basically the in in this case the green
or the tennis or the third cluster as i
was talking about right so we assign it
to this third class so in this case it
is uh that's how it is decided okay so k
nearest neighbor so first thing is to
identify the number of neighbors that
are mentioned as k so in this case it is
k is equal to five so we find the five
nearest points and then find out out of
these five which class has the maximum
number in that and and then the
new data point is assigned to that class
okay so that's pretty much how k nearest
neighbors work and that brings us to the
end of this live session on machine
learning engineer full course i hope it
was useful and informative thank you for
watching and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here